Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan. Wir stehen vor dem Salon und unterhalten uns jetzt erst nochmal ganz kurz über Wokeness. Denn es ist ja doch so, dass das Thema, das wir da angeschnitten haben, durch den Zeitaufmacher viele Leute interessiert hat. Und ich will nochmal ganz ausdrücklich betonen, dass ich mich wahnsinnig darüber ärgere, wenn irgendwelche Leute, die nie für linke Positionen eingestanden sind, im Sinne von Klassenkampf, jetzt schützen wir die Mieter oder sonst irgendwas, plötzlich sagen, ja, das ist irgendwie schlimm, dass die Linken gar nicht mehr an die Arbeiterklasse denken.
Das war doch deren Aufgabe.
Ja, da meine ich jetzt vor allem, ich muss es nochmal betonen, Iris Berben. Also Iris Berben, ihres Zeichens Multimillionärin in, ja, mehr durchschnittlichen als guten Filmen mitgespielt, mit einem sehr erfolgreichen Produzentensohn, die den Architekten der Agenda 2010, Frank-Walter Steinmeier, zum Bundespräsidenten mitgewählt hat. Gibt jetzt derzeit ein Interview und sagt dort, ja, das ist ja schade, dass die Linke gar nicht mehr sich um die Arbeiterklasse und um die Leute kümmert, die wenig Geld haben. Dann denke ich mir, aber wo hat Iris Berben das je getan und wo hat sie das durch ihre politischen Engagements jemals getan?
In ihren Thoughts und in ihren Prayers.
Ja, aber nachträglich da gereicht. Und das finde ich wirklich fatal. Und dass da so getan wird, als sei das jetzt diese dringend notwendige Kritik an den Linksliberalen, die jetzt von diesem Mittelspektrum ja kommt, das ist etwas, was anzugreiden ist. Denn ich will nochmal deutlich sagen, es gibt Wokeness, und ich will gleich mal so ein Beispiel dafür geben. Und es gibt auch vieles, was ich daran kritisiere. Und es waren ja ursprünglich, um das auch mal hier deutlich zu machen, Linke, die sagten, diese voke, linksliberale Identitätspolitik ist gar nicht richtig links. Zum Beispiel jemand wie Nancy Fraser hat ja schon früh sich eingemischt in diese Debatte und vom Ein-Prozent-Feminismus gesprochen. Also jenen, die Hillary Clinton unterstützen und selbst dick verdienen, die sagen, ja, wir brauchen Inklusion, die aber überhaupt natürlich nie über die Normalarbeitenden nachdenken, nie über die Alleinerziehenden oder so. Diese Kritik am Ein-Prozent-Feminismus kam von links. Viele weitere Beispiele, gerade so aus dem amerikanischen Jacobin-Gebiet, aus dem Kosmos um Bernie Sanders, war eine politische Bewegung und ist sie in gewisser Weise noch immer. Die sich mit so einem Wokeness-Begriff kritisch auseinandersetzte, der eigentlich nur meinte, wir brauchen ein bisschen Diversität in den Vorstandsetagen. Was ja auch eine Forderung ist, der man zustimmen kann. Nur war das ja dann häufig so, dass man dachte, das reicht auch schon. Und dann noch vielleicht ein paar Fernsehsendungen, die das abbilden. Und dann ist eigentlich doch alles super. Und genau diese neoliberale Variante wurde kritisiert. Und Nancy Fraser beschreibt ja dann auch diesen Pakt, der da passiert ist. Also, dass der Neoliberalismus natürlich in der Weise, indem er modernisiert, entwurzelt etc. Leuten, die es auch schaffen, erfolgreich sind, dann eine gewisse Diversität zugesteht. Beziehungsweise man das vielleicht sogar noch fördert, weil man herausgefunden hat, ach ja, genau in diesen Szenevierteln, wo so ein bisschen die Verrückten und Alternativen leben, da gibt es auch vielleicht tolle Ideen, die wir wirtschaftlich ausbeuten können. Da können wir auch eine tolle Start-up-Kultur errichten, dass dadurch so eine merkwürdige Ehe geschmiedet wurde zwischen einer tatsächlich progressiven gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung mit einer wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung, wobei dann die Linken, die eigentlich Linken immer wieder darauf hingewiesen haben, haben gesagt, naja, das ist aber doch nicht das, warum es eigentlich mal ging. Es ging ja mal um so etwas wie ökonomische Gleichheit. Es ging ja mal darum, dass man die Rechte der Arbeiter stärkt. Und das habt ihr alles vergessen, weil ihr euch nur noch mit diesen Themen auseinandergesetzt habt. Das war eine linke Kritik. Man kann die teilen oder auch wiederum kritisch sehen. Aber was jetzt gerade passiert ist, dass Leute, die sich nie um irgendwelche Probleme von Arbeitern oder sonst wem gekümmert haben, siehe Ulf Poschert oder sonst wer, daherkommen oder jetzt dann auch Iris Berben und sagen, ja, also die Linke, die hat die Arbeiter vergessen. So als hätten die gerne Arbeiterthemen thematisiert. Nein, die wollen ja auch die ganze Zeit nur über den Woken-Kulturkampf sprechen, damit sie nicht vielleicht mal über eine Erbschaftssteuer diskutieren müssen.
Also es ist ja kaum etwas leichter zu erklären als das, nämlich dass Superreiche da sitzen und eine Aufgabenteilung unterstellen, in der sich die Linken doch mal um die Arbeiter kümmern, damit es jemand tut. Und wenn die dann ihrem Auftrag, ihrem fremdbestimmten Auftrag, nicht nachkommen, dann ist ja wirklich blöd, weil dann kümmert sich ja gar nicht mehr jemand darum und das bedauert man dann. Das finde ich auch soweit amüsant. Wir haben ja heute mit Nils Kumkar und Polarisierung ein Buch, das all das adressiert und wir sind in diesem glücklichen Umstand, dass wir kurz sagen können, gestern bei Ronzheimer war Maurice Höfgen zu Gast, der natürlich super clever jede Ansprache mit und ihr die Linken und die Linken und du als linker Ökonom und so weiter einfach komplett ignoriert. Und stattdessen diese eine Lehre aus dem Buch, also es sind viele Lehren drin, aber eine kann man ja mal zentral setzen, man kommt aus der Polarisierung nicht raus, man muss nur die Pole halt neu definieren.
Ja.
Und wenn die einen mal kommen mit, aber das Bürgergeld, aber das Bürgergeld, aber das Bürgergeld als Thema und als Problem wird immer mitgeschleift, aber die niedrigsten Einkommenklassen, aber die niedrigsten Einkommenklassen, aber die müssen sich doch ein bisschen davon unterscheiden, dass es auch Bürgergeldempfänger gibt. Kommt Boris Hoefgen einfach, ignoriert das komplett und sagt, ja, Binnennachfrage, Wirtschaft allgemein, die Leute sind zu arm. Sie geben zu wenig Geld aus. Woran liegt das? Sie haben zu wenig Geld. Warum haben sie zu wenig Geld? Ihnen wird zu wenig Geld gegeben. Und macht eine ganz neue Kette auf, also neu für Ronsheimer und so, für uns natürlich.
Für uns nicht, aber...
Dann kann man sich das einfach mal 40 Minuten lang anhören. Und ganz am Ende kommt dann dieser kleine Joke, nur weil Ulf Poschert sich so vehement aufgeregt hat, dass der ehemalige Kanzleramtsminister Wolfgang Schmitt, also Olaf Scholz, Spezi, auf Maurice Höfgen zu sprechen kam. Nur weil sich Poschert so aufgeregt hat, saß Maurice Höfgen in dieser Sendung bei Ronsheimer. Was ja auch wieder bedeutet, offenbar kann man dieses, oder das sind so Bro-Podcaster, die sind alle unter sich und haben alle sechs Stille G-R-A-s einkommen, kann man offenbar hacken, indem man einfach nur das...
Ulf Poschert provoziert.
Genau.
Ja.
Denn zack, wird genau so über Bande gespielt, wie das ja in dem Kumkar super gezeigt wird, wie man halt über Bande spielen muss, statt einfach direkt die ganze Zeit empört zu sein. In der Hinsicht wollen wir es nicht ganz abhaken, was wir über die Linken in der Zeit gehört haben von Iris Berben. Aber eine Pointe aus dem Buch können wir kurz vortragen.
Willst du schon? Ja, bitte, dann mach doch ruhig.
Denn man kann es einfach direkt vorlesen. Es passt so gut, man muss gar nicht groß rahmen. Also wir lesen kurz aus Nils Kumkar, wir besprechen das Buch gleich zwei Stunden, da werden alle Details geklärt. Aber hier mal ein Snippet. Aus der Berichterstattung, mittlerweile kaum noch wegzudenken, sind Kommentare, die Umtriebe der politischen Rechten routiniert damit erklären, dass zunächst, oder zumindest gleichzeitig, die politischen Linken einen Konflikt eskaliert hätten, geheimnisvollerweise, da steht ein Klammer, geheimnisvollerweise gilt das Verhalten der Linken fast immer als ursächlich, indem sich nun die gesamte Gesellschaft außer den Rechten zu einem übermächtigen linken Block zusammenschließe. Also da steckt alles drin. Ursächlich ist immer, was die Linken tun. Wenn die Rechten dann darauf reagieren, konnten sie nicht andern. Genau, weshalb man auch besondere Vorsicht nehmen muss, wenn man ein ostdeutscher Wahlkämpfer ist. Weil die Ostdeutschen sind ja, wie wir alle wissen, nur Opfer, also ganz passiv. Und die haben ja vor zwei Sachen Angst. Entweder vor Ausländern oder vor einem Rechtsdruck. Und an beiden sind sozusagen die Linken schuld. Weil sie entweder die Ausländer ins Land lassen, oder, und zwar weil sie die Ausländer ins Land lassen und dann einen Rechtsdruck gibt, haben die Ostdeutschen wieder Angst vor den Nazis nebenan.
Ja.
So, und aus dieser Klammer kommt man natürlich nicht raus. Dass man aus dieser Klammer sehr gut rauskommt, beste Pointen in diesem Buch überhaupt, das ist wirklich ein Spektakel. Ich freue mich sehr, das gleich zu besprechen.
Ich will aber hier auch etwas, ein bisschen Salz reinstreuen, insofern, als manchmal der Eindruck jetzt entsteht, in einigen Debatten.
Darf ich kurz?
Kommt jetzt von der Unterbrechung eh an, Fange.
Ja, ich unterbreche sofort. Ich will einfach nur sofort den kognitiven Anker. Du hast jetzt Salz gesagt. Typischerweise hat man 300, 400 Gramm Essen auf dem Teller. Und das Salz ist so eine...
Es heißt ja Salz in die Wunde. Ja, genau.
Das heißt trotzdem, wir reden jetzt wirklich nur über das Salz. Ganz wenig. Der Anteil ist gering.
Ja, ich will das aber doch deutlich machen. Denn es ist schon so, dass wir in einigen Bereichen merkwürdige Debatten hatten. Und die waren auch zum Teil mal kurz nahe des hegemonialen Diskurses. So, ich will damit jetzt nicht sagen, und genau, gut, dass Iris Berben das aufgeschrieben hat. Nein, eben nicht. Aber wir können ja vielleicht uns mal auf ein Feld konzentrieren, auf das Feld Film. Da kenne ich mich nämlich ganz gut aus. Also wir hatten zum Beispiel Frances McDormand. Die wird für einen Oscar nominiert, gewinnt ihn auch, hält dann eine Rede, in der sie noch mal am Ende klarmacht. Zwei Worte muss man sich jetzt merken. Inclusion Rider. Inclusion Rider bedeutete, dass die Zusammensetzung von Cast und Crew die tatsächliche gesellschaftliche Vielfalt widerspiegeln soll. Nun, das bringt uns bei vielen Filmen in die Predouille, da die meisten Filme ja nicht einfach nur Gesellschaft widerspiegeln, sondern zum Beispiel von Gesellschaften handeln, die nicht so sind wie die unseren. Also, wenn man dort eine Diversität herstellen will, dass man sagt, die sollen aber jetzt alle so repräsentiert sein mit der Gesellschaft. Also, man guckt sich die Gesellschaft an, sieht die USA, sagt, die haben so und so viele Eingewanderte aus Südamerika, die haben so und so viele Afroamerikaner, so und so viele so. Und dann hätte ich das gerne in einem Film repräsentiert, und zwar vor und hinter der Kamera. Dann enge ich die Kunst extrem ein und verstehe überhaupt nicht, wie Fiktion funktioniert. Und das war ja auch das, was letztendlich zum Amazon Playbook geführt hat, Amazon Prime Playbook, wo ich auch hier dazu sage, ja, das wurde auch wieder abgeräumt. Aber das war damals ein sehr stark vorherrschender Diskurs. Wahrscheinlich werden sich viele auch erinnern an die Golden Globes 2020, die von Ricky Gervais moderiert wurden. Und Gervais hat ja dann sich über diese Voken lustig gemacht und hat gesagt, hör zu, wenn der islamische Staat morgen eine Filmproduktionsfirma aufmacht, dann werdet ihr eure Agenten anrufen und fragen, kann ich da vielleicht auch einen Job haben? Also er wollte sagen, das sind Opportunisten, die machen überall mit. Und ich finde diese Rede von Ricky Gervais bis heute noch sehr gut. Was ich jetzt Gervais wiederum vorwerfen kann, dass er dann danach nur noch auf dem Anti-Vogue-Ticket Shows gemacht hat und ganze Abende gestaltet hat, wo man sagen muss, du musst dann auch vielleicht bereits auch mal eine andere Seite, nämlich die andere Seite, zu kritisieren, zu persifieren, was er dann nicht gemacht hat. Wir haben mitunter obskure Debatten in der Filmlandschaft. Zum Beispiel wird jetzt immer wieder darüber diskutiert, ob Call Me By Your Name ein problematischer Film ist. Pass auf, weil Elio und Oliver, die sind ja ein Paar in diesem Film oder werden zu einem. Elio ist 17, Oliver ist 24. Das wird dann als besonders problematisch ausgelegt, wo man auch fragen muss, geht es noch? Wir hatten eine Petition, die verhindern wollte, dass die, wo die Ellen-Biografie, Autobiografie auf Deutsch erscheint. Ich bin, also die Leute können das machen, also können eine Petition auflösen. Ich bin ja für Meinungsfreiheit und bin nicht für eine Zensur. Ja, nur will ich sagen, dass das schon ein sehr, sehr vehementer Diskurs war, gegen den ich mich auch stellen würde. Und dass wir dann auch sehr viele Filme bekommen haben, bei denen man ja wirklich ganz merkwürdige Vokopolitik plötzlich hatte. Das letzte Beispiel war sicherlich Schneewittchen, dass man dort Schneewittchen nicht mehr von Zwergen sprechen lässt, weil man meint, man würde kleinwüchsige Menschen beleidigen, wenn gleich Zwerge Fabelwesen sind und nichts mit kleinwüchsigen Menschen zu tun haben. Dass wir diese ganzen Debatten haben, will ich hier nicht leugnen. Die Frage ist, wie hegemonial waren sie, wie massiv waren sie? Ich glaube, es gab eine Zeit, in der sich tatsächlich so ein progressives Hollywood und auch ein gewisses progressives Kapital von der Wall Street, wie Nancy Fraser das beschreibt, verbunden hat mit eben diesen Politiken, die ich jetzt hier angesprochen habe. Dass das aber natürlich nicht dazu führte, dass jetzt so etwas passiert wie unter Wolfram Weimar oder anderen, dass wird sich Verbote erlassen werden, dies und das. Aber dass man zum Beispiel diese Entwicklung kritisiert hat, finde ich absolut richtig. Und das geht so ein bisschen jetzt gerade verloren. Also manchmal wird jetzt von auch wiederum Linkstiberalen, die sehr auf dem Wokenticket rumgefahren sind, so suggeriert, als sei das eigentlich nur ein Hirngespinst gewesen, als hätten die Rechten sich das alles nur einfallen lassen. Und das stimmt so auch nicht.
Ich will jetzt nicht in die Falle tappen, die ich finde, Gilda Sahebi aus Versehen aufmacht, nämlich zu glauben, wir haben hier eine Emotionalisierung und gegen die hilft eine inhaltliche Aufklärung. Also ich will keine inhaltliche Aufklärung machen, sondern eher darauf hinweisen, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das Ricky Gervais Programm in fünf Jahren aussieht, wenn man sich nicht über Magamer lustig macht und so. Das könnte man jetzt schon machen, das ist ja alles lächerlich. Aber die Zeit, die du jetzt gerade markierst, da war es vielleicht sogar mal hegemonial, ist immer noch die Zeit von Nancy Pelosi, Joe Biden, Olaf Scholz und so weiter und so fort. Also wir haben es hier nicht mit nicht mit einer politischen Macht zu tun und Boris Johnson und so zu tun, sondern das läuft auf anderen Ebenen.
Nein, wir haben es auch nicht mit einer politischen Macht zu tun, die das jetzt, also das wird ja immer von Rechten dann so getan, als hätten die alle in den Ministerien gesessen und hätten das durchgeboxt. So ist es nicht. Es war ein anderer Zeitgeist und diesen Zeitgeist kann man ja auch kritisieren oder zumindest in Teilen kritisieren. Denn es war ja nicht alles an Vorschlägen, die gebracht wurden, falsch und gewisse Inklusionsprogramme zum Beispiel in der Filmlandschaft zu haben und auch andere Mechanismen, wie zum Beispiel Machtmissbrauch angezeigt werden kann oder überhaupt öffentlich gemacht werden kann. Dass das alles in die Öffentlichkeit muss, das ist ja absolut richtig und das ist ja auch tatsächlich der positive Effekt zum Beispiel von MeToo. Aber was wir dann doch gerade in der Kulturbranche stark gesehen haben und ich glaube, das liegt immer daran, dass man eigentlich ja weiß, mit der Kunst bewirkt man gar nicht so viel. Also das große Rat dreht man am Ende doch, wenn man im Finanzministerium sitzt und sagt, nee, gibt kein Geld oder man gibt Geld. Aber dadurch, dass man in der Kultur eigentlich in einer gewissen Ohnmachtsposition ist, glauben Leute, die in der Kultur sind, dass sie immer besonders vehement nach vorne treten müssen. Also sie sind die Ersten, die sagen, schließ den Luftraum über der Ukraine. Sie sind die Ersten, die wissen genau, wie der Nahostkonflikt einzuschätzen ist. Sie sind die Ersten, die sagen, zero, zero, Covid. Und genauso haben wir das natürlich auch bei den Inklusionsprogrammen, weil bei den, ich sage das jetzt mal, der Einfahrtheit halber, den Woken-Politiken erlebt. Und das hat dann mitunter obskure Blüten getrieben. Und ich will ein aktuelles Beispiel bringen, gar nicht, um da eine Einzelperson oder so vorzuführen, sondern was ich eigentlich zeigen will, ist eine gewisse Argumentation, die durch eine gewisse Wokeness hineingekommen ist, die ich für falsch halte und gegen die man sich auch stellen kann, ohne dass man in irgendeiner Weise in Verdacht gerät, konservativ rechts oder was auch immer zu sein. Und zwar Bayern 2 veröffentlichte auch so kurze Kultur-Clips bei Instagram und dort werden dann Statements abgegeben zur Literatur oder so. Hier ein Statement Thomas Mann. Wir hören da mal rein.
Man darf von Thomas Mann ja nicht halten, was man will, deswegen kurze paar Dinge vorneweg. Ja, er war ein Meister seines Fachs. Ja, er ist unglaublich wichtig für die deutsche Literaturgeschichte. Und ja, ich kann ihn und seine Werke trotzdem nicht ausstehen.
So, das ist ja erstmal was.
Wie man hat hier eine Meinung zu Thomas Mann? Geh mal auf die Straße und frag die Leute.
Wir hören da gleich mal weiter. Gut, sie mag offenbar die Werke von Thomas Mann nicht. Ich würde sagen, es gibt recht viele Leute, die das auch so sehen. Es ist wahrscheinlich nicht die Mehrzahl in der literarischen Welt, aber es gibt ja schon viele, die sich an Thomas Mann abgearbeitet haben. Mir würde jetzt zum Beispiel Maxi Billa einfallen. Wir hören mal weiter.
Thomas Mann hat die schlimmsten Fans nach Jesus und Fußball. Ich rede so viel über Literatur auf der Bühne, in meinen Büchern, im Internet. Und bei keinem anderen Autor wird mir so vehement unterstellt, zu dumm für seine Werke zu sein, wenn ich sage, dass ich sie nicht mag. Meinung über Thomas Mann zu haben, scheint überhaupt nicht erlaubt zu sein in der deutschen Literaturszene.
Da wird da so ein Pubkamerad aufgemacht. Wir sehen direkt diese Literaturszene. Wir sehen die die professoralen Typen, die da sitzen und sagen, jetzt redet da jemand über Thomas Mann und eine junge Frau. Kann das denn sein? Das ist ja nicht die Wirklichkeit. Also Thomas Manns Werk wird seit Jahrzehnten auch einer Kritik unterzogen. Zum Beispiel mit Blick auf antisemitische Tendenzen. Zum Beispiel mit Blick auf die unterschiedliche Qualität seiner Werke. Ja, viele können sich auf den Zauberwerk und auf auf Buddenbrooks einigen, aber sagen wir bei Dr. Faustus sieht das schon anders aus oder bei Königliche Hoheit. Wir haben es ja hier nicht mit einem Autor zu tun, der ohne Sono einfach nur abgefeiert wird. Das ist nicht der Fall. Und als ich mit der Anglistin, die Silvette Bronfen, zusammen zum Thomas Mann Jubiläum in der Schweiz sprach, sagte sie auch gleich nochmal am Ende, dass sie eigentlich tot in Venedig für ziemlich einen Kitsch hält. Ich habe ihr dann widersprochen, aber das ist durchaus ein Diskurs, der vorhanden ist. Wir hören mal weiter.
Du bist entweder Fan oder du hast es leider nicht ganz richtig verstanden. Aber ich habe es schon verstanden. Thomas Mann war ein Leidender. Dieses Leid war echt, aber er leidet in einem Arbeitszimmer, in dem er sich wochenlang von allen abschotten kann, weil er seine Frau alleine lässt mit der Familie und den Kindern und dem restlichen Leben. Er leidet in einem Haus, das er sich gekauft hat, weil er ein literarischer Superstar war.
Der Vorwurf, der jetzt gemacht wird, Thomas Mann war privilegiert. Ja, stimmt. Aber den Vorwurf kann ich ja genauso auch Virginia Woolf machen. Die ist aus gutem Hause und hatte jetzt finanziell keine großen Sorgen und konnte ihrer feministischen Literatur nachgehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob dieses Argument weit trägt, ist aber ein Typisches, das man in vielen Debatten gehört hat, vor allem dann von Linksliberalen vorgetragen, die oft selbst Privilegien hatten, sie aber verschleierten. Der ist privilegiert, der hat eigentlich gar kein Recht zu sprechen. Wir hören weiter.
Er leidet, während er seinen Nobelpreis poliert. Ja, schwul zu sein und es verstecken zu müssen oder das Gefühl haben, es verstecken zu müssen, ist massiv scheiße. Und ja, Depressionen ist Reichtum und Erfolg meistens komplett egal. Thomas Manns Werken wohnt ein unglaubliches Leid inne. Aber vielleicht sind wir langsam in einer Zeit angekommen, in der das Leid von reichen, erfolgreichen, weißen Männern einfach nicht mehr so wahnsinnig interessant ist. Und vielleicht sind wir dann langsam auch in einer Zeit, in der man Meinung über Literatur haben darf, obwohl sie von Thomas Mann ist.
Im Prinzip übernimmt ja hier die Woke-Seite die Rhetorik der Rechten. Das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen. Und ich sage mir, ja klar, darf man das sagen. Es gibt sehr viel Kritik an Thomas Mann. Und dass man jetzt sagt, ja, das Werk ist aber vielleicht auch gar nicht so wichtig, weil wir jetzt in einer anderen Zeit sind und uns nicht mehr mit den Problemen eines reichen, schwulen Mannes auseinandersetzen sollen, dann würde ich doch hier fragen, wie viele Werke von Thomas Mann sind denn wohl bekannt? Denn mir fällt zwar auf, dass die Homosexualität in seinem Werk immer wieder eine Rolle spielt und sie wird exponiert, thematisiert in Tonio Kröger und Toten Venedig. Aber bei den Buddenprugs, beim Zauberberg, bei Dr. Faustus, Königliche Hoheit, da weiß ich nicht, da wird man homosexuelle Tendenzen drin finden, aber das ist nun wirklich nicht das Thema dieser Romane. Es geht ja um ganz anders. Es geht um große, überzeitliche Menschheitsfragen. Zum einen, es geht um brillante Charakterbeschreibungen, um Figuren, die lange in Erinnerung bleiben, zum Beispiel auch weibliche Figuren, wie zum Beispiel Toni aus den Buddenprugs. Für alle Thomas-Mann-Leser würde ich fast behaupten, die Lieblingsfigur dort. Wir sind hier also in einem sehr eigenartigen Diskurs, wo man plötzlich die Identität des Autors und auch seine Privilegien und seine Leiden in Einsatz mit dem Werk, und damit ist aber auch das Werk vielleicht heute nicht mehr zeitgemäß, denn wir haben uns ja geschworen, uns nicht mehr nur mit privilegierten reichen weißen Männern zu beschäftigen. Und genau dieser Kurzschluss, und das ist ja nur exemplarisch hier, dass er jetzt nicht ein Spezialfall, den ich hier rausgepickt habe, dieser Kurzschluss, der war in sehr vielen kulturellen Kreisen, wenn nicht hegemonial, doch sehr dominant.
So, Grundbegriff, hegemonial, Diskurs, wie auch immer. Ich sehe so ein Video und denke mir, ja okay, ich sehe hier wieder ein Diskurs, noch irgendwas hegemonial ist. Eine junge Frau hat ein Video gemacht, über die Prinzipien und Hintergrundgedanken, die dazu führten. Werden wir gleich wunderbarste Aufklärung erleben.
Bei Kumkar.
Nun ist das Video da. Du siehst es und spielst sofort über Bande. So wie sie ja auch. Denn sie glaubt, es interessiert irgendjemanden noch, wie Thomas Mann gelesen wird, im Sinne von, Leute kennen Thomas Mann und haben aber noch eine fluide Meinung. Also sie ließen sich noch durch so ein Video beeinflussen. So, ist ja nicht so. Dieses Video wird von Leuten gesehen, die entweder diese Meinung schon hatten oder nicht haben. Und zu 99,9 Prozent, wenn das auf TikTok läuft oder so, fragen sich die Leute, wer ist Thomas Mann?
Also wir haben es ja hier nicht mit jemandem zu tun, der einfach ein Video gelandet hat. Das ist ja vom bayerischen Kultursender schlechthin, Bayern 2.
Der große bayerische Kultursender.
Ja, wenn die sich jetzt auf dieses Niveau begeben. Und das haben wir eben in ganz vielen, das haben wir in ganz vielen Bereichen in den vergangenen Jahren erleben müssen. Dass man immer sagte, ach so, Moment, privilegiert, weiß, dann kann das ja auch keine gute Literatur sein, können wir nicht in anderen Filmen besprechen. Also diese Kurzschlüsse, die hier gezogen werden, waren sehr typisch und die sind auch, ich meine, ich kenne Leute, die sind durchaus in ihrer ganzen Lebensweise dem Diversity-Lager zuzurechnen, die genau davon berichten, wie zum Beispiel Kulturförderungen nicht erteilt wurden, weil man irgendwelchen Kriterien nicht entsprach.
Auch so ein Punkt von Gilda Sahebi, alles über Bewusstsein zu leiern.
Das ist nicht Bewusstsein, das ist Realität in Deutschland, in der deutschen Kulturpolitik auch gewählt.
Aber wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen die Lockerungsübung, die uns Kumkar sagt, wir brauchen jetzt eine Lockerungsübung. Mein Buch ist eine Lockerungsübung, die müssen wir jetzt machen. Und ich will zum folgenden Beispiel machen. In Amerika regiert gerade, und es ist immer, der mächtigste Mann der Welt, von dem wir heute sagen, oh der ist aber irgendwas zwischen dumm und gefährlich, wie auch immer, er heißt Donald Trump. Der legt sich jetzt in Amerika mit der wichtigsten Kulturinstitution des Landes, nämlich den Nationalen Museen, Smithsonian, direkt um, er kann zu Fuß dahin laufen in drei Minuten. So, wir haben also der mächtigste Mann der Welt, und die nun ohne Frage kulturelle Hegemonie-Instanz der Welt Amerika, und dort die Gehirnzelle sozusagen, das Gehirn. So, und der Streit dreht sich darum, wer hängt dort in der Porträtgalerie. Denn die Chefin hat gesagt, die sind alle ziemlich pale and male, und das fanden die nicht so witzig im Weißen Haus, und haben gesagt, nö, also hier hängen bitte nur die allerwichtigsten und das waren halt Männer und Weiß und so weiter und so fort, und dann sagen die so, ne, wir können ja auch mal normale Amerikaner malen lassen und dahin hängen. So, das gesagt, wenn du jetzt auf die amerikanische Straße gehst und sagst, was sagen sie zur Porträtgalerie, sagen die 100% der Amerikaner, grob gerundet, Porträtgalerie, keine Ahnung, was, wovon reden sie und so. Ja, also wenn wir uns auf die Suche...
Ich beschreibe ja auch hier nur ein Spektrum im kulturellen Bereich. Und ich bin ja sehr viel in diesen Bereichen zu Hause. Ich weiß, dass das nicht im Sinne hegemonial ist, dass Pentagon und Washington darüber empfehlen, dass Pentagon und Weißes Haus darüber empfinden.
Aber Wolfgang, wie groß ist deine Angst, dass, wenn dieses Video irgendwo gespielt wird, dass dann jemand denkt, stimmt, Thomas Mann wird ja völlig falsch beobachtet, ich bin jetzt auf der Seite dieser Frau.
Nein, das ist ja unsinnig. Ich habe ja keine Angst davor. Ich sage nur, dass dieser Diskurs einer war und dem haben ja sehr viele auch widersprochen und auch zu Recht widersprochen. Wogegen ich mich wehre, ist das jetzt so getan wird, als hätte es diesen Diskurs nur in den Köpfen der Rechten gegeben. Dann würde ich sagen, nein, das stimmt nicht. Und es gab entsprechende Entscheidungen, wie Festivals laufen, wie Professoren besetzt werden und und und. Und es ist immer ein Kampf um die Ideen. Es ist immer ein Kampffeld um verschiedene Positionen. Ich male mir ja nicht irgendeine Welt aus, in der alles heil ist und alles schön ist, sondern ich weiß, dass das immer entsprechende Kämpfe sind. Und was ich aber erlebt habe, war, dass sehr viele, die aus einem linken, progressiven Lager kommen und darin auch weiterhin sind, ein Problem hatten mit einer gewissen Woken-Politik, ich nenne es der Einfachheit halber einfach Woken-Politik, die sich sehr stark in kulturellen Institutionen ausgebreitet hatte, die nicht mehr über z.B. Form sprechen wollte von Werken, sondern erst mal nur gefragt hat, von wem sind sie und wie ist die Identität etc. Und das hat viele auf die Palme getrieben. Ich will ein Beispiel geben, will das anonymisiert machen. Ich saß mit jemanden zusammen aus der Kulturbranche, der selbst das absolute Feindbild eigentlich der Rechten ist. Der lebt nicht heteronormativ, der lebt in einer Regenbogenfamilie. Verschiedene Konstellation will ich jetzt nicht alles ausbreiten. Und der sagte zu mir, als wir in einer Bar saßen, also zum Teil hatte man wirklich den Eindruck, da gibt es so einen Boken-Stalinismus. Der sagte, also jemand, der dir mit einer Perlenkette um den Hals gegenüber sitzt, spricht plötzlich so. Und natürlich war das eine Überschwitzung von ihm. Und er ist auch nicht irgendwie ein Feind gegen all das, was jetzt hier aufgeführt wurde. Ist nicht ein Feind dessen nur. Aber was er sagte, war, dass es diese Tendenz sehr stark gab. Was jetzt für mich aber nicht bedeutet, dass ich sage, diese Tendenz darf es nicht geben. Nur, würde ich sagen, man muss erst einmal angekennen, dass es sie gab. Und ich habe ja auch immer wieder in Filmanalysen gewissen Tendenzen widersprochen und habe auch dann zum Beispiel darauf hingewiesen, dass das wahrscheinlich wenig zweckdienlich ist, wenn man jetzt einfach nur Werken unterstellt, weil sie von dem und dem geschrieben wurden, sind sie nicht gut. Sondern es wäre ja viel interessanter, sich zum Beispiel auch in so einem Video mit dem Werk von Thomas Mann kritisch auseinanderzusetzen. Zum Beispiel, wie ich das mit Elisabeth Bronfen getan habe. Wir haben nämlich über Dr. Faustus gesprochen und haben zum Beispiel auch darauf hingewiesen, dass da doch eigenartige Darstellungen sind bezüglich Antisemitismus. Und das ist etwas, was ja stattfinden soll. Und ich bin ja nicht da in irgendeiner Weise, dass ich sage, lasst bitte alle auf dem Sockel stehen, alle großen Denker. Aber das ist, man hat es sich sehr leicht eine Zeit lang gemacht. Und die Beispiele, die ich eben genannt habe, so aus der Filmbranche eben auch. Und ich glaube, dass das ein Diskurs war, der auch sehr viele verärgert hat. Und damit muss man aber jetzt nicht bei Iris Berben ankommen und sagen, die Linken sind an allem schuld. Und deshalb überhaupt haben wir Donald Trump und die AfD.
Ich will es mal so sagen. Ich schreibe mir jetzt mal ein Orchideen-Dasein zu. In den Kreisen, in denen ich mich auch hobbymäßig noch über Sachen austausche, also wir in der Bar nach unseren Auftritten, wie wir beim Schnitzel essen, ich mit meinen ehemaligen Soziologie-Kommilitonen, wie auch immer. Das, was wir heute als Aufklärung bekommen, und das haben wir ja schon von Steffen Mauer gesagt bekommen, da geht der Kumkar sehr drauf ein, Leute haben eine ganz andere Meinung und eine ganzere Einstellung als das, was wir sehen, wenn die Kognition einmal durch die Kommunikation geleiert ist. Da greifen also kommunikationseigene Prinzipien, die irgendetwas abbilden, was man, wenn man demoskopisch an die Sache rangeht, gar nicht findet. So und in den Kreisen, in denen ich mich bewege und am liebsten aufhalte, war das, was du jetzt als ich nenne es mal Vogue, noch nie zu keinem Zeitpunkt etwas anderes als absolut lächerlich.
Ah ja, aber das ist ja eine andere Haltung, wenn du jetzt mit dieser Haltung zum Beispiel...
Und mit absolut lächerlich meine ich auch absolut ungefährlich.
Genau, aber wenn du jetzt mit dieser Haltung zum Beispiel auf eine Dokumenta gehst oder bei irgendeinem Theaterfestival...
Ich war ja auf der Dokumenta und ich hab mich über jedes Ding da ausgeholt. Also wirklich. Ich hätte überall einen schwarzen Link drüber gehangen. Das sah aus wie so eine Kinder Sache.
Ja, du bist aber in der Glück...
Ein Klassikkunstprojekt oder so sah das alles aus. Manches war echt von Müll in Kassel nicht zu unterscheiden.
So, aber genau mit diesen Aussagen würdest du erheblichen Ärger bekommen, wenn du in diesen Institutionen auf einem Podium wälztest und das sagst. Du kannst das hier so schön sagen.
Ich lasse mich diese Formate machen. Diesen Ärger würde ich nur bekommen, weil Leute mir unterstellen würden, dass auf mich jemand hört und diese Meinung übernimmt. Wenn es nur um meine Meinung ginge.
Ich glaube, man würde das schon als solches problematisieren.
Wenn sich jemand von mir als einzelner Wortbeitrag beleidigt fühlt. Da könnte ich mir vorstellen, der Künstler selbst, klar. Aber jemand anderes, der auch durch Zufall gerade in Kassel ist, ich dachte, ich fahre auf meine Dokumente, hört mich dann, wie ich mich darüber lustig mache und sage, oh, das ist aber krass. Das ist so eine krasse Meinung. Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das ist die Stimme eines privilegierten Europäers. Wir wollen hier nicht länger zuhören.
Wenn das auf der Ebene der, da hat jemand eine Meinung bliebe, wäre alles gut. Nur, weil wir immer unterstellen, der hat nicht nur eine Meinung, sondern, und das ist ja am Fernsehen sehr beliebt, war ja auch zum Beispiel, als wir Aufwachen-Podcast gemacht haben. Mein Ansatz war ja immer anders als der von Tilo Jung, weil Tilo ja immer der Meinung war, wir müssen jetzt die Aufwachen-Hörer darüber aufklären, was im Fernsehen eigentlich stattfindet. Weil der normale Fernsehzuschauer ist ja doof. Nur wir durchschauen es und müssen es jetzt aufklären. Und diese Unterstellung, dass die anderen ja alle leicht empfänglich für, was macht der Bayern Zwei da mit so einer komischen Frau, die irgendwas zu Thomas Mann sagt, die Realität ist, auf dieser Meinungs- und Einstellungsebene, es interessiert niemanden. Aber Realität ist eben auch, sagt Nils Kumkar, auf kommunikativer Ebene muss es gar niemanden geben, der auch weiß, wer Thomas Mann ist. Allein, dass diese Frau unterstellt mit dem Label, hier spricht Bayern Zwei. Es gäbe da einen Diskurs und es bestünde eine Gefahr der Hegemonie. Und morgen werden alle Bilder von Thomas Mann falschrum im Museum aufgehängt.
Okay, aber darum geht es ja jetzt noch nicht. Also ich sage, dass es Diskurs- und Kommunikationssimulationen gibt und dass das auch so funktioniert in einem Medienbetrieb, ist mir ja vollkommen klar. Ich wollte ja nur darauf hinweisen, dass es sie gab. Es war jetzt mitunter so, dass man so tat, als hätte das wirklich nur in den Köpfen der von Rechten stattgefunden. Und das ist so nicht richtig. Und was ich ja zum Beispiel feststelle ist, dass das ja eine Diskussion war, die wurde vor allem geführt, ich würde mal sagen von, also wenn wir ein paar Jahre zurückgehen, wo das so dieses Denken sehr präsent war. Ich sage jetzt nicht Berlin Mitte, meins aber auch. Also es wurde geführt in Ende.
Also ich finde, wir können jetzt mal alles namentlich nennen.
Nein, lass es mich mal sagen.
Aber nicht mehr virtuell bleiben, mach es konkret.
Nein, das war so Ende 30, Anfang 40, Ende 40. Das war so eine bestimmte Gruppe von Leuten, die machten ein bisschen Kultur, ein bisschen Podcast, ein bisschen Marketing und so weiter. Und für die war das jetzt plötzlich, nachdem sie irgendwie gemerkt haben, ach, ich bin ja selbst auch relativ privilegiert, so ein Thema. Und da sind die auch unglaublich drauf rumgeritten und haben sich dann nochmal so selbst verwirklichen können, so eine zweite Pubertät durchlaufen, sage ich mal. Wenn ich jetzt aber zum Beispiel mit jüngeren Leuten zusammen bin, also die Anfang 20 sind, für die ist das überhaupt in dieser Weise gar kein Thema. Die sind viel offener sowieso schon an sich. Und für die ist das, also in dem Bereich, in dem ich mich jetzt befinde. Also beispielsweise komme ich ja gerade aus Mainz zurück. Ich war gestern Abend in Mainz. Da wurde der wunderbare Billy Wilder-Film Sunset Boulevard gezeigt. Und ich habe dann darüber gesprochen. Da sitzt natürlich niemand, da sitzt nicht ein 22-jähriges Publikum und sagt, das finde ich aber jetzt problematisch, dass wir dann einen Film von einem alten weißen Mann oder so gucken. Nicht überhaupt. Vielleicht denkt sich das trotzdem. Nein, es ist ein völlig anderer Diskurs. Es sind ganz andere Fragen, die kommen. Es ist eine ganz andere Diskussion. Und da gebe ich dir recht, es gab da eine Diskurssimulation und die war auch eine, die sehr elitär war, denn sie wurde von Oscar-Kandidaten und von irgendwelchen Leuten, die gute Stellen in irgendwelchen Fernsehanstalten haben oder so geführt. Und das ging sehr an der Sache vorbei. Ich wollte nur mit diesen Beispielen aus der Filmbranche, weil ich mich da ein bisschen auskenne, darauf hinweisen, dass es diese Entwicklung tatsächlich gab. Manches war davon positiv, aber vieles war auch zu kritisieren. Und dass dies auch weiterhin stattfinden darf, auch wenn gerade Donald Trump der mächtigste Mann ist oder so, finde ich, sollte auch dazu gehören. Also man kann nicht nur so tun, als gäbe es da so ein Problem, das ist das Einzige, was wir noch reden können.
Also Filmbranche ist schlagkräftig, weil da kommen echte Casting-Entscheidungen, echte Budget-Entscheidungen aufgrund echter Management-Entscheidungen zustande. Und denen kann man unterstellen, dass sie so ein Fähnchen im Windzeitgeist folgen und dann passiert so was wie dieses Playbook. Ich will nur als abschließenden Gedanken, bevor ich noch Clips, die uns dann zum Buch führen, sagen, wenn wir Hoss und Hopf hören, arbeiten die sich immer an irgendetwas ab. Die haben zuletzt über Abtreibung gesprochen, da haben sie ein Video gespielt, von dem sie vorher sagten, so war es ja nie die Probleme, die da beschrieben wurden, aber wir spielen es mal trotzdem, weil wenn es so wäre, dann wäre das ja voll krass und dann wäre das Video auch voll richtig. Und es wird genauso fast wörtlich gesagt. Also völlig absurd. Wir lesen in diesem Buch wieder, Curtis Jarvin hat so diese Cathedral-Vorstellung. Wir lesen diese Aufklärung über, die Linken sind immer schuld, weil die Mitte sich vorstellt, dass die Rechten nur erfolgreich sind, weil die Linken irgendwas machen, aber wir sind ja die Neutralen. Also jeder ist in so einem imaginären Dings verfangen. Wenn ich aber Diskurses suche und ich sie ja auch finde zum Thema, was weiß ich, Klimawandel. Richard David Brecht sagt, wir werden das Jahr 2200 nicht überleben, die Menschheit. So, dann haben wir hier ein Thema gesetzt, das relativ unabhängig, also eine Wahrhaftigkeit, relativ unabhängig davon hat, wie das jetzt problematisiert wird im nächsten Robin-Alexander-Macht-Im-Markt-Wechsel-Podcast, eine Aufklärung darüber, für wen das jetzt ein Problem ist und warum man dann überbande so und so. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch total verständlich. So, also wir haben unhintergehbare, einfach Diskurse, von denen ich sage, die sind legitim. Und dann haben wir Diskurse, die wir davon unterscheiden müssen, wie zum Beispiel, da irgendeine junge Frau äußert sich.
Es geht mir auch gar nicht immer um dieses Video, da muss man gar nicht drauf rumreiten. Aber du hast jetzt eben gesagt, du hast dich drastischer zur Dokumenta geäußert, als ich das wahrscheinlich getan hätte. Ich habe die nicht besucht, aber wahrscheinlich in dieser Drastik hätte ich mich gar nicht ausdrücken. Du hast gesagt, das meiste war von Müll nicht zu unterscheiden und da hätte man Tücher drüber hängen sollen.
Das sah aus wie in unserer Waldorfschule, in der dritten Klasse damals.
Und da ist doch die interessante Frage, die sich daran anschließt. Warum ist es zu diesen Werken oder zu der Auswahl dieser Werke gekommen? Und da würde ja eine Kritik ansetzen und die hat dann auch eben mit gewissen, zum Beispiel identitätspolitischen Paradigmen zu tun, die sehr dominant sind, zum Beispiel bei Kuratoren der Dokumenta oder anderen Kuratoren, die dann zu kritisieren sind. Und das ist aber nicht etwas, was ja von Rechten oder so nur gekommen ist. Die sind später erst auf den Zug aufgesprungen. Sondern es gab von links auch eine Kritik an solchen Dingen. Es gab von links viel früher eine Kritik an einem wohlfeilen Diversity-Diskurs, der die eigentlichen Ausbeutungsverhältnisse ignoriert. Dietmar Dard hat hier in dem Band, den ich mit Anne-Christine rausgegeben habe, selbst schuld, auch darüber noch mal einen Text geschrieben. Und das ist nun wirklich niemand, der sagt, ich bin anti-vogue oder so. Das ist ja völlig unsinnig. Und da muss man sich ja auch nicht eingemeiden lassen da. Aber diese Art der Auseinandersetzung war etwas, was zum Teil äußerst schwierig wurde. Und das sind aber nur, wie du richtig sagst, spezielle Bereiche. Wenn man nicht auf der Republik ist, wird man es kaum mitbekommen.
Ich bin für vehement. Wir haben diese Lockerungsübung. Demgegenüber, man kann auch eine Festigungsübung machen, dass man sagt, also in der Porträtgalerie der amerikanischen Geschichte hängen nur Männer, weiße Männer, weil das waren die Präsidenten, die CEOs, wer auch immer. So, dann kommt die Museumsleitung und sagt, wir könnten ja auch mal normale Amerikaner abbilden. Dann wird irgendwie so eine Idee, also so eine Person halt, und dann hängt halt ein Zettel dran. So sahen übrigens 90% der Leute, dann hat man so eine Schürze und jemand steht in der Küche oder wie auch immer. So, wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, und das ist eben jetzt wichtig für die Zukunft, dass man nicht wieder in dieselbe Falle tritt, denn wir wollen ja nicht Maga und März so besiegen, dass das Pendel wieder überschlägt. Das wäre ja total doof, wenn es immer hin und her pendelt. Wir können nicht immer nur zwischen Weltkrieg und Vereinten Nationen hin und her pendeln und alle 50 Jahre das wiederholen. Deswegen müsste man jetzt, und da ist Kumkars Buch eben sehr gut, das werden wir dann gleich lesen, einfach ein paar Pflöcke einschlagen. Wenn wir sagen, in der Geschichte spielen bislang Männer nur eine große Rolle, weil, und dann kommt es eben auf Raffinesse und wissenschaftliche Unterstützung an, Frauen andere Rollen zugesprochen bekommen haben, die wir aber nicht auf kommt in die Porträtgalerie hoch einschätzen.
Genau, das waren die patriarchalen Strukturen.
Genau, dann muss das einfach mal ein thematischer Fakt sein, genau wie koloniale Ausbeutung und so weiter, die man sich nicht nur weil irgendwelche Maga- oder Märzleuter und so weiter unzufrieden sind, wie auf amerikanische und deutsche Geschichte geschaut wird. Also wir haben ja auch die Nazi-Zeit gut abgeschüttelt, obwohl alle so traurig waren, dass wir einen ganz wichtigen Krieg verloren haben. Ja, wir blicken ja heute anders darauf. Dann muss man das thematisieren können und zwar aus der, ich sag jetzt mal richtigen Seite, so, dass man sie ein bisschen abschottet gegen die Prinzipien der Kommunikation der anderen Seite. Und das geht. Ja. Und das geht aber nicht, indem man einfach, und da muss ich leider sagen, das Buch von Gilda Sahebi ist nicht so gut, einfach das Vorzeichen umdreht und sagt, da halten wir uns voll dagegen und klären mal inhaltlich auf. Ihr seid ja viel zu emotional. So, ja. Das ist nicht der richtige Weg. Also wir haben heute ein Buch, das ist sehr gut beschreibt und dann haben wir als Kontrast dazu ein Buch, das ist halt, in das ein oder andere Fettnäpfchen tritt, von dem uns Kumkar sagt, nein, da nicht reintreten. Dann ist einfach nur, dann geht es halt weiter wie bisher. Dann haben wir einfach nur die richtige Polarisierung im Vergleich zur falschen, obwohl Kumkar ja selbst sagt, wir könnten durchaus richtig polarisieren, denn aus der Dichotomie kommen wir ja sowieso nicht raus. Also in der Ansicht, heute haben wir die Chance, echte Aufklärung zu leisten über dieses sehr gute Buch von Nils Kumkar. Ich will es nochmal sagen, wir besprechen es gleich.
Dann machen wir das.
Jetzt aber politische Kommunikation, drei Clips, oder vielleicht nur zwei, je nachdem, wie die Zeit läuft. Esra Klein erklärt hier, finde ich, wie immer, sehr aufgeklärt, was Kandidaten im politischen Betrieb jetzt kommunikativ leisten müssen, um nicht einfach anti-mager zu sein oder anti-vogue, weil die Unterstellung, dass die anderen einfach alle mager sind, nein, nein, nein, das ist ja Triggerpunkte, wenn man sie wirklich fragt, die Leute, die sind nicht alle mager. Das schaukelt sich nur kommunikativ so hoch. Also muss man jetzt kommunikativ runterschaukeln, um die Leute abzuholen, wo sie sind, nämlich nicht mager. Und er kommt über diese Beispiele jetzt in New York und so. Mandami, wie kommunizieren die und warum ist das richtig?
What you need is not like the one recipe. You need candidates who are compelling on their own. And one reason they are compelling is that they are compelling on their own.
Die also sich nicht abgrenzen von, das finde ich blöd, ich bin der Antitrumpf, sondern ach so, du bezahlst zu viel im Supermarkt, dann mache ich dir selber einen Supermarkt.
Also nicht Hillary Clinton. Hillary Clinton war das einzige Versprechen, ich bin nicht Donald Trump.
Und ich bin eine Frau. Genau. Also das nützt einem gar nichts, dass Hillary Clinton eine Frau ist.
Compelling on their own is that they know who they are and they're willing to stand up for it. And sometimes that is to the left of where, you know, much of the electorate is comfortable with them being, and sometimes it's like a little bit to the right, but there is something about being willing to unleash the energy of some conflict around yourself, right, not being so...
So, der Konflikt, aber der sich um die Person dreht, also nicht jetzt große thematische und so weiter, sondern die Person muss unterscheidbar sein von anderen Angeboten im politischen Diskurs und dann ihr Angebot voranstellen, das natürlich in der Politik im Konflikt, daraus kommen wir nicht raus, das sagt ja Nils Kumkar auch, sehr eindrächtig, der Konflikt ist der maßgebliche Treiber.
Careful and cautious and poll-tested and mealy-mouthed, that everybody feels when they hear you talk. Like the first thing happening in your mind is a filter that is catching anything you might say that anyone might not like first. People really sense when they're not quite talking to you.
Ja, die Leute spüren, wenn du nicht direkt zu ihnen sprichst, sondern dieses Spiel über Bande machst. Da hinten ist noch eine Laufkundschaft, die ist noch zu überzeugen. Und zwar die 50-jährigen Eingewandneten aus Indien, die bisher noch nicht abgeholt wurden von Maga. Da haben wir noch Potenzial. Und dann hältst du eine Rede zum Thema. Blablabla. Und alle stehen vor dir und fragen, was gerade? Ich verstehe es nicht. Das ist nicht meine Wellenlänge.
And when you talk to Mamdani or you hear him talking, you're talking to him. When you talk to Gaigo or you hear him talking, you're talking to him. Or that's true for Angie Craig, right? That's true for Lee Slotkin. There are a lot of really good candidates, but one thing that those candidates tend to have is an authenticity. And you watch me like, yeah, I would keep listening to this person.
So, das war auch das Erfolgsding von Christian Lindner. Du verdienst über 100.000 Euro im Jahr oder möchtest es, ich senke deine Steuern. Punkt. Das war das ganze Angebot. Tiefer wurde der Diskurs nie mit den Wählern der FDP. Jetzt hören wir im Kontrast dazu Lars Klingbeil, der nichts davon beherzigt, von nichts eine Ahnung hat, sondern einfach nur, ich bin ja als Finanzminister und so. Und die Vorzüge seiner Finanzpolitik und seiner Mitgliedschaft in der SPD uns erklärt. Und der Clip geht 26 Sekunden und ist Tiefschlaf für alle.
Das oberste Ziel dieser Regierung, das will ich noch mal betonen, ist, dass wir Arbeitsplätze sichern, dass wir Deutschland auf den Kurs des wirtschaftlichen Wachstums zurückbringen und dafür auch sorgen, dass am Ende die Arbeitsplätze hier sicher sind und neu geschaffen werden können. Wir verbessern das Leben der Menschen. Wir sorgen mit Investitionen dafür, dass neue Jobs entstehen können, dass es faire und bessere Löhne gibt und dass das Wohnen in unserem Land ein gutes Stück wieder bezahlbar wird.
Aber auch nur ein gutes Stück wieder.
Ein gutes Stück bezahlbar, was auch immer. Man hört das und man ist sofort wütend. Und man sucht geradezu, kann bitte jemand meine Wut aufgreifen? Und dann steht natürlich die AfD da und sagt, wir hassen ihn noch mehr als du.
Und das will ich schon mal vorwegnehmen. Wir müssen gleich mal über die Mitte sprechen. Das hier ist so ein Mittelsprech, der macht mich so aggressiv, der radikalisiert mich in einer Weise, wie ich es kaum aussprechen kann.
Ja, aber selbst hier, also 16 Prozent, das ist weder hegemonial noch sonstig. Das ist einfach nur durch Demokratie-Mathematik in Finanzminister-Posten gekommen.
Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, aber trotzdem...
Selbst in der Partei nur 60 Prozent.
Aber trotzdem ist er jetzt dort.
Ja, genau.
Also er hat jetzt diese Macht da.
Ja, aber das ist eben dieser Punkt. Nur weil wir etwas sehen und alle unterstellen sogar, die verfassungsrechtliche, wissenschaftliche Literatur sagt, der ist ganz mächtig, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das hegemonial ist. Sondern das ist Anflussfähigkeit.
Ja, aber doch, das ist hegemonial.
Ja, wenn du jetzt nur über Diskurses redest. Funktional begründet, ja. Aber in der Ansprache...
Aber der hat ja wirkliche Macht. Also das ist ja eben der Punkt, den du eben richtigerweise gemacht hast. Wenn da jemand gesagt hat, ich finde Call Me By Your Name problematisch und man sollte den Film nicht mehr zeigen oder so. Das war nicht hegemonial. Das waren einzelne Stimmen und die wurden vielleicht dann sozialmedial verstärkt. Aber hier sitzt ja jemand in der entsprechenden Behörde, der sagt, wir bringen irgendwas ein Stück weit voran und wir wissen ganz genau, er tut das nicht.
Genau, dann ziehen wir nämlich mal die, das ist wirklich mächtig, dann ziehen wir mal Bilanz in vier Jahren, wie viel Stücke die Mieten gesunken sind. Und schließen daraus mal, wie mächtig dieser Mann war. So, jetzt nochmal Esra Klein.
Naja, weil er es gar nicht will. Also das wäre ja, das ist ja schon eine Unterstellung.
Darin steckt schon mal diese große Lüge, nur weil jemand etwas sagt, heißt das noch lange nicht und so weiter. So, Esra Klein zu genau dieser Frage.
Was ich nur sagen will, diese Art des Sprechens von Lars Klingbeil und ganz vielen anderen und das verbindet ihn ja auch mit CDU und mit anderen Parteien, die so sprechen. Das ist ja eines, das auf Mäßigung aus ist, das so sagt, hier spricht die Vernunft, alles in Ruhe und Gelassenheit. Darin steckt selbst ein Extremismus, würde ich sagen. Das ist auch ein Wir und die anderen.
So und jetzt, wie sollte man eigentlich sprechen?
One other thing I want to say about Mondani, that I've always found to be a big part of his appeal and what makes him a real political talent, is he feels very motivated by his sympathies and not his resentments. That's not, in my view, how Donald Trump feels, but it's also not how a lot of people on the left feel. Oftentimes people in politics, they feel more motivated by who they hate than who they're in this for. And Mondani, who took a lot of flack, right? You know, who got a lot of unfair attacks. Nevertheless, there is a fundamental friendliness to his campaign. A sense that even if you disagreed with him, he didn't hate you. He wasn't looking to push you out of his circle. He wanted you in there. He wanted you in that tent. And that idea that there is a political value to what you might call like a high political theory level pluralism and what you might call a normal human being, like friendliness and openness to other people, I think that's easy to underestimate. I think that a real failure of the left, and I don't just mean like the democratic social left, I mean like the broad, you know, left of the center, was developing a politics that seemed like it was more interested at times, and a communication style, and figure out who wasn't on our side, and making that clear, than inviting people, even people who didn't agree with us, in, at least halfway. And Mamdani, though he's into a lot of people's left, he doesn't feel that way. He's looking for where you agree with him, not where, you know, he can kick you out.
So, nun ist so. Kumkar klärt uns gleich auf, ja, die Politik führt zu Kollektivbindenden Entscheidungen. Und die Willensbildung innerhalb der Partei ist so auf Gemeinwohl ausgerichtet. Und das ist schon ein sehr inkludierendes Kollektivbinden, das gilt ja wohl für alle, ja, stimmt. Aber es wird immer auch Leute geben, die mit den Entscheidungen unzufrieden sind. Und der Trick ist, sie dann trotzdem daran zu binden. Und diese Gemeinwohlsache ist nun, klar, Wahlkampfrhetorik. Denn das, was Esa Klein hier sagt, hat eine dunkle Seite, über die uns Kumkar gleich aufklärt. Und das lautet wie folgt, wenn du eine politische Ansprache für jemanden machst und sie so ehrlich meinst, dass jemand sich wirklich verstanden fühlt und sagt, genau das ist, was ich brauche, ich nehme dein Angebot wahr und an, dann funktioniert es nur, wenn dieses Angebot für jemand anderen, pro antin Kumkar, gefährlich ist. Nur dann funktioniert es. Was bedeutet, Donald Trump war nicht aus eigener Kraft durch die Unterstützung seiner Base so erfolgreich, sondern weil er für die anderen so gefährlich schien, hat er mobilisiert. Er hat also klar polarisiert. Und Kumkar sagt, wir kommen aus diesem Polarisierungsgebot nicht raus, denn wir können keine Politik über Langeweile machen. Das geht einfach nicht. Vernunft, Gemeinwohl, kollektive Bindung, es ist alles Langeweile. Niemand interessiert sich für den Ablauf des Verwaltungsprinzips, wo dann wirklich kollektiv bündende Entscheidungen hergestellt werden. Sondern erst, wenn längst entschieden wurde, heißt es, ach ne, das finde ich aber ganz blöd jetzt.
Du hast völlig recht, wir werden jetzt gleich darüber diskutieren. Es gibt noch einen anderen Ausweg, aber den verrate ich nachher. Und den verrät Kumkar auch so mal ganz kurz. Es gibt einen anderen Ausweg, den ich nicht als meinen Ausweg vielleicht definieren würde, aber der ist auch noch da. Und der hat mir am meisten eigentlich zu denken gegeben, von allem, was ich so gelesen habe.
Was lesen wir noch?
Wir sprechen über Polarisierung von Nils Kumkar. Das steht also an und diskutieren dann auch Verbinden statt Spalten, eine Antwort auf die Politik der Polarisierung von Gilda Sahebi. Man kann jetzt, wo wir die beiden Sachen gelesen haben, durchaus sagen, das ist das Gegenbuch zu Kumkar. Außerdem gibt es von mir wieder einen Musik-Tipp, diesmal Tchaikovsky. Dann habe ich den neuen Roman von Leif Randt gelesen, der heißt Let's Talk About Feelings. Dein Buch Allegro Pastel war ja ein großer Erfolg. Und jetzt schauen wir, was Leif Randt zu erzählen hat in seinem neuen Roman, der in der ganz nahen Zukunft spielt. Aber die Wirklichkeit ist ein bisschen verschoben, denn die Bundesrepublik wird von einer Bundeskanzlerin regiert und das ist so ein progressives Lager, aber das ist kein politischer Roman in dem Sinne. Dann habe ich Gedichte gelesen und zwar von...
Laut oder leise?
Ich lese sie gleich mal laut, habe sie aber auch leise gelesen. Zheng Jiaoqiang, ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig ausgesprochen, ist eine chinesische Wanda-Arbeiterin, die irgendwann anfing, Gedichte zu schreiben, die dann Erfolg hatten, auch in China, auch übersetzt wurden in andere Sprachen. Und jetzt ist ein Band von ihr erschienen, der heißt Erzählung von den Konsumgütern. Und sie macht Lyrik aus den Produktionsprozessen, aus den Menschen, die dort arbeiten, wirklich sehr, sehr beeindruckend. Außerdem habe ich einen Text gelesen, der sich damit beschäftigt, was hat eigentlich Donald Trump in Venezuela vor? Ja, wir haben das ja von Recht gehört.
Die Schiffe sind schon unterwegs.
Und jetzt sind schon Schiffe unterwegs. Und es wurde schon ein Schiff torpediert. Was ist da los? Ich habe also eine Analyse dazu dabei. Und wir fragen uns, wie war das jetzt eigentlich bei diesem Will Smiths Konzert, bei den Konzerten, die er hatte in Europa. Da ist ein Video bei YouTube erschienen mit begeisterten Fans. Und es wird darüber diskutiert, ist das etwa alles AI generiert? Und uns sagt aber hier ein Autor, nee, es ist eigentlich noch viel schlimmer.
Okay, sehr gut, da bin ich gespannt. Wir lesen den Brief von Frauke Brosius-Gersdorf. Ich will die Poente gleich verraten. Das ist im Grunde ein Bewerbungsschreiben auf das Amt der Bundespräsidentin.
Okay.
Also meine Lesung. Dann eine sehr große Studie. Die ganze Welt wurde untersucht. Wir haben doch alle dieses u-förmige Zufriedenheitsbild. Wir werden geboren, sind relativ zufrieden. Dann kommen die Mühlen der Ebene. Wir müssen Kinder erziehen und Ausbildung und alles. Wir sind sehr unglücklich und am Ende wieder fröhlich.
Das gibt es nicht mehr.
Aber jetzt wird einfach unzufrieden geboren. Und danach kann man hoffen, dass es besser wird, aber schwierig. Und da wurde wirklich Stichprobe 1,7 Millionen und so. Da geht es weltweit zur Sache. Und dann ein Text. Ich trage ihn vor allem vor, um Fragestellungen zu formulieren zum Thema Homophobie. Denn die New York Times klärt auf über Donald Trumps Big Gay Government. Es gibt schwule Bande in der Republikanischen Partei und der neuen Regierung, die ganz offen sagen, das ist unser Club, so heißen wir, hier gibt es Mitgliedschaftsregeln. Ich bin zwar hier nur so Unterstaatsrekretär, aber ich bin der Pascha im Net Club, den du gleich kennenlernen wirst. Genau, Peter Thiel macht immer große Partys, zu der man... also eingeladen bei Peter Thiels Party ist so ungefähr wie Stanford-Zusage. Danach ist das Leben anders.
Und warum Homophobie? Also dagegen richten sich dann andere in der republikanischen Partei?
Zum einen geht es darum, im Text selbst, dass es natürlich noch Schwule in Washington gibt, der schwulsten Staat der Amerikas, die mit denen nichts zu tun haben wollen. Und sich wirklich abgrenzen davon. Wenn die die auf, wo man sich herum trifft, sehen und das herausfinden, dass die aus diesen ist sofort Ende Gelände. Und ich möchte eine allgemeine Argumentation soziologischer Natur, warum es überhaupt mal zur Homophobie kam oder warum auch Frauen ausgeschlossen sind. Warum hat die Kirche sich immer so krass zölibärter organisiert und so? Will ich jetzt noch mal aufwerfen, da wir sehen, dass hier, ich will es nicht sagen, geheime, aber schwule Bande in Regierungsnähe befinden. Denn da gibt es ja historische und funktionale Argumentationen, die zumindest mal ein paar Pointen bereithalten, wenn nicht sogar einiges aus der Vergangenheit erklären. Aber sei gespannt.
Dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich im Salon. Und wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, dass wir ja dann in diesem Monat uns nochmal hören. Es gibt ja noch den Live-Salon, und der wird selbstverständlich dann auch noch diesen Monat veröffentlicht. Ich will noch ganz kurz darauf hinweisen, dass ich am 14.9. in Krefeld zu Gast bin. Da ist eine Podiumsdiskussion über Kunst. Ist Kunst anachronistisch geworden? Ist da die Frage. Und dann bin ich im Thomas Mann Museum, im Buddenbrooks Museum, so muss ich richtig sagen, in Lübeck die Woche darauf zu Gast. Das findet man aber auf meiner Homepage dann. Und da geht es dann um auch Männlichkeitsbilder bei Thomas Mann.
Das würde ich ja mal problematisieren. Was müsste ich da bayerischer Rundfunk überhaupt ein bei Thomas Mann?
Das sollen die in Lübeck klären.
Am 19.9. machen wir Live-Salon. Vorher gibt es die Stadtführung von Mary. Den Link zum Anmelden für limitierte 15 Plätze gibt es gleich zu Beginn im Salon.
Bis gleich.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ist Gilamoos Deutschland?
Ja, Gilamoos gehört auch zu Deutschland wie Berlin Mitte.
Okay, also ich erinnere mich noch grob, dass Willrich Merz einen Joke gemacht hat irgendwann.
Ja, er stand in Guillermo's bei einem Wahlkampfauftritt und sagte, hier ist Deutschland. Ja, nicht da irgendwo, wo die Elite in Berlin herrscht. Hier ist tatsächlich Deutschland.
Wo die Somewheres sind.
Ja, da sind die Somewheres und das ist ja eine interessante Verortung, dass man also nicht nur sagt, hier ist auch Deutschland, das wäre ja die richtige Beschreibung, sondern zu sagen, also hier ist eigentlich so ein wahres Deutschland, also wo noch nicht alle so verrückt geworden sind wie in Berlin. Und das ist ja auch ganz entscheidend wieder hier zu sehen, dass Friedrich Merz derjenige ist, der ja sonst eigentlich nicht in Giedermos unterwegs ist, sondern natürlich zu diesem Jetset gehört viel mehr noch als diejenigen, die er da kritisiert. Aber was man daran sehen kann, ist, dass wir es mit einer polarisierenden Rede zu tun haben und sofort kann man dann dagegen stellen und sagen, aber nein, Berlin ist eigentlich Deutschland und sofort ist man in einer Argumentation drin, bei der man sagt, ja, kommt man überhaupt daraus? Und wir haben jetzt ein Buch des Soziologen Nils C. Kumkar, der uns sagt, Polarisierung gibt es. Wer sie abschaffen will, wird ein Problem bekommen. Man muss sie anders steuern, die Polarisierung. Man muss andere Felder, andere Arenen auch suchen. Der Begriff Arena fällt ja da auch. Aber er ist jemand, der jetzt nicht sagt, ich schreibe euch mal ein Buch auf, wie wir die Gesellschaft dahin verändern können, dass wir am Ende die Spaltung aufgelöst haben, die Polarisierung sich in Luft auflöst. Er sagt, ob die Gesellschaft polarisiert ist, ist eigentlich nicht die Frage, sondern welche Polarisierung man in welchen Situationen politisch für fruchtbar machen kann. Wie fruchtbar machen kann, das sei eigentlich die Frage. Und diese Fruchtbarmachung der Polarisierung ist ja zunächst einmal ein sehr guter Ansatz. Der uns auf direkt eine andere Ebene hebt. Nämlich wir denken über das demokratische System, den Parlamentarismus, aber auch die Medienöffentlichkeit in anderer Weise nach, als die ganze Zeit nur Sorge zu tragen, wie wir die Spaltung der Gesellschaft überwinden. Und das ist erstmal ein Angebot, das neuer ist als das, was uns sonst häufig angeboten wird.
Ja, also es ist dann doch immer wieder schön, ein gutes, soziologisches Buch zu lesen, das einen selbst dazu anregt, eigentlich noch viel härter hätte man das schreiben müssen. Auch zum Beispiel die Pointe Polarisierung wird immer so problematisiert, dann klärt er uns darüber auf. Man kann sich auch mal abfeiern, erstens sich schafft Übersicht, letztlich zu mitmachen, einen verkauft sich gut. Also alles, was im Wahlkampf zielträchtig ist, bringt Polarisierung. Und typischerweise würde ich sagen, die Demokratie zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass wir eine Doppelspitze aus Regierung und Opposition innerhalb der Politik haben. Außerhalb findet dann das, wie Dietmar Daert sagt, Partizipationstheater in den sozialen Netzwerken und in der ARD statt. Und wenn man gegen Polarisierung ist, kann man sagen, Einheitspartei wie in China. Richtig. Da wird nicht polarisiert. Da ist einfach Linie, fertig.
Oder Nationalsozialismus. Eine Linie ist auch möglich, wenn gleich ich hier. Wir reden immer so einfach über China. China hat natürlich dieses Ein-Parteiensystem, hat aber doch, wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, dann diese Regionen, über die man da spricht, die sind ja riesengroß. Und da ist natürlich eine enorme Binnenpluralität dann plötzlich doch da. Und wahrscheinlich könntest du auch Chinesen befragen und sie würden sagen, ja, mich stört gerade die Spaltung in der Gesellschaft. Und sie meinen dann damit eine Polarisierung innerhalb dieser Blöcke, die es da gibt. Auch nicht alle sind ja Parteimitglied. Insofern gibt es da natürlich auch Polarisierung. Aber der Hinweis ist natürlich genau richtig zu sagen, na ja, wenn man offenbar keine Spaltung will, wie sähe denn bitte schön ein Parlamentarismus aus? Also keine Polarisierung will, wie sähe dann ein Parlamentarismus aus? Wenn sich ja dann ohnehin man in allen Punkten eigentlich im Großen und Ganzen einig ist, braucht man ja gar keine Parteien mehr. Könnte man ja alles zu einer Partei zusammenführen. Und das ist genau diese falsche Herangehensweise, wenn man Polarisierung als solches schon problematisiert. Ich will aber gleich schon eine Kritik mitgeben. Also ich bin nicht so begeistert von dir, wie du das jetzt bist. Und würde auch genau da diese Kritik schon weiter fortführen, dass es so wahnsinnig zaghaft ist in seiner Kritik, dass man sich so sehr in sehr langen Bandwurm setzen absichert, dass man sich kaum noch in die eigene These zutraut. Das finde ich ist wirklich eine Untugend hier, die offenbar soziologeninherent ist. Wir haben das ja schon bei anderen auch beobachten können. Aber das finde ich tatsächlich ist eine Schwäche des Buchs, dass hier doch jemand auch sich versucht, immer sehr stark dann in die Mitte, die er ja eigentlich auch kritisiert, hineinzuschreiben, indem er das so liebevoll und ausdifferenziert auffächert.
Das will ich mal direkt kontern, denn wir hatten bisher Bücher, die du gut fandest, in denen von der Dämmerung, der Demokratie, der Abschaffung von irgendwas und so weiter. Und ich kam dann immer und meinte, naja, aber nur weil das Gerede immer ist, dass die Demokratie abgeschafft wird, heißt das noch lange nicht und so weiter. Und hier haben wir es mit einem Soziologen zu tun, der einfach finde ich dann schon relativ deutlich einfach diesen Tenor, und der finde ich immer richtig, zu sagen, nee, morgen ist auch noch ein Tag. Hier wird wieder was abgeschafft, noch was dramatisiert. Wir haben eine Dramatisierung in der politischen Kommunikation, vor allem durch eine sehr hohe sichtbare Unzufriedenheit über politische Angebote, politisches Personal, politischen Kommunikationsuferten. Daraus schlussfolgend, da haben ganz schön viele was dagegen, wie es läuft. Und ein Regierungswechsel macht gar nicht so den großen Unterschied. Also März kommt und der Ärger ist im Grunde derselbe. Und die Argumentations- und Kraftzentren der AfD funktionieren genauso. Also werden wir auch dieses... Also, Merkel hat jetzt die AfD ja vorgebracht durch 2015. Und dann zehn Jahre später, endlich Merkel tritt nicht mehr an und so. Jetzt wird auch das Feindbild der AfD verloren gehen. Es kommt Olaf Scholz. Ein Monat nach der Wahl haben alle vergessen, dass die AfD mal was gegen Merkel hatte, sondern dann geht es einfach gegen Olaf Scholz. Und dann, oh nee, wir brauchen jetzt dringend einen neuen Kanzler. Der Olaf Scholz bringt es ja gar nicht. Die Ampel ist ja voll gescheitert. Wir brauchen jetzt jemanden wie Friedrich Merz. Also ein völliges Gegenangebot zu Olaf Scholz, laut politischer Journalisten und Selbstbeschreibung der Protagonisten. Und schon wieder haben wir voll vergessen, dass die AfD mal was gegen Olaf Scholz und die Ampel hatte, sondern nein, die sind natürlich voll auf Merz eingeschossen. Also es geht einfach immer weiter. Und dieses immer weiter könnte man ja mal in Nuancen zerpflücken, ohne dass man jetzt gleich sagt, also das ist jetzt die allerletzte Chance, die es gibt. Liebe Leser, bitte seid alarmiert.
Nein, das will ich auch nicht lesen.
Ich will kein 5 vor 12-Buch lesen.
Ich sage nur, dass man, wir werden es gleich an Beispielen sehen, dass man es durchaus auch besser formulieren kann.
Das kann man immer.
Na ja, das Buch, also wenn ich zum Beispiel lese, lesen Sie dieses Buch, wie Sie gerne möchten. Aber auf jeden Fall als Einladung zum Gegen, mit und nicht zuletzt weiterdenken. Viele werden einiges in diesem Buch schon einmal in anderen Kontexten so ähnlich gelesen oder sogar gedacht haben. Aber hoffentlich nicht das meiste und schon gar nicht im Kontext soziologischen Nachdenkens über Polarisierung. Das ist schon sehr eitel, wenn man in dieser Weise so Lesensanweisungen, Gebrauchsanweisungen gibt, aber dann zugleich auch wieder keine geben will. Aber ich gebe es Ihnen doch mal mit, das ist ein sehr nerviger Ton, der mitunter da zu lesen ist. Ich finde es auch nicht witzig, sondern eher von so einer gewissen soziologischen Überheblichkeit.
Man hat schon mal in einem Buch den Hinweis bekommen, falls Sie selber Twitter nutzen und wissen, wovon ich rede, blättern Sie einfach auf Seite 101. Das ist doch witzig, so was.
Ich lese Bücher generell so, wie ich sie möchte, die meisten aber doch von vorn bis hin.
Na gut, so machen wir es auch mal. Wir gehen mal von vorn nach hinten durch. Wer braucht wozu und weshalb überhaupt Polarisierung? Alle Fragen, die wir uns dazu stellen, sind im Grunde so ein bisschen falsch. Wie polarisiert ist die Gesellschaft? Eins bis hundert. Ist Polarisierung schlecht? Alle Fragen, die grundsätzlich so im Raum stehen, sagt er, die führen uns auf jeden Fall zu zu einfachen Antworten. Im Grunde ist die Frage schon falsch. Wir müssen uns hier über Polarisierung mal als Phänomen statt als Problem beschäftigen. Da kommt natürlich auch sehr viel dann Zurückhaltung her, weil man will es ja gerade nicht problematisieren wie alle, sondern sagen, wir können das doch einfach mal ganz locker und ruhig beschreiben. Wir wissen ja, dass wir alle polarisiert sind. Machen wir mal einen Haken dran und gehen in so eine Art Yogasituation. Lockerungsübung, wie er das schreibt. Erinnert ja dann auch, es gab doch schon so Bücher wie Triggerpunkte und es wurde ja auch schon als so eine Art Entwarnung rezipiert, weil eben da von Steffen M geschrieben wurde, ja wenn man wirklich so richtig nachfragt und wir haben ja sehr gelobt, seine Fokusgruppen findet man das so gar nicht. Ich finde, Kumkar, das würde ich ein bisschen kritisieren, Steffen M ging schon sehr viel weiter. Also der hat uns auch schon gezeigt, dass es auf der kommunikativen Ebene hier ein Problem gibt, weil nämlich diese Arenen bewusst falsch gespielt werden. Also ein eigentlich ökonomisches Argument wird auf identitätspolitischen Ebene und so weiter gespielt. Also in der Ansicht, er hätte ein bisschen wohlwollender damit umgehen können, aber er nimmt Triggerpunkte als Trigger, um auch nochmal darüber aufzuklären, was ist mit diesem Unterschied aus. Leute haben Meinung und Einstellungen und dann äußern sie sie und dann hören sie jemanden zu, der ihnen unterstellt, eine Meinung und Einstellung zu haben. Dann noch eine Gruppenabstraktion dazu, damit man irgendwie auf 10 Millionen Wähler kommt. So, also wir haben politische Kommunikation, die typischerweise macht das Kommunikation grundsätzlich, aber hier erst recht ein Eigenleben hat. Also nicht ganz die Summe ihrer meinungshabenden Mitglieder ist zu Hause.
Er schreibt die völlig zutreffende Erkenntnis, dass wir nach den Maßgaben der Meinungsforschung nicht in einer polarisierten Gesellschaft leben, hilft den Menschen nicht, solange sie die Gesellschaft in den Momenten, in denen sie der Gesellschaft begegnen, ebenso zutreffend als polarisiert erleben. Hier ist man ja auf einer anderen Ebene plötzlich. Man kann feststellen, dass es ganz viele Gemeinsamkeiten gibt und die Polarisierung gar nicht so weit getrieben ist, wie man eigentlich annimmt. Wenn aber dann doch die Menschen auf Gesellschaft treffen oder über Gesellschaft anfangen zu reflektieren, dann sagen sie sofort, dass es alles so polarisiert. Denn das ist ja tatsächlich auch etwas, was er nochmal sehr gut herausarbeitet, zu sagen, alle sagen, dass die Gesellschaft polarisiert ist und sehen das als ein Problem an. Also egal, mit wem er da spricht, gibt es immer dieses Problem der Polarisierung. Und da geht er also aufgrund dieser Gemeinsamkeit, die man da ausmacht, aber jeder macht natürlich auch was anderes und begegnet dieser Polarisierung woanders. Ausgehend davon kommt er dann und sagt, ja, Polarisierung ist vielleicht gar nicht schlecht. Er sagt, wir stehen also vor der Frage nach der Notwendigkeit, des doch scheinbar falschen, aber hartnäckigen Eindrucks von der Polarisierung anders ausgedrückt, nach der praktischen Wahrheit in dem, was zunächst aussieht wie ein einfacher Irrtum.
Im Grunde könnte man hier reformulieren, vielleicht hätte dir das besser gefallen, wenn man sagt, Polarisierung ist die, nicht die Einsicht, aber der Weg zur Einsicht, dass man feststellt, ich habe eine politische Meinung und andere haben andere. Und nicht nur haben andere andere, sondern andere spielen dann noch auf anderen Spielfeldern und haben so andere Trainer und die sind viel erfolgreicher als ich. Oder mein Trainer, so. Also dieses Repräsentanzproblem noch mit rein. Aber diese Problematisierung von Polarisierung als unhintergehbares, finde ich, das hat er schon ganz gut. Also klar, man könnte jetzt in so einer Rezension, würde ich sagen, für dieses Zeitungspublikum, könnte es auch noch mal auf Pointen zuspitzen und so. Aber hier über, ja, also wenn wir feststellen, dass die Antwort auf die Frage, wie polarisiert sind wir denn, sowohl superpolarisiert als eigentlich gar nicht polarisiert ist, dann ist halt die Frage falsch. Aber falsche Fragen sind halt das Hartnäckigste, was man überhaupt hat. Denn wenn jeder schon über Polarisierung redet, und das kann man sich ja so ungefähr vorstellen wie, also wenn ich Polarisierung bei Google eingebe, bin ich völlig überfordert. Dann komme ich gar nicht weiter. Also muss man diesen Angebot Blätterwald dann mal lichten. Und was das angeht, muss ich sagen, Einstieg ins Buch wirklich hervorragend. Denn als Soziologe nochmal sagen, ja, die Soziologie hat ihre eigene Sicht auf Polarisierung, aber es gibt ja noch eine öffentliche Debatte, und da können wir nicht einfach vorwerfen, soziologisch nicht aufgeklärt zu sein, sondern die ist ja trotzdem real. Und dann nicht einfach wie Gilda Sahebis sagen, die sind halt emotional und da müssen wir halt mal ein Bildungsprogramm auflegen, so dass man genau diesen Kurzschluss dann nicht macht, sondern sagt, egal wie du das beschreibst, die sind emotional, die sind verwirrt, die sind nicht aufgeklärt, oder wie auch immer, ganz egal es ist, wie es ist.
Ich glaube der Unterschied hier liegt zwischen den beiden Büchern auch darin, dass Gilda Sahebi sich auf Extreme konzentriert und dort besonders emotionsgeladene Debatten verfolgt und entsprechende Akteure vorstellt, während ja bei Kumkar auch der Blick auf die normalen, sage ich mal, also auf die etwas ruhigeren Zeitgenossen fällt. Denn er sagt dann einfach, wenn alle einen Marktplatz der Ideen wollen, dann ist uns doch eigentlich klar, dass da ein Austausch von Meinungen organisiert wird, aber da auch eine Polarisierung gebraucht wird, sonst hätte man ja keinen Marktplatz mehr. Da gibt es ja konkurrierende Elemente, folglich braucht man die Polarisierung und der Marktplatz ist eigentlich gar nicht gefährdet durch die Polarisierung, sondern die Polarisierung ist die Bedingung des Marktplatzes. Und indem man natürlich so abstrakt darüber spricht und jetzt nicht gleich in die Extrem geht, da ist ein Querdenker, da ist ein evangelikaler Extremist oder so, komme ich natürlich auf eine andere Ebene dadurch, weil da geht es erstmal gar nicht um Emotionen und wie kann ich sie mit Vernunft woanders hinleiten, sondern wir stellen erstmal fest auf einem Marktplatz der Ideen, gibt es verschiedene Interessen zum Beispiel, die sich gegenüberstehen. Was ich nicht verstehe ist, er deutet das ja nur an sehr wenige Punkten an, warum er nicht stärker macht, dass auch generell eine Gesellschaft, die eine Klassengesellschaft ist, grundsätzlich eine Polarisierung hat. Also er spricht dann sehr von Markplatze Ideen, von verschiedenen Interessen oder so. Aber man muss doch auch ganz klar erkennen, naja, in einer Gesellschaft, in der es Vermieter und Mieter gibt, gibt es eine Spaltung. Punkt. Ja.
Also diese ökonomischen, und zwar gerade mit Bezug auf Marks und so, ich würde sagen, ganz hinten raus ist die Pointe, also man kommt gar nicht drum herum, ökonomische Diskussionen daraus abzuleiten.
Wer das so vorsichtig macht, leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Ja, weil es eben keine, es ist politische Soziologie und kein politisches Wahlprogramm.
Er soll ihr nicht aufschreiben, was die Linke machen soll oder so. Das interessiert mich nicht. Mich interessiert nur, warum, wenn ich so viel über Spaltung und Polarisierung und so weiter rede, so wenig das Ökonomische, das ja doch ganz entscheidend dazu beiträgt, dass wir überhaupt von Polarisierung sprechen, dass das so wenig vorkommt.
Gilda Sahebi vorgeworfen, sie sucht sich Extremfälle raus. Und den Vorwurf würde ich dir jetzt auch machen, du suchst jetzt schon wieder das Ökonomische raus.
Nee, das ist aber kein Extremfall. Das ist ja unsere grundlegende Struktur, auf der alles stattfindet.
Naja, grundlegend ist erstmal, du hast jetzt Marktplatz gesagt. Der Marktplatz zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass die Sachen, die auf dem Marktplatz feilgeboten werden, wie man so schön sagt, schon fertig produziert sind. Das heißt, da fanden Abstraktionsprozesse statt. Man ist also auf dem Marktplatz und dann brät jemand Würste und du hast noch die Auswahl zwischen Rindswurst, Bratwurst und Mettwurst oder sowas.
Aber ich bin jetzt zum Beispiel in einer Situation, bei der es eine Polarisierung gibt aufgrund von konkurrierenden Akteuren auf dem Markt plus das Verhältnis Käufer-Verkäufer. Also du wirst mir doch jetzt nicht sagen, dass das ein Spezialfall der Extreme ist. Ich habe bei Gilda Sahebi gesagt, sie konzentriert sich auf sehr extreme Gestalten in der Öffentlichkeit und zeigt dann, wie so eine emotionale Meute im Netz sich da dran hängt und dann sich immer weiter hochschaukelt. Und das ist ja auch tatsächlich ein Phänomen. Und da kann ich natürlich darüber nachdenken, ob ich das mit ein bisschen mehr Bildung und so weiter stärker eingehegt bekomme. Da, glaube ich, gibt es auch Ansätze, die dafür sprechen. Nur, glaube ich, geht es ja, wenn wir hier darüber sprechen, dass die Polarisierung generell unserer Gesellschaft bestimmt, eigentlich die Notwendigkeit, dass man das Ökonomische stärker in den Mittelpunkt rückt, als das jetzt bei Kumkar der Fall ist.
Und genau da möchte ich widersprechen, denn aus der Schlussfolgerung oder, sagen wir mal, als Effekt der sozio- logischen Aufklärung, die wir von diesem Autor hier bekommen zum Thema Polarisierung, finde ich, läuft auf jeden Fall die Pointe hinaus. Wir müssen, sage ich jetzt mal dann aus, und das spricht dann für mich aus meiner Wählersichter, wünsche ich mir Wahlkämpfe, in denen eine klare Lagerbildung auffindbar ist. Und das eine Lager wird für das andere gefährlich. So, jetzt kann man natürlich in die Einrichtung des drehen und sagen, und es wäre ja auch ein direktes Argument dagegen, also wenn es in der Politik darum geht, politisch erfolgreich zu sein, kann man das offenbar, Beispiel Amerika, sehr gut machen, indem man sagt, nee, das Ökonomische ist ja gar nicht wichtig, der Kulturkampf ist wichtig. Es ist viel wichtiger, welche Porträts im Smithsonian hängen, als dass du genug am Ende des Monats hast. Und die Amerikaner haben sich nun mal mehrheitlich dafür entschieden, dass sie lieber für die nichtökonomische, was hängt eigentlich in der Gemäldegalerie für Porträts, also dass ihnen diese Polarisierung viel wichtiger ist. Jetzt sagst du natürlich, na ja, wenn man die Wähler jetzt mal richtig aufgeklärt hätte, was ja nötig ist und so, und diese Aufklärung beginnt bitte bei den Soziologen, also die müssen uns schon mal das richtig reinhämmern. Es geht ja um das Ökonomische. Is economy stupid und so? Und dann sagt aber jemand wie Kumkar oder auch ich, na ja, aber wir haben ja erstens in der Politik schon das Beispiel dafür, als erfolgreiches Example, das noch Jahrhunderte im Geschichtsbuch stehen wird, wie Donald Trump es schaffte, das Ökonomische rauszuziehen. Die Leute, die Verarmung als grundlegendes Problem beobachtet haben, nochmal mit nichtökonomischen Argumentationen oder sogar Verarmungspolitik auf seine Seite zu ziehen. Und zwar über den Modus der entsprechenden erfolgreichen Polarisierung.
Ja, das ist ja so.
Also wir haben es hier einfach mit einer Empirie zu tun, die uns sagt, ja klar, müssen wir über Ökonomie, also wer sagt, wir müssen ganz wichtig über Ökonomie reden, gehört schon wieder in so einen spezifischen, wir wollen aber nochmal allgemeiner über Polarisierung reden. Und da macht das Buch genau das richtige Denkangebot. Nämlich es beginnt erstmal mit der grundlegenden Beobachtung. Also dass es ein politisches Buch ist, ist ja klar. Aber wenn es um Polarisierung gibt, stellen wir erstmal fest, Polarisierung findet gar nicht da statt, wo wir sie immer vermuten, nämlich nicht in den Einstellungen und Meinungen der einzelnen Punkt. Das ist die erste Erkenntnis, dass wir auch noch über Ökonomie reden müssen. Ja, ja, aber hier noch nicht. Erstmal sind wir nur an dieser Differenz. Und dann ist nämlich die Frage, wie wird es von hier aus weiter entfaltet? Und dann sagt Gilda Sahebi, ja, dann müssen wir jetzt bei den Einstellungen Meinungen ansetzen und da agitieren und propagieren, bis die alle meiner Meinung sind. Und Nils Kumkar sagt, nee, wir müssen uns jetzt erst mal diese Kommunikation anschauen. Wie läuft die eigentlich? In Social Media, in Medien und so weiter. Die Ökonomie spielt dann schon noch eine Rolle. Aber das hat Zeit.
Ja, das kommt aber bei ihm dann zu kurz. Das will ich noch mal deutlich machen. Also, dass du das daraus ableitest für dich, das ist ja schön. Ich frage mich nur, wenn man über Polarisierung redet. Man kann ja auch nicht nur über Kommunikation und alles reden. Und deshalb wäre das auf einer ökonomischen Grundlage gestellt, was nicht für mich meint, der soll mal zehn Punkte aufschreiben, ob wir eine Vermögensteuer und was weiß ich alles bauen. Das kann ich alles selbst beantworten. Nur, dass man da rüber, also, dass man sozusagen die Klassenverhältnisse deutlich macht und darüber kann man ja eine Polarisierung schon beschreiben, jenseits der Diskurse, die bei Twitter oder sonst wo stattfinden.
Aber jenseits der ökonomischen Klassenpolarisierung haben wir auch wirklich noch Polarisierungen. Jung und alt, gebildet, nicht gebildet. Somewhere, anywhere ist auch eine empirische, durchaus eine Korrelation.
Aber das interessante ist jetzt das nächste Mal in Kapitel 1, dass er dann auf Querdenker zu sprechen kommt und dass diese im Prinzip auch die Spaltung des Volks beklagen. Also wenn man auch in rechte Gruppen reingeht, beklagen die auch die Spaltung des Volks. Und man fragt sich, ja, was meinen die jetzt eigentlich gerade mit Volk? Worauf bezieht sich das, wenn man dann sagt, mir ist die Gesellschaft zu polarisiert, sind zum Beispiel Migranten inkludiert oder exkludiert. An diesen Punkten ist man dann plötzlich. Und da sieht man dann eigentlich sehr gut, dass die Leute eine eigenartige Vorstellung davon haben. Er zitiert dann einen Teilnehmer einer solchen Gruppendiskussion, der dann anfängt zu sagen, na ja, also zum Beispiel im Zweiten Weltkrieg. Da war das ja so, da war das ja folgendermaßen, also da sind wir uns doch irgendwie auch zusammengerückt und sonst irgendwas. Und das ist erst mal erstaunlich, dass hier jemand also sitzt und plötzlich den Zweiten Weltkrieg als Beispiel anführt und sagt, da haben wir noch zusammengehalten. Also da sagt zum Beispiel Folgendes, also M und darüber dann geht auch eben dieser, dieser Kompensenz verloren, der in der Gesellschaft und ich glaube, da sind wir sogar schon weiter fortgeschritten als zur Krise des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Da war damals die Bedrohung nicht nur die Bedrohung der Freiheit, sondern es war existenziell, natürlich da weitaus existenzieller, was der Zweite Weltkrieg an Entbehrung mit sich brachte. Ich muss einfach, vielleicht hinkt der Vergleich auch, also kommt ja auch noch dazu, dass wir damals die Kriegstreimen Nationen waren, aber was sollte ich jetzt sagen? Ich mache einen Cut und geh weiter. Also was hier eigentlich so passierte, war der Versuch plötzlich zu überlegen, ob wir jetzt gerade gespaltener sind als im Zweiten Weltkrieg. Und jetzt merkt aber natürlich dieser Teilnehmer, dass er sich gerade selbst sehr verheddert, sondern nämlich genau dann bei diesem Punkt ankommt. Und es schreibt dann Kumkar, es geht hier gerade nicht darum, dass das, was explizit gesagt wird, diejenigen, die nicht mit dieser Form des laufengelassenen Sprechens derjenigen, die nicht ständig öffentlich sprechen, vertraut sind, erschrecken könnte. Sicher, die sich andeutend Stellungnahme, dass wir damals zumindest noch zusammengehalten hätten, verletzt zumindest als öffentliche Äußerung inzwischen den guten Ton. Aber erstens sollte man sich nicht vormachen, dass der Mythos von der Volks- und Kriegsgemeinschaft wirklich jemals aus dem alltäglich geteilten und intergenerational weitergegebenen Common Sense verschwunden wäre. Und zweitens ist auch dem Sprechenden das Problem hier offensichtlich bewusst, dass ihm an dieser Stelle gewissermaßen die Zügel schießen, merkt er selbst und ruft sich dementsprechend zur Ordnung. Gerade darin aber, wie mächtig dieses Bild auch gegen das Tabu an die Öffentlichkeit drängt und darin eben zu den erkennbaren Konflikten mit sich selbst führt, zeigt sich, wie naheliegend diese Metapher in gewisser Weise ist. Für die Lehrerinnen in der Gruppe ist die Krise der Gesellschaft, die sie als Spaltung und Polarisierung fassen, in erster Linie eine Krise der Gemeinschaft. Und damit ist man plötzlich woanders, schreibt dann ein besonders markantes Bild für die Wiederbelebung der Gemeinschaft durch kollektives Zusammenrücken, ist nun mal der Krieg. Ja, dann sind wir nämlich genau an diesem Punkt, wenn man sagt, Spaltung überwinden, mit dem Krieg ginge das ja, dann rücken wir mal wieder zusammen. Und wir haben das ja auch jetzt in diesen Aufrüstungsdiskursen fortwährend erlebt, dass manche so argumentierten, jetzt wo wir bedroht sind, können wir als Europäer oder als Deutsche wieder zusammenrücken.
Also da bist du jetzt schon zu schnell bei den Themen, denn hier ist ja, finde ich schon, diese soziologische Aufklärung, die halt in dem Buch so drin liegt, er hat diesen Overview-Effekt. Zum einen, also die Astronomie oder die Physiker erlauben uns irgendwann, die Erde zu verlassen, die Erde von außen zu sehen. Wir sehen eine blaue Kugel und stellen fest, wir sind alle eins. Das ist ein Bild, das er braucht. Und dann das zweite, dieser Slavoj Žižek-Witz mit dem Huhn. Also ein Mann geht zu einem Therapeuten und sagt, ich glaube, ich bin ein Korn und draußen auf der Straße steht ein Huhn, das würde mich fressen. Dann sagt der Therapeuten, aber sie sind ja gar kein Korn, sie sind ja ein Mensch. Dann fragt er zurück, aber weiß das Huhn das auch? Also könnte das Huhn, das auf der Straße steht, ihn verwechseln, unabhängig davon, dass die therapeutische Aufklärung natürlich lautet, du bist ein Mensch. Aber was nützt es, wenn das Huhn das nicht erkennt? Und das ist ja super interessant, wie er jetzt hier auch versucht, den Soziologen, also sich selber, und sein Potential der Aufklärung mal zu positionieren. Denn er schreibt explizit, es nützt den Menschen innerhalb von politischen Diskussionen gar nichts, wenn sie eine soziologische Aufklärung dazu bekommen, dass ja am Ende wir alle in einem Boot sitzen, und dieses Boot heißt Erde, und im Weltraum ist sehr kalt, und besser mal, wir halten zusammen und so. Oder eben man ihnen sagt, naja, du bist ja nur paranoid. Du siehst ja überall nur Polarisierung, da ist ja gar keiner. So wie Stefan Schulz im Podcast gesagt hat, kann man sich da nicht einfach drüber lustig machen. Also muss man die Polarisierung so ernst nehmen. Und Kumkar sagt eben, nee, auch Herr Stefan Schulz sollte die Polarisierung mal ernst nehmen, denn sie ist ein kommunikatives Phänomen, das nun durchaus seine Effekte zeigt. Da nützt es gar nichts, so lächelnd daneben zu stehen und zu sagen, na hoffentlich macht in fünf Jahren Mariki Chavez irgendwie ein Comedy-Programm draus, dass wir alle mal herzlich über Maga lachen. Dann war halt Maga trotzdem 20 Jahre Realität und hat seine Spur durch die Weltgeschichte gezogen. Und diese Unhintergehbarkeiten, also dass wir hier nicht einfach sagen können, du bist paranoid oder du bist doch gar kein Korn, du bist doch ein Mensch. Und dass das alles nichts nützt, weil es eben nicht um der Einzelne, seinen Blick auf die Gesellschaft, den besten Bemühen, seine kommunikativen Anstrengungen, wie auch immer, können wir nicht noch mal gegen, also du hast diesen Film Soldaten des Lichts schon gesehen, ich noch nicht. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, da sieht man keine Protagonisten, von denen man sagt, die waren einfach 10 Stunden zu wenig in der Volkshochschule oder so. Sondern das läuft wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders.
Das läuft über eine andere Ebene.
Also wir kommen hier grundsätzlich...
Man sieht, es gibt da einer, der wirklich zum Opfer dieser Leute wird, und der wird aber auch in einem Gespräch mit seinen Eltern gezeigt. Und ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die Eltern gerade das Buch von Kumkar lesen und danach das von Sahebi. Und trotzdem können die genau... Sie können sie, obwohl sie das wahrscheinlich nicht gelesen haben oder so, können sie dem Sohn eigentlich genau das Richtige sagen. Also sie können ihn in einer eigentlich richtigen Weise aufklären. Und trotzdem verfängt es nicht wiederum beim Sohn, auch wenn er das eigentlich gedanklich nachvollziehen müsste.
Also wir haben eine allgemeine Auffassung, dass eine Anschauung von außen transformatives Potenzial hat. Und das ist so einfach nicht gegeben. Also wir können Kindern die Schule schicken und die lernen da auch Sachen. Also es verändert deren Leben, so wie wenn wir im Buch lesen auch das verändert. Aber wir können diese Zielgerichtetheit gibt es einfach nicht. Und man muss halt immer wieder sagen, man muss genau sagen, in welcher Arena man gerade ist. Also wenn ein Soziologe über ein politisches Phänomen ein Buch schreibt und ein Rezensent fordert, dass er gerne bitte ein ökonomisches Argument recht früh macht, dann verstrickt man sich.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also Soziologie und Ökonomie ist ja nicht voneinander getrennt. Doch. Nein.
Natürlich.
Ja.
Sonst wäre es ja halt dasselbe.
Als Fach. Aber wenn ich über eine Gesellschaft spreche, dann muss ich mich ja fragen, und das ist ja auch mein Vorwurf, den ich an Luhmann gerne wiederhole, dann muss ich schon wissen, bin ich jetzt zum Beispiel in einer planwirtschaftlichen Gesellschaft, bin ich in einem Sozialismus oder bin ich in einem Kapitalismus, der wie geartet ist. Und ich glaube, dass man darauf nochmal seine Soziologie prüfen müssen, weil man ja nicht einfach nur von Menschen begegnen sich irgendwo.
Die Systemtheorie ist darauf geprüft, ob du ein Argument zur kapitalistischen Marktwirtschaft, marktwirtschaftlichen Kapitalismus, Teil planwirtschaftlichen Marktwirtschaften oder was auch immer machst. Die ist auf alles geprüft. Die kann dir zu allem Aussagen machen. Aber du kommst nicht drum hin. Die ersten fünf Seiten sind anderen Problemen gewidmet.
Mir ist völlig egal, wann es in einem Buch kommt. Ich will ja auch nicht darauf rumreiten jetzt. Ich sage nur, wir leben in einer Klassengesellschaft. Und darüber kann ich schon auch in einem Buch, das sich so stark mit Polarisierung beschäftigt, mehr als ein paar spröde Sätze drauf verwenden. Nicht, weil ich jetzt noch mal alles aufgezählt bekommen will, was eine Klassengesellschaft auszeichnet. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man diesen Klassensstandpunkt ein bisschen stärker einbringt, dass dadurch auch noch mal über Polarisierung sich anders sprechen lässt, weil man dann plötzlich bei denen ist, die haben und die nicht haben, bei denen ist, die vermieten und mieten, bei denen ist, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen und jenen, die sie kaufen können. Und über diese Ebene, da sind wir immer auf der soziologischen Ebene. Ich will ja nicht ein ökonomisches Buch über Erbschaftssteuer oder sowas lesen. Kann man auch Gesellschaft noch mal vielleicht an einigen Punkten besser beschreiben, als das hier der Fall ist, während man sich mitunter hier in recht verquassten Formulierungen verliert, bei Dingen, die man eigentlich dann auch schon mal verstanden hat und dann wird es aber noch mal 20 Seiten weiter gesagt. Das wäre mein Vorwurf an dieses Buch. Das ist aber jetzt nicht, dass ich damit das Buch an sich ablehne in seinen Thesen, sondern ich unterstütze die These, frage mich nur, ob es in dieser Fülle hätte sein müssen, ob man dann nicht das eher noch mal rückgebunden hätte, stärker an eine Polarisierung, die notwendigerweise in einer kapitalistischen Gesellschaft sein muss. Wenngleich ich auch hier hinzufüge, ich brauche hier jetzt nicht einen zweiten Marx oder so lesen, den kenne ich ja schon.
So, hast du den Eindruck, dass er Marx auch ausführlich gelesen hat?
Ich habe den Eindruck. Ich würde es ihm unterstellen, dass er das hat. Genau, er kommt ja viel drauf zu sprechen.
Aber er kommt ja viel auf Marx zu sprechen. Und das, was ich da lese, klingt mir erstmal plausibel ausgewählt für die Argumentation und so weiter. Es ist natürlich die Frage, warum macht er das nicht? Und ich würde jetzt das Buch mal, wie folgt, gerade für diejenigen, die es nicht gelesen haben, die dies gelesen haben, können ja dann mitentscheiden. Nils Kumkar sagt, das Problem, das er in diesem Buch soziologisch behandeln möchte, ist das der Polarisierung. Und als Thema wählt er sich kein Klassenthema oder Ökonomisches, sondern er sagt, mein Thema, anhand dessen ich hier plausibilisiere und die Relevanz dieser Themenwahl unterstreiche ich auch durch, wenn ich Nachrichten schaue, sehe ich das als allererstes und drängendstes Problem, zu dem sich die Soziologie mal äußern sollte. Und Stefan Schulz hat ja immer gesagt, bitte äußert euch doch mal zu Themen, die uns alle interessieren sollten, sagt Rechtspopulismus. So, und der Rechtspopulismus zeichnet sich aber dadurch aus, dass wir Leute, die mit Milliarden im Hintergrund News finanzieren, die Ärmsten in der Gesellschaft im Osten einsammeln. Jetzt könnte man natürlich eine sehr aufwendige und das finde ich auch lohnenswert sagen, und jetzt versuchen wir mal die Klassendifferenzen darin wiederzufinden und das Funktionsprinzip dieses Rechtspopulismus zu beschreiben. Nur das wäre wieder eine Aufgabe für in der Soziologie vielleicht Steffen Mau, der dann einfach in den Osten fährt, dort Gespräche führt und genau versucht herauszufinden, warum im Dresdner Umland jemand davon begeistert ist, was er von News, also von dem Westdeutschen Milliardär und so weiter vorgesetzt bekommt. Nur das ist halt eine inhaltliche Arbeit, der man sich stellen kann, die aber eine andere Fragestellung folgt, weil dann sind wir nicht mehr in Polarisierung. Das ist dann sozusagen angewendete Sozialwissenschaft, die auf sehr viel beruht, das vorher schon als Grundlagenwissenschaft geschrieben sein muss, wie zum Beispiel ein Buch über Polarisierung, was wir jetzt behandeln.
Ja, ich bin ja auch gar nicht dagegen, den Fokus auf die Polarisierungslegenden, das ist ja nun das Thema dieses Buches. Ich bin mir nur sicher, dass man es auch nochmal hätte man mehr das Ökonomische in eingebracht, auch den Polarisierungsbegriff nochmal in anderer Weise hätte schärfen können. Was ich aber dem Buch sehr zugute halte, ist ja, dass es sich erstmal mit der Mitte auseinandersetzt. Also alle wollen, wenn wir jetzt von der Mitte reden, so einen deliberativen Demokratieansatz ja eigentlich haben. Ja, wir diskutieren über verschiedene Konflikte, die wir haben. Und er sagt dann, ständig muss man damit rechnen, dass Unterschiede zu Konflikten eskalieren, so dass die Delibration, in deren Rahmen wir doch eigentlich, dass uns Vereinende herausfinden und gemeinsam an Lösungen für die Probleme der Gegenwart arbeiten könnten, abgebrochen wird, bevor sie beginnt. Polarisierung ist für dieses Milieu eine Form der geteilten Sprachlosigkeit, die uns davon abhält, gemeinsame Lösungen zu entwickeln. Das bedeutet natürlich hier, dass immer wieder von vielen Leuten die Gesellschaft als Gemeinschaft gedacht wird, was an sich schon ein Problem ist. Nämlich, dass sie immer davon ausgehen, dass man eigentlich eine Gemeinschaft herstellen könnte. Dann ist nur die Frage, warum dann noch deliberative Demokratie, warum dann überhaupt noch den Austausch über Konflikte, wenn man ja dann schon in der Gemeinschaft wäre, wie sähe die dann aus?
Und deswegen ist ja meine Kritik zum Beispiel im Fernsehpodcast seit Jahren, liebe Journalisten, unterstellt nicht, dass die Regierung eine Familie sei, in der sich alle, sondern nein, das ist Konflikt. Dauerhafter Konflikt, Stabilität durch Konflikt. Aber eben, die Digitalisation durch Verfahren achtet auf die Verfahren. Und was machen sie immer? Sie achten auf Mama und Papa und ob sie sich verstehen, statt auf die Verfahren. Werden immer Protagonisten in den Mittelpunkt gestellt, statt Abläufe, Programme, Verwaltungsprinzipien.
Dann hatte er ein sehr gutes Beispiel. Da geht es, ich würde mal sagen, um die Tonalität. Also da ist eine Frau, die berichtet, dass sie in der Weihnachtsfeier haben sie, glaube ich, sie lädt eine Freundin ein, von der sie weiß, oh, das wird problematisch, wenn die an ihren Sohn gerät. Denn wenn sie sich dann über den Krieg in der Ukraine austauschen, dann wird es zu Reibereien kommen. Und sie können das auch eine Zeit lang umschiffen, aber irgendwann ist dann doch das Thema. Und jetzt hat man folgende Positionen. Die Freundin sagt, dass Putin dort in die Ukraine einmarschiert ist, ist reine Notwehr, das liegt alles an der NATO. Die hat sich erweitert. Und der Sohn sagt, nein, das ist ein Angriffskrieg, Putin hat keinen Grund, die Ukraine anzugreifen. Das sind die beiden Lager. Interessanterweise ist jetzt diese besagte Freundin, die schon die Sorge hatte, dass es zu dem Konflikt kommt, inhaltlich auf der Seite des Sohnes und sagt, ich glaube das auch nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie nur die NATO schuld sein soll. Aber die Art und Weise, wie der Sohn dann mit der Freundin spricht und sie belehrt und welchen Ton er anschlägt, ist wiederum so, dass sie das nicht gut heißen kann, wie darüber gesprochen wird. Das ist also eine Tonalität, die eine Spaltung über die inhaltliche Frage deutlich hinaus hervorruft. Also das, obwohl sie eigentlich auf der Seite des Sohnes steht, inhaltlich, sagt aber dieser Ton so nicht.
Das ist ja wieder, also kurz vor Psychologie, dann schreibt ja zum Beispiel Katharina Nockun die Aufklärung darüber. Erst mal die Beziehungsgestaltung machen, bevor man auf Themen kommt, also erst mal Regeln des Gemeinsam-Sprechens oder wie auch immer. Also war ja dann auch immer als Angebot, wo er sich ja nicht wendet, aber wo er sagt, naja, das ist halt, das kann man nicht so hoch skalieren, dass man ostdeutsche Abgedrifter aus Regionen, wo es gar keine Zuwanderer gibt, indem man ihnen empathisch begegnet und so weiter. Und er erst mal versucht, wieder eine Bande zu schlagen, gemeinsames Orchester, Kunstprojekte, was auch immer. In der Hoffnung, dass man dann, wenn es mal zur Politik kommt, eben nicht solche Verstimmungen auftauchen. Aber das ist ja mit Absicht von der Soziologie einfach ignoriert, würde ich jetzt mal so ganz hart sagen.
Dann ist ja der weitere Punkt, dass er sagt, wir kommunizieren, aber wir können die Kommunikation an sich nicht komplett von außen betrachten. Also wir sind nicht die Astronauten, die einfach dort auf eine Welt blicken und sagen, ach, da ist sie, da unten, diese Welt. Das ist mit der Kommunikation so eine Sache. Und er bringt dann ein Beispiel. Und zwar geht es da um Claude Lévi-Strauss. Der hat einen Kollegen, Paul Radin, und der hat die Angehörigen der Winnebargo, also der indigenen Bewohner an den großen Seen in Nordamerika gebeten, mal das Dorf zu skizzieren. Und da ist doch interessant, dass da unterschiedliche Schematar herauskommen, wie das also angeordnet ist, das Dorf. Und Radin hat das dann Claude Lévi-Strauss erzählt und gesagt, ja, das zeigt mal wieder Erinnerungen sind unzuverlässig, die Menschen haben gar nicht so ein gutes Vorstellungsvermögen. Und dann hat Lévi-Strauss gesagt, Zitat jetzt Kumkar, dass die Unterschiede einer basalen Unterscheidung innerhalb der Venebargo Sozialstrukturen entsprachen. Einige, in Klammern von oben, zeichneten ein Dorf, in dem die Hütten sich einigermaßen gleichmäßig auf einen Kreis verteilten, die wiederum in zwei Hälften geteilt war, in denen die von oben oder die von unten lebten und bei denen an den überliegenden Außenrändern die Hütten der jeweiligen Anführer dieser Gruppe verortet waren. Die anderen, von unten, zeichneten ein Dorf, in dem die Anführer der jeweiligen Gruppen im Zentrum des Dorfes und nicht an der Peripherie wohnten und in dem überhaupt die entscheidende Gliederung, die nach Zentrum und Peripherie war, wobei wenige Hütten sich in Zentrum balten. Da sind wir plötzlich genau in dieser Debatte von Globalisten und Kommunitaristen, die Anywares und die Somewares. Und das ist die Frage der Perspektive. Es ist nicht eine Frage von, ach, die können sich schlecht erinnern, wie ihr Dorf eigentlich gebaut ist.
Genau. Und das ist super instruktiv und das muss man sich jetzt wirklich verdeutlichen. Klar, auf Dorfebene liest man das so und fragt sich, wie die sind doch die Wege abgelaufen, können die einfach malen, wo die Hütten sind? Das ist auch die einfachste Übung. Aber wenn wir uns das jetzt vorstellen für Deutschland und manchmal findet man das, wenn man Kinder hat, kleine Kinder, in Wimmelbüchern, Deutsche Bahn zum Beispiel, da gab es früher in diesen Malbüchern so ein großes Bild, wo einmal ganz Deutschland abgebildet wurde. Also von den Bergen bis zur Küste, der Fernsehturm, der Kölner Dom, alles in einem Bild. Dann ist ja die Frage, wie ordnet man das eigentlich für sich an? Und dann gibt es die einen, die sagen, Deutschland funktioniert wie Frankfurt am Main. Da ist in der Mitte einfach eine Skyline, da sind die Häuser 200 Meter hoch. Und umso weiter man rauskommt, umso flacher sind die Häuser. Im Zentrum wird gearbeitet, da wird gelebt. Dann gibt es die Künstler, die sagen einfach, ist doch völlig klar, Städel und Oper sind in der Mitte und sind ja auch die zentralen Adressen so. Dann gibt es das Kanzleramt, das Weiße Haus mitten im Zentrum. Und der Rest ist halt irgendwo anders. Und das kriegt man in seinem Kopf nicht zustande, weil wir eben, hier wurde jetzt gerade von Zentrum und Peripherie gesprochen und so. Ja, am Anfang war es segmentiert, aber einfach klar, hier ist ein Dorf, da ist ein Dorf. Wenn man zu dem Dorf rüber geht, ist man einfach in einem Wald, das ist ein magisches Gebiet. Niemand sieht einen. Danach kann man alle Geschichten erzählen. Und man sieht ja im Rheintal an den Schlössern noch, wie dann aus den Geschichten gemeldet wurden und dann irgendwie ein sechsfüßiger Löwe irgendwie angeblich hier durch den deutschen Wald gelaufen ist und so. Nur wir leben jetzt in einer zirkulären, arbeitsteiligen, funktional differenzierten Gesellschaft, in der es grundsätzlich schon mal schwierig ist, eine Aussage zu treffen, mit was wir es hier zu tun haben. Und wenn man es dann noch unter diesem politischen Wille unterordnet, alle halten zusammen. Wir sind so eins. Teufels Küche. Also Polarisierung ist der Modus operandi. So Polarisierung heißt mindestens zwei Pole, können aber sogar mehr sein. Beobachtung von innen ist schwierig, Beobachtung von außen ist nicht hilfreich. Das sind die ganzen Aufklärungen, die wir dann bekommen. Und dann, und jetzt wird es richtig tricky, muss man sich vorstellen, in so einer politischen Kommunikation, die funktioniert wie Geld. Nur weil ich 100 Euro habe und daran glaube, dass sie etwas wert sind, das bringt mir noch gar nichts. Sondern ich gehe erst dann vertrauensvoll in die Welt, wenn ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass im Supermarkt, wo ich die ausgeben möchte, auch hinreichend viele Menschen sind, die daran glauben, dass meine 100 Euro etwas wert sind. Ich muss also nicht nur einen eigenen Glauben haben, sondern ich muss diesen Glauben auch noch auf den Glauben anderer ausrichten und das dann koordinieren. Aber nur so kommt man zu Stabilität. Also die 100 Euro einfach in Gold, also in Materie tauschen, das bringt gar nichts. So, weil dann bin ich im Tauschprinzip, dann müsste ich ja jedes Mal ewig diskutieren, was sie jetzt genau wert sind. Und dann kommt diese komische Börsenlogik, also für einen Goldene, was auch immer, Münze kannst du immer einen Mantel kaufen, egal in welchem Jahrhundert. Du kriegst immer genau einen handgemachten Mantel. Ja, aber das ist das Einzige, was man dann dafür kriegt. Ich will ja im Supermarkt alles. Ich will aus 100 Autos auswählen, mit welchen mich nun, und zwar nur für ein Wochenende geliehen und so weiter. Und das funktioniert nur, wenn man Glauben mit Glauben verkoppelt und daraus eine Erwartung, ein Vertrauen schürft, dass ich eigentlich, wie wir heute wissen, nur über Erfahrung, also nur über Geschichte einschreiben kann. Man könnte also, wenn man überhaupt Gemeinsamkeit, Zusammenhalt, allenfalls noch in, aber dass die Geschichte so war, darauf können wir uns noch einigen, oder? Und dann gehen schon wieder die Diskussionen los.
Welche Geschichte und wie, und die wird ja von Siegern geschrieben, etc.
Genau, genau, genau. Also selbst das ist schon schwierig. Ist alles schwierig, ja. Weshalb ich ja immer wieder dafür werbe, nicht übers Bewusstsein, ne? Also nicht mit Leuten anfangen zu reden. Im besten Fall kriegt man dann noch so Anekdoten wie von Aladdin El-Mafalani, der einfach sagt, also ich frage immer wieder auf Prudhums Diskussionen, können sie mir kurz sagen, was die deutsche Leitkultur ist? Und dann seine Pointe nach dem dritten Satz wird angefangen zu lachen. Von den Leuten, die das selber versuchen, gerade zu beschreiben. Weshalb ich sage, lieber gar nicht versuchen zu beschreiben. Einfach Christopher Nolan-Style. Einfach fühlen, ja. Wenn das Gefühl in die richtige Richtung geht, nicht drüber reden. In der Küche keine Politik und so. Das kann natürlich keine legitime Antwort der Soziologie sein. Weshalb es immer schwierig ist, es dann doch mal in Worte zu fassen. Aber im Grunde ist dieses Shijakes Huhn der astronomische Blick von außen oder der astronautische Blick von außen. Da sind wir schon in so Grenzgebieten der, wer soll denn so eine Erfahrung machen? Also wer erlebt denn wirklich mal von einem Therapeuten die Aufklärung, dass Huhn wird sie wohl als Mensch erkennen? Okay, so kannst du jetzt deinen Kanzler wählen. Oder eben Katy Perry, selbst Katy Perry. Sie fliegt sogar in den Weltraum. Und wir würden ihr trotzdem nicht unterstellen, dass sie daraus die Leere zieht, jetzt nie wieder auf einer Superjacht Silvester zu feiern, weil das ja die Erde kaputt macht.
Nee.
Also all die Angebote, die wir so vermeintlich immer vorgegaukelt bekommen, wenn nur die Aufklärung im heutigen All sehr viel besser wäre, dann wären wir gar nicht polarisiert und würden gemeinsam in eine Richtung gehen. Nein, das ist es nicht.
Ich bin aber trotzdem dafür, dass Aufklärung schon relevant ist. Nein, nein, so ist es ja nicht zu verstehen. So ist es nicht zu verstehen. Aber man kann ja aufgrund von Aufklärung trotzdem in eine andere Richtung streben.
Genau.
Also das eine schließt das andere nicht auf. Ich habe mich kürzlich mit jemanden unterhalten, der sehr viel Geld mit dem Vermieten von Wohnungen verdient. Der ist durchaus aufgeklärt über die Verhältnisse in Deutschland. Aber der macht es trotzdem.
Der ist ja viel besser aufgeklärt als die Wähler der AfD.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Weshalb ja Kumkar am Ende auch sagt, Polarisierung ist, wie sie ist. Aber die Polarisierung selbst kann man ja ein bisschen steuern.
Kommen wir mal zu diesem Online-Kapitel. Da geht es vor allem um Twitter, ja Social Media. Da geht es also darum, dass Carlo Massalla ja auf Twitter ist, wie wir alle wissen. Und dann hat irgendjemand einen Account gemacht, der hieß er Carlo Massacca. Und Carlo Massalla hat ja gar nicht ein Profilbild von sich selbst bei Twitter, sondern hat ein Profilbild von einer Figur aus Game of Thrones. In seinem Profil. Und diese Figur wurde dann kopiert von diesem Scherzkicks. Und der hat dann solche Tweets abgesendet, wie ich zitiere mal so aus dem Gedächtnis, denke gerade darüber nach, ob ein nuklearer Schlag eine schöne Möglichkeit wäre oder so. Ja, also einfach so den ohnehin Zynismus von Massalla noch weiter auf die Spitze getrieben. Und das sorgte aber dann zu großen Konfusionen deshalb, weil das von manchen als realer Account angesehen wurde. Massalla dann wiederum Leute mobilisierte, doch bitte diesen Account zu sperren. Was wiederum bedeutete, dass andere sagten, ach, ich fäke jetzt auch so ein Profil. Wer gleich mal auch sagen muss, naja, eine Verifikation hatte ja ohnehin schon nicht richtig stattgefunden, weil er auch nur so ein komisches Profil aus einer Serie drin hatte. Und er beschreibt dann sehr ausführlich hier, wie diese Debatte dann war. Und das produziert natürlich eine enorme Unübersichtlichkeit, weil plötzlich da zwar eine Polarisierung zu beobachten ist, die aber zugleich überlagert ist, zum Beispiel mit Leuten, die ironisch das Spiel jetzt mitspielen. Manche, die nicht wissen, dass es ein Fake-Account ist und sagen, das ist ja wirklich krass, jetzt will der nuklearen Schlag. Dann die seriösen Massalla-Unterstützer, die sagen, Hilfe, diese Plattform wird von Trollen okkupiert, wir müssen dagegen vorgehen. Und dann nochmal andere, die sich einmischen. Das heißt, man hat also mehrere verschiedene Einmischungen. Bedeutet also auch, man ist hier nicht mehr in einer Arena, die man unterscheiden kann in, was ist deine Position dazu, was ist meine Position dazu, sondern es gibt verschiedene Rezeptions- und Aktionsmodi, die dort in Gang getreten werden. Das ist an sich eine hochkomplexe Sache, aber auch eine unglaublich banale wiederum. Denn natürlich funktionieren so die sozialen Medien, wenn ich nicht einfach nur 1 zu 1 Verifikation habe und Leute gegenüber sitze habe und sagen, das ist Stefan Schulz, der hat folgende Meinung, hier sitzt Wolfgang M. Schmitt, der hat eine andere.
Genau, aber in diesem Kapitel wird es ja ganz wunderbar entfaltet, was wir die letzten 20 Jahre eigentlich da erlebt haben. Also zum einen aus dieser Zentrumslosigkeit, aus dieser funktionalen Differenzierung, der Arbeitszahlung und so weiter, ergibt sich ja, wie eben schon beschrieben, dieser Ich lese nicht einfach auf Twitter, was jemand schreibt. Es ist ja nicht so banal, dass das einfach eine Verwechslung ist im Sinne von, ah ja, es war gar nicht der Puh, noch mal den Schweiß von der Stirn gedischt. Offenbar haben die politischen Berater doch nicht den Atomkrieg im Sinn so. Und das Phänomen ist ja, das kann ja jeder selber nachfühlen, der dabei war auf Twitter, solange es funktioniert hat. Wenn man einen Fake-Account gesehen hat, von dem alle wussten, der ist Fake, aber die inhaltliche Botschaft trifft doch irgendwie so ein bisschen Kern, also witzig ist es schon so. Und dann sieht man darunter 20.000 Likes. Dann unterstellt man ein Publikum, das man niemals sieht, aber man weiß, krass, irgendwo sind 20.000 Leute, die das irgendwie genauso attraktiv, vielleicht sogar auch aus diesen Witzigkeitsgründen fanden wie ich. Oder sind da vielleicht auch einige dabei. Also man kommt zu uns und denkt, was dachten so diese anderen 20.000 Leute? Nur auf diese 20.000 Leute hat man ja keinen Zugriff. Denn es ist ja das Schlechte aus beiden Welten, nämlich es ist eine relativ aktuelle Echtzeitkommunikation, wie eine Interaktion, ein Gespräch unter Anwesenden. Nur die Anwesenden sind ja abwesend. Ja, also muss man sich allein aus Zeitmangel, wenn man auch noch einen Witz machen will, dann ist man besser der Dritte, der antwortet auf den Tweet und nicht der 37. Muss man relativ zügig kommunizieren auf Twitter, aber halt in so einem Abwesenheits... Also man muss sehr viel imaginieren, sich vorstellen, darüber, wie die anderen gerade... Also man muss die ganze Debatte in seinem eigenen Kopf simulieren, weil man die Debatte selbst gar nicht sieht. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen diese Unterstellung, wie vorhin bei den Bayern 2 Video. Da macht einen Video und man sieht eben nicht nur das Video, sondern im Kopf läuft selber noch mit, wie sehen das andere gerade? Wie viele Leute haben das schon gesehen? Hat sie da einen Punkt? Finde ich irgendwas überzeugend im Sinne von, das würde andere überzeugen, das wäre mein Haken, wo ich dann einhake und so. Und dieses Mitlaufen, das gab es vorher nicht. Also mein Opa saß nicht vor dem Fernsehnachrichten und hat dann die ganze Zeit gedacht, oh krass, die kommuniziert gerade und das ist ja... Nein, er hat einfach nur wissen wollen, was in der Welt los ist und hat es da bekommen als Information. Und es lief eben nicht dieser ganze interen Fingerdruck und du kannst auch noch teilnehmen und die Debatte prägen. Also mach dir jetzt Gedanken darüber, wie du diese Debatte prägst und sei dir bewusst, die anderen denken auch gerade so aktiv darüber nach. Hier konsumiert keiner einfach nur, sondern hier wird, da gab es auch früher dieses Wort, wo Producen mit reinkam, der User und der Producer.
Achso, du meinst der Prosument.
Der Prosument, genau, solche Sachen. Und die haben natürlich richtig Feuer reingebracht, weil wir kommen aus Polarisierung nicht raus, alle Vorstellungen, alle Immunikationen, darüber, wie etwas rezipiert wird medial, läuft natürlich unter Polarisierungsproblematisierung.
Jaja.
So, und das bringt das Feuer. Nicht die Inhalte, sondern diese Unterstellung. Manchmal ist man ja einfach nur getriggert worden, weil ein Video 50.000 Likes hatte, und man hat es aber innerlich gar nicht verstanden. Also hat man erst mal nachgegoogelt, welcher Beef ist das gerade? Was habe ich hier verpasst und so?
Damit man mit einsteigen kann in den Beef.
Man hat schon gesehen, da ist eine Polarisierung, aber ich verstehe sie doch nicht. Bitte erklär es mir. Und dann gab es ganz viele diese ganzen Webblogs, die so aufgeklärt haben über die Beefs, die gerade laufen. Und das sind die Triebfedern, die wir durch Social Media hatten. Vorher gab es das einfach gar nicht. Ich weiß noch, wir hatten Wikipedia, äh, Wikipedia hier in Berlin, Republikaveranstaltungen, wo Marietta Slomka auf der Bühne saß und sagte, ja, wir haben jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen intern darauf geachtet, dass wir nicht einfach nur, weil ein Tweet so viele Retweets hat, da ein Thema draus machen, sondern erst mal gucken, was da so dran ist. Weil die haben sich voll da mittreiben lassen.
Nur, du beschreibst jetzt ja gerade etwas sehr gut.
Aber das hat Kumkar, ich komme mit dem Namen durch. Kumkar hat das so reingeschrieben. Ich kann es dir vorlesen.
Ja, nein, du beschreibst das jetzt gerade sehr gut, was ich nur sagen will. Sind wir jetzt bei diesem Kapitel in dem Bereich, wo wir sagen, dass das ist uns was in irgendeiner Weise, also ist uns das vorher nicht aufgefallen, ohne dass wir das jetzt aufschrieben bekommen haben?
Ja, würde ich sagen. Also hier ist auf jeden Fall, doch, ich habe selber ein Buch darüber geschrieben.
Ja, genau. Aber wir reden doch seit Jahr und Tag genau darüber, dass dort diese Konflikte produziert werden, auch aufgrund dessen, dass man eben solche Dynamiken hat, die sich selbstverständlich beginnen und bei denen man dann plötzlich eine Polarisierung hat, wo vorher nie irgendetwas gewesen ist. Also ich sage jetzt, man muss ja nicht alles, was man schreibt, muss man nicht immer der Erste sein oder so. Aber ich fand ja zum Beispiel dieses Social-Media-Kapitel nicht besonders originell.
Jetzt allerdings kommt die Pointe, den ich lese vor. Also alles, was ich jetzt beschrieben habe, steht hier drin. Das Schlechte aus beiden Welten, also ich lese mal beides. Also in dieser Hinsicht, der Überforderung durch Komplexität in der Sozialdimension kombiniert die politische Social-Media-Öffentlichkeit das Schlimmste aus den zwei Welten der Interaktion zwischen Anwesenden und der schriftlichen Kommunikation unter Abwesenden. So, also das jetzt beschrieben, da sagst du, so relevant ist es nicht. Jetzt lese ich aber weiter in dem Buch, das Tragische dabei ist, all das braucht gar keine polarisierenden Algorithmen oder anderweitige Manipulationen, denn, wie ich jetzt etwas pointiert anfüge, genau, das findet nämlich alles schon in unseren Köpfen allein statt. Durch die Social-Media-Erfahrung, und das habe ich ja damals in Redaktionsschluss auch geschrieben, das Social-Media-Zeitalter, wie auch die Altenrepublik, das sind Phänomene, die betreffen auch diejenigen, die gar nicht daran teilnehmen. Also auch jemand, der niemals einen Twitter-Account hatte, kann heute nicht mehr Tagesschau gucken, ohne im Kopf die ganze Zeit mitlaufen zu lassen, Scheiße, wen polarisiert das schon wieder? Oh nee, schon wieder so viele Flüchtlinge. Ich habe ja nichts gegen Flüchtlinge, aber jetzt machen die Nazis wieder so einen Stress. Scheiße, kann ich meine Tochter morgen noch nachts durch die Straße schicken oder werde ich jetzt verfolgt von Baseballschlägertypen und so. Und dieses Prinzip, da hat uns sozusagen Social Media mit etwas infiziert, dass wir jetzt grundsätzlich durch diese Allgegenwärtigkeit von Kommunikation nicht mehr rausbekommen.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja...
Und das ist ein interessanter, wichtiger Punkt.
Ja, natürlich, aber wir wissen ja auch von Luhmann, dass Sinn in gewisser Weise... Also die Suche nach Sinn, der Versuch ist, Komplexität zu bewältigen, ja. Und das findet dann hier auch statt. Und Sinn liegt dann darin, dass man eine Seite bezieht und gegen die andere kämpft. Und das schafft natürlich dann auch eine neue Übersichtlichkeit, um mit dieser Komplexität in irgendeiner Weise klarzukommen.
Aber dann schließt er eben direkt an, die neue Übersichtlichkeit kommt eben darüber, dass wir die Sachdimensionen unserer politischen Diskussion eigentlich komplett freigeräumt haben. Austauschbar, ist eigentlich alles nur noch beliebig. Was aber dafür nicht beliebig ist, ist die Sozialdimension.
Ja.
Wer spricht? Also wenn man durch einen, was weiß ich, man ist irgendwo im öffentlichen Raum und sieht in einem Fernsehen, der aber auf leise geschaltet ist, um niemanden zu stören, Friedrich Merz macht eine Ansage oder Alice Weidel sagt irgendwas, dann ist man sofort getriggert und denkt sich, Scheiße, was hat die jetzt schon wieder gesagt? Welche Polarisierung wird jetzt schon wieder aufgemacht? Niemand erwartet eine inhaltliche Aufklärung oder erwartet, dass man Alice Weidel Spruch hört und sich dann denkt, naja, wusste ich ja schon. Klar, wussten wir das alles schon. Aber dieses mitlaufende Programm der Polarisierung, angestarrt durch Social-Media-Erfahrung, hinter das die Journalisten nicht wieder zurückkommen, und wenn man ehrlich ist, diese politischen Podcasts, über die wir uns immer lustig machen, laufen komplett darüber. Das ist ja keine inhaltliche Aufklärung, sondern es ist ja der Sing-Sang von Rosenfeld, Dagmar Rosenfeld, ein Thema aufzuwerfen und dann an Robin Alexander überzuleiten, mit irgendeiner Variante der Frage, und warum ist das jetzt für wen ein Problem? Und dann sagt er, ja, das ist jetzt für Friedrich Merz ein besonders großes Problem, weil jetzt ist wieder Mobilisierung auf der anderen Seite wirklich, und das ist natürlich blöd, und das muss er wieder, und so weiter. Und es läuft alles auf der Ebene. Und das einmal deutlich klar, diese Hinweise zu bekommen in so einem Text, halte ich schon für sehr wichtig. Also das ist wirklich, das ist ein richtig gelungenes zweites Kapitel zu Social Media.
Okay, das dritte Kapitel ist wahrscheinlich noch besser, wie du meinen wirst. Da setzt er sich ja dann auseinander mit so Äußerungen wie Kinder statt Inder von Norbert Rutgers oder Glamour ist Deutschland von Friedrich Merz und sagt dann, ja, die Polarisierung liegt in der Logik des Systems. Es sind also die Vertreter von Regierung und Opposition, um das in der Sprache der Systemtheorie zu sagen, Leistungsrollenträger, die in ihrer Kommunikation hauptsächlich aneinander anschließen und auf das so ausgeschlossene Publikum vor allem legitimierend Bezug nehmen. Also indem man sagt, ihr seid Gilamos oder mir geht es um eure Kinder statt um die Inder, versuche ich natürlich ein an sich ausgeschlossenes Publikum, sie sind Repräsentanten, ja, aber eigentlich haben sie dann auch das Publikum wieder ausgeschlossen nach der Wahl, dann doch wieder mit hineinzunehmen. Und die Spaltung ist also von Nöten, damit man überhaupt Politik betreiben kann. Denn sonst müsste man ja sich hinstellen und sagen, es gibt ja gar keine Polarisierung. Und jetzt ist ja interessant, wenn wir zum Beispiel auf jemanden blicken, der immer sagt, ich will keine Spaltung, also jemand wie Robert Haber, der ja eine massive Spaltung erzeugt, dadurch, dass er sagt, ich will keine Spaltung, denn wir sind ja für die Vernunft, für den Fortschritt und für Wirtschaftswachstum. Bedeutet also, dass all jene, die jetzt nicht mit Habeck d'accord gehen, sagen, das ist absolut der Gegner, denn der sagt ja, ich bin offenbar gegen Wirtschaftswachstum, gegen Vernunft und gegen die Gemeinschaft. Das heißt also, wir kommen, also das zeigt noch mal sehr gut, wir kommen gar nicht aus einer Polarisierung raus, selbst wenn wir es wie Habeck als der Große Einende versuchen. Im Gegenteil, man könnte eher sagen, das kann sogar noch die Abwehr verstärken, weil man sagt, ja, ach so, dann bin ich jetzt offenbar nicht gerade dazu gehörig.
Und genauso ist es auch dann, dass wenn die Klimabewegungen zum Beispiel gerade niemanden in der Politik haben, den sie unterstützen können, also wenn die Grünen nicht regieren, wenn die nicht in der Regierung sind, dann hat die Klimabewegung die Möglichkeit, mit den Grünen auch zu paktieren und zu sagen, wir müssen den Merkel-Leuten ordentlich Dampf machen. Sobald die Grünen aber dann zur Regierung zählen, können die Klimaleute nicht mehr mit den Grünen das zusammen ausagieren, weil dann plötzlich eine Opposition auch entstehen muss.
Genau. Hier kann man mal, also das ist ganz anschauliche Soziologie. Ich versuche es jetzt mal richtig runterzubrechen, darauf, was ich gelesen habe. Und dann kann jeder, der hier zuhört, mal entscheiden, ob das zum einen plausible, lehrreiche Soziologie ist und ob man das in dem Buch tatsächlich so wiederfindet. Aber ich würde sagen, ja, das steckt so im Text. Also, wir haben, es beginnt alles mit einem Thema. Jemand macht einen Themenvorschlag, weil er die Welt verbessern will und so weiter. Und wir haben aber jetzt schon festgestellt, wir leben nicht in diesem Paradies der großen Eintracht, sondern die Produktion von Sinnen läuft über Differenzen. Am Anfang war das Licht, oh, was ist mit der Dunkelheit? Am Anfang war Adam, oh, was ist mit der Frau? Also jeder versucht, also alles provoziert sofort zu einer Unterscheidung. Und die kann man irgendwie problematisieren. Und dann ist man ja schon gleich mittendrin. So, wir haben also ein Thema auf einer Sachdimension. Aber, wie eben schon aufgeschlüsselt, es ist ja sehr entscheidend, wer spricht. Wenn Alice Weidel spricht, ist das viel wichtiger, dass sie spricht, als das, was sie sagt. Weil wir dann schon wissen, scheiße, jetzt hat Alice Weidel wieder was gesagt, jetzt müssen wir wieder dagegen halten und so. So, wir haben also jetzt ein Thema, das von der Sachdimension als Problem auf die Sozialdimension rutscht. In der Sozialdimension wird jetzt aufgeschlüsselt Regierung und Opposition, also wer spricht? Die Regierung macht einen Vorschlag, dann wissen wir sofort. Mal gucken, was die Grünen dazu sagen. Die AfD fordert irgendwas. Mal gucken, was Merz jetzt dazu sagt. Also so dieses Prinzip. Und jetzt fehlt ja noch die Zeitdimension als dritte. Und jetzt sagt er, naja, was wir auf jeden Fall sehen, und das hat ja Dietmar Daertzsch damals schon gesagt, das Partizipationstheater um das Parlament herum beeindruckt das Parlament nicht. Sommerpause heißt, auch wenn ganz viele politische Themen da sind, es findet keine Sitzung statt. So, wenn abends 18 Uhr ein Zug entgleist, also wenn sich der Bundestag notfallmäßig trifft, ist es trotzdem erst 10 Uhr morgens, zu regulären Sitzungsbeginn und so weiter und so fort. Also es findet eine Entzerrung in der Zeitdimension statt. In der nämlich gesagt wird, ne, der Parlamentarische Prozess wird hier mal eingehalten. So, wir haben es aber schon mit problematischen politischen Themen zu tun, die schon Sprecher in der Bevölkerung haben. Und nun läuft sehr viel über Abwehr und über Polarisierung wird Dringlichkeit erzeugt. Und die Dringlichkeit wirkt nun sehr negativ auf die eigentlichen Vorteile, nämlich wir halten uns hier an Prozess und Ablauf und so. Legitimation durch Verfahren. Genau, weil dann steht plötzlich der Kanzlerkandidat da und sagt, am Tag eins, ne, eigentlich würde ich schon früher, aber noch darf ich ja nicht. Aber sobald, ich mache es gleicher als allererstes. Und ich achte auch nicht auf die anderen, ja. Also das ist ein ganz typischer Effekt von Polarisierung. Und den beschreibt ihr jetzt ganz wunderbar. Denn diese Polarisierung läuft darüber, dass sich nicht jemand für etwas einsetzt, sondern gegen etwas. Der Kanzler sagt, ich bin dagegen. Ja, ich habe es ja schon mal beschrieben an, der Bundespräsident hält eine Rede gegen Antisemitismus. Also denken sich die Leute, die den Staat eh scheiße finden, ach so, ja, dann bin ich jetzt Antisemit. Weil so kann ich den Bundespräsidenten ärgern. Und das ist ja das, was ich eigentlich will. Eigentlich ganz einfaches Prinzip. So, diese Abwehr läuft aber in dem ein, und das schreibt er hier, ein imaginiertes politisches Projekt, der Gegenseite synthetisiert wird. Was eben bedeutet, wenn in Amerika sich alle aufregen, dass sich Leute darüber aufregen, dass Sidney Sweeney eine Werbeplakat-Kampagne hat, in der Jeans mit Jeans verwechselt wird, also ihre blaue Jeans mit ihren tollen Genen, die sie hat. Dann braucht es dafür gar keinen Woken-Aufstand, damit die Anti-Woken sich auf Fox News über diese synthetisierte politische Gegenkampagne aufregen können, weil die haben sie ja nur synthetisiert. Und so läuft relativ viel. Einfach über synthetisierte und so weiter. Also das auch bei dem ganzen Woken-Anti-Woke-Diskurs. Und da finde ich, ich mache dieses Buch ja wirklich hervorragende Aufklärung, weil das sind einfach nur kleine Schritte. Du hast ein Thema, Sachdimension. Es wechselt auf die Sozialdimension. Uns interessiert, wer spricht. Dann ist es ein politisches Thema. Es wird also in den parlamentarischen Prozess, der viel so langsam ist, also muss da Dringlichkeit eingebracht werden. Und zack, weil der Tweet jetzt gleich geschrieben werden muss, ist Polarisierung.
Dann kommt er auf Johannes Agnoli zu sprechen, der ein von Marx geprägter Denker ist. Er sagt, Agnoli betrachtet die parlamentarische Demokratie gewissermaßen als Verstaatlichung des potenziell gesellschaftsbringenden Widerspruchs zwischen Kapital und Arbeit. Sie integriert die eigentlich Ausgeschlossenen. Das heißt, die Kritik von Agnoli an der parlamentarischen Demokratie ist natürlich, dass dadurch der Widerspruch eingehegt wird und dann auf so einen parlamentarischen Diskurs gebracht wird, bei dem aber der eigentliche Widerspruch von Kapital und Arbeit dann immer weiter zum Verschwinden gerät. Agnoli ist natürlich auch gewisserweise durch Karl Schmidt geprägt und denkt dort natürlich mehr in der Gegnerschaft. Also da wird eine Regression durch eine Inklusion erzeugt. Die Widersprüche werden gezähmt und damit findet so eine Domestikation durch die Institutionen statt, was dann dazu führt, dass der parlamentarische, demokratische Apparat integrative Kraft hat, zugleich aber auch das wirklich Radikale, also den eigentlichen Klassenkampf, wir wissen alle Parteien wären gerne Volksparteien, ja, exkludiert. Und das bedeutet aber auch wieder, dass in dieser Struktur eigentlich ja eine Polarisierung liegt. Und diese wird aber dann von vielen gar nicht als solche wahrgenommen, wenn man sagt, ja, das ist doch hier die offene Gesellschaft. Wir haben im Parlament doch alles sitzen.
Jetzt können wir ja zum einen sagen, das finden wir gar nicht so gut. Also dass die Power der Arbeiterschaft über Gewerkschaftsfunktionseliten da so gezähmt wurde. So schlecht wir das finden, müssen wir trotzdem anerkennend sagen, das hat 100 Jahre ganz schön gut, erfolgreich funktioniert. Weil das ist ja das Problem der Gegenwart, dass wir eine Arbeiterschaft haben, von der wir immer noch unterstellen, dass sie den eigentlichen volkswirtschaftlichen Mehrwert bietet, aber die nicht genug Lohn dafür bekommt zum Beispiel.
Aber dann hat es ja nicht gut funktioniert.
Das Einhegen der Gesellschaft und die Ruhe der Gesellschaft.
Die Ruhe hat funktioniert, aber es hat ja nicht funktioniert, dass dadurch eine wirklich integrative Kraft für die Arbeiter zustande gekommen ist. Es gab ein paar Verbesserungen, und die räumt man jetzt so nach und nach wieder ab.
Ja, aber unter Befriedungsgesichtspunkten hat es sehr gut funktioniert.
Ja, das gibt es nicht.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie konnte das eigentlich gelingen? Und dann macht er ja nach Social Media, Politik, also alles, was ich eben beschrieben habe und was du jetzt beschrieben hast, kommt er mal ganz explizit auf die Journalisten zu sprechen.
Ja.
Die Journalisten haben ein Gebot der Neutralität, der Objektivität. Die verorten sich immer in der Mitte, die dann beide Seiten und so. Ja. Und seine Schlussfolgerung, nachdem er das hier beschreibt, ist einfach der Nationalstaat kommt gar nicht ohne Polarisierung aus. Und sei es die Polarisierung nach außen, also wir haben einen gemeinsamen Feind irgendwo, dann ist Krieg oder so, wie auch immer. Und der Journalismus durch seine Neutralität validiert die Pole der Polarisierung. Er sagt also beispielsweise bei den Lohnsachen, also auf der einen Seite stehen Arbeitgeber, die sagen, wir wollen gar nicht so viel bezahlen. Und auf der anderen Seite sagt man dann einfach, und da stehen aber Wissenschaftler, die sagen, die können auch gar nicht so viel bezahlen. Und damit wird diese Unterscheidung validiert, statt einfach zu sagen, ja, man könnte doch einfach die Arbeitnehmer mal fragen. Also Arbeitgeber Arbeitnehmer als Polarisierung aufschlüsseln. Und da muss ich sagen, ja, das ist das hier, das größte Gebot des Journalismus als die größte, wie soll man sagen, Verirrung oder Falle für sein Argument im Sinne von, nee, man kommt ja aus Polarisierung nicht raus, man könnte sie aber richtiger, konstruktiver organisieren. Und das finden wir aber nicht im Journalismus. Also wir müssen es genau anders machen als der Journalismus. Also nicht so eine Neutralisierung.
Ja, das heißt, man muss auf eine, und das finde ich da auch sehr gut, der Ergebnis sagt, man muss von einer Position aus ja sowieso sprechen und kann nicht von dieser scheinbar neutralen Ebene sprechen, weil die sieht dann so aus, wir fragen Arbeitgeber und danach fragen wir Veronika Grimm und dann haben wir auch noch die Wissenschaft abgedeckt für die Kapitalinteressen, sondern bedeutet natürlich, dass man sich auf eine Position begeben kann, muss geradezu, um das zu erkennen. Und das ist aber schon interessant, dass dieses Neutralitätsgebot jetzt ja gerade so in Anschlag gebracht wird, um zu unterstreichen, dass so eigentlich eine Polarisierung überwunden werden könnte. Also so in den vorherrschenden Diskursen und dass wir jetzt hier nochmal gesagt bekommen, nein, das ist eigentlich anders, ist schon sehr richtig. Ja, ja, da stimme ich zu und auch, dass wir natürlich diese massenmedialen Empörungen ja gar nicht außerhalb der massenmedien auch wahrnehmen können. Also das ist natürlich die Realität der massenmedien von Luhmann, dass wir, wenn wir über Politik, Öffentlichkeit, all das reden, das massenmedial vermittelt bekommen. Insofern können wir die Welt auch nur so wahrnehmen, also wenn wir die ganze Zeit auf Polarisierung stoßen und da wirklich immer wieder klar zu machen, dass das aber das Prinzip des Systems eigentlich ist, das ist mir eigentlich auch sehr, sehr recht, das so zu betrachten. Er kommt ja auch auf die Talkshows zu sprechen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das ist ganz, ganz lustig auch deshalb, weil er, ich zitiere das mal, an einem Beispiel festmacht. Und zwar schreibt er da über Hart aber Fair. Du warst ja auch da schon zu Gast. So sitzen dann zum Beispiel in der Sendung Hart aber Fair am 29. Januar 2024 drei Politikerinnen, die sich über die richtige Antwort auf die Frage streiten, wer unser Land angesichts von Wut, Protesten und neuen Parteien eigentlich noch zusammenhält. Sie geben sich selbstverständlich, was sollten sie in der Situation auch anders tun, gegenseitig die Schuld daran, dass diese Frage überhaupt gestellt werden muss. Eine Friseurstudio-Besitzerin erklärt, sie fühle sich von der Politik allein gelassen. Eine Unternehmerin meldet den Wunsch an, Politik möge wieder führen und beklagt damit nicht zuletzt den Streit der Anwesenden über Polarisierung als die Polarisierung selbst. Ein Soziologe merkt an, dass es mit Spaltung gar nicht so weit her sei. Kurz, alle zusammenführen genau die Polarisierung auf, um die sie sich gemeinsam sorgen. Und die Pointe nun des Ganzen ist, die bekommen wir dann in einer Fußnote erklärt, auch das sei noch an dieser Stelle zitiert, da nämlich heißt es, der Umstand, dass der Soziologe in diesem Falle ich war, sollte unterstreichen, dass es mir mitnichten darum geht, die Beteiligten dafür zu verurteilen. Gerade wenn man in einer solchen Sendung sitzt, wird einem deutlich, wie groß die strukturierende Kraft des Formats ist, gegen die man kaum anrennen kann, ohne sie dabei zu stützen. Manchmal freuen sich Leute, wenn wir in einer Talkshow sind, und das ist ja auch schön, aber manchmal ist auch eine Enttäuschung da, dass man nicht das ganze Konzept umreißen konnte. Stefan geht aus Hart aber Fair raus und die Schuldenbremse ist passé oder so. Oder dass man jetzt den ganzen Diskurs völlig stören konnte. Also man kann natürlich einmal ausrasten dort und dann ist für immer Schluss, dann hat man einen schönen Fernsehmoment produziert. Aber diese Formatstarre und die Strukturstarre, die dort einfach vorherrscht, die aber in dem System der Talkshow an sich liegt. Genau und sorgt dafür, dass manches da gar nicht möglich ist. Also dort den vernünftigen anderen Diskurs zu erwarten als den der Polarisierung und des Aufeinanderklaffens von irgendwelchen halbbaren Meinungen ist gar nicht anders denkbar.
Ja, wir sind ja da immer noch mit jedes politischen Journalismus. Auch wenn nicht alle Sprecher Journalisten sind, sondern bei Hard-to-Affair auch mal jemand eingeladen wird. Aber dann hat er beschrieben gerade, wie die Stellanheit des Formats dich immer wieder einordnet. Nun könnte man das ja aufbrechen, indem man sagt, erst mal eine Aufklärung darüber, dass der erste, der hier Zusammenhalt fordert oder Verständigung oder was auch immer, fliegt raus. Ja, wir wollen das nicht.
Das wird schon gut.
Es ist die Frage, wie weit man es treiben kann in dem Buch hier jetzt als Vorschlag sehr weit. Also gegen die Affirmation. Ich hatte das ja auch, dass dann wir gegenüber, sah es ja Kubicki und Dorothee Bär, die natürlich die ganze Zeit nur, das hört man ja schon in, wie sie reden, dass sie Opa Erna zu Hause die Botschaft geben. Also mit mir an Status Spitze wird es abends immer genug Geruhsamkeit geben. Wir können alle zufrieden ins Bett gehen. Da drüben sitzen schon wieder die, die so stumpf machen und so. Dagegen will man sich ja wehren. Also das ist ja auch Mitformat, dass da die Hälfte der Politiker das einfach mitträgt. Und jetzt eine Botschaft an alle, die es immer noch nicht glauben wollen, wie weit man es treiben kann. Aber zu diesem, und ich springe mal zurück an den Anfang des Buches, zu dem Overview-Effekt. Wenn auf Demonstrationen für stärkeren Klimaschutz die blaue Murmel mitgeführt wird, dann ist das, wie die Berufung auf die Wissenschaft, also Listen to the Science, eine politische und damit konfliktorientierte Handlung. Sie richtet sich nämlich an Leuten, die ihre eigene Wissenschaft damit bringen. Die Berufung auf den Overview-Effekt, also dieses geruhsame, können wir nicht alle mal und so weiter zur Besinnung kommen, als Evidenz einer über den Parteien dieses Streits stehenden Wahrheit ist selbst ein Einsatz in diesem Streit und dokumentiert damit auch dessen Wahrheit. Was ich finde, sollte man auch mal gegen die AfD in Anklang bringen, weil die AfD kommt ja immer sehr mit diesem Nicht-Zusammenhalt, also jetzt in der Gegenwart wollen sie schon in diesen Konflikt, den forcieren sie sehr gut, aber die kommen ja immer mit diesem Unsere Zukunft sollte genauso schön sein wie unsere Vergangenheit. Und da muss man halt da rein torpedieren. Aufklärung über die Vergangenheit, sie war nie schön, der Krieg war scheiße, alles war scheiße, mein Leben ohne Smartphone war scheiße. Wenn Alice Weidel sagt, Deutschland aber normal, ich will es wie in den 90ern, dann muss man den Wählern sagen, ja dann gebt mal alle eure Smartphones ab. Eure EC-Karten her, ihr zahlt nur noch mit Bargeld. So, mal gucken, wie dann die AfD Leute. Also man muss diese Polarisierung forcieren, statt denen das einfach durchgehen zu lassen, dass irgendwer immer den Vorschlag macht, unter mir Einheit, Paradies, Zusammenhalt und so.
Ja, ich meine, jetzt beginnt ja bald die Frankfurter Buchmesse. Ich glaube, wenn wir für jedes Buch, das die Demokratie retten will, 100 Euro bekämen, müssten wir jahrelang nicht mehr arbeiten. Das ist genau das, immer nur in diese Richtung. Wir müssen uns ein bisschen sputen, damit wir noch zu Gilda Sahebi kommen. Jedenfalls finde ich wirklich lobenswert, dass er dem Reckwitz eins mitgibt. Er sagt von Robert Habeck und Christian Lindner, über Lars Klingbeil bis zu Sarah Wagenknecht und Friedrich Merz. Wir haben sie damals mit Fotos gesehen. Alle haben sie das Buch von Reckwitz gelesen. Er sagt, für auf verschiedenen Seiten der von Reckwitz behaupteten Spaltung zu verordnenden Politikerinnen à la Couleur, scheint es politisch gleichermaßen attraktiv, ihre jeweiligen Programme als Beitrag zur Versöhnung dieser beiden Lager zu präsentieren. Jeder liest gerade das Buch, indem er noch mal gesagt bekommt, Herr Stimpf, ihr müsst diese Spaltung da mal überwinden.
Ihr erleidet keinen Verlust. Es war einfach und so weiter.
Es geht ja um dieses Buch der verlorenen Illusionen und Bücher der Singularität.
Ihr seid einfach alle ganz individuell.
Das ist schon ganz lustig, dass er das macht. Teilst du mit mir wenigstens diese Kritik, dass diese sehr lange Ausführung dazu, Murray Rothbard, jetzt nicht so viel Neues uns gebracht hat. Das ist einer der Vordenker der Rechten, was wir heute in den USA erleben. Der hat schon so eine Polarisierungsrede gehalten. Das war noch mal so durchexorziert, aber das ist jetzt nicht zwingend notwendig, in diesem Buch zu haben.
Er erwähnt es kurz, weil diese Rede Strategy for the Right damals schon voraus sah, wie es funktioniert. Was eben bedeutet, die Rechten polarisieren programmatisch, die machen das bewusst. Da sind Strategien dahinter, finde ich schon nicht schlecht. Weil typischerweise im Journalismus immer, ja, aber ist da nicht doch was dran und so. Als würde Alice Weidel aus ihrem Gefühl heraus jetzt für die Somewheres irgendwie sprechen in Brandenburg. Und da muss man sagen, ne, ne, die folgt diesem Drehbuch von dem Rothbart.
Naja, ich würde nicht sagen, die folgt dem Drehbuch, sondern das ist einfach die, also du hättest jetzt auch 50 andere Texte dieser Art aus der Zeit rauskramen können.
Aber so lange ist das doch gar nicht.
Wo das immer dann präsent ist sowas, das sind halt wiederkehrende Muster. Dann fand ich noch eigentlich interessanter, wie dann nochmal Anjoli aufgerufen wird, auch nochmal um Francis Fukuyama ein bisschen anders einzuschätzen. Nämlich insofern Francis Fukuyama ja nicht davon ausgegangen ist einfach, dass das Ende der Geschichte eintritt und damit ist vollständige Ruhe, sondern Fukuyama sagt dann, dass möglicherweise die Langeweile die Menschen dazu bringen könnte, dass sie wieder Polarisierung und Konflikt und alles wollen. Und daraufhin sagt dann Anjoli, dass es aber nicht die Langeweile sein wird. Die liberale Demokratie selbst nämlich gerät in eine Integrations- und damit in eine Legitimationskrise, wenn sie den Widerspruch zwischen Politik und ihrem Publikum nicht mehr in sich selbst abbilden kann. Damit navigiert sie, könnte man nach Anjolis Überlegung festhalten, zwischen der Involusion zur konstitutionellen Oligarchie und Konflikten, die in ihrem Rahmen nicht gemanagt werden können. Und wenn sie denn gemanagt würden, so Anjolis sadonische Poante, setzte gerade dadurch eine Dynamik ein, die wieder auf die konstitutionelle Oligarchie hintriebe. Also es kann gar nicht in einer liberalen Demokratie so sein, dass dann eine Ruhe einkehrt oder so etwas, sondern es muss eigentlich der Konflikt fortwährend ausgesetzt werden.
Genau, er rettet Fokuyama nochmal, im Sinne von er wurde falsch gelesen.
Ja.
Denn die Unterscheidung bleibt, es ist nur welthistorisch diese eine Unterscheidung, die sehr viel geprägt hat, nämlich zwischen Marktwirtschaft und dann Planwirtschaft, die wurde aufgelöst, was eben nur bedeutete, dass ich, und das ist ja schon dankbar, dass er das ganze Kapitel ohne Dialektik und so auskommt. Sondern dass er einfach sagt, nein, ein Pol reicht halt nicht, man braucht immer eine Unterscheidung. Wenn man etwas politisch diskutiert, hat man immer diesen Dreiklang aus dem Thema, das wird auf die Sachdimensionen geschrieben und dann wird eine zeitliche Dringlichkeit reingebaut. Also das finde ich hervorragend, das validiert diesen Fukuyama nochmal. Und dann macht er ja eine ganz große, er beschreibt ja mal ein richtig großes Desiderat, was eine Theorie des Rechtspopulismus bräuchte. Für den Fall, dass irgendwer hier auf Abschlussarbeits-Themasuche ist. Er schreibt, selbstverständlich bietet dieses Kapitel keine umfassende Theorie des Rechtspopulismus. Die müsste neben der, erstens, Transformation der Klassenstruktur, ja, hast du sie gleich ganz oben, der betreffenden nationalen Gesellschaften, mindestens auch die, zweitens, veränderten Kommunikations- und Organisationsstrukturen der politischen Öffentlichkeit, die, drittens, Renationalisierung der Geopolitik und nicht zuletzt die, viertens, historische Spezifik der liberalen Demokratie umfassen, die als idealisierte Selbstbeschreibung und als institutionalisiertes oder institutionelles Ensemble den Gegenpol des Rechtspopulismus bildet. Also man muss sich nochmal neu darüber verständigen, was wir hier verteidigen, aus der Perspektive des Rechtspopulismus und wie er die Gesellschaft sieht, also wirklich hervorragend, das mal so zu fassen.
Die rechte Politik sagt ja auch, es ist ein seltsam klassenloser Klassenkampf.
Genau.
Das ist ja eine richtige Schilderung.
Die machen nämlich das Große, die Ver-Entklassifizierung einer Polarisierung. Das MAGA-Projekt ist das große Projekt, Polarisierung zu machen, aber ohne Klasse. Kulturkampf, falsche Arenen bespielen, Geschichte neu schreiben und der ganze Kramme. Und deswegen ist seine Antwort darauf so rührend, perfekt einfach auf die Welt zu kommen. Denn er beschreibt es, ich habe das hier so als letzte Notiz, kann sein, dass danach ein Buch noch was folgt, aber wie auch immer. Aus dieser Problemstellung geht für die politische Soziologie nicht oder zumindest nicht prima die Aufgabe vor einer solchen imaginären Partei, die also dem Rechtspopulismus die Levitnen lösen kann, das Programm zu schreiben. Stattdessen muss sie zunächst einmal festhalten, dass eine mögliche Alternative zur Alternative vom Standpunkt der bestehenden politischen Ordnung aus betrachtet, problematisch, wenn nicht gar gefährlich aussehen muss. Und wie bekommt man eine Gefahr wieder rein, wenn wir doch diagnostizieren, dass im Rechtspopulismus Milliardäre und Millionäre einen klassen- oder entklassifizierten polarisierungsvulgär Klassenkampf führen. Na, indem man die ökonomischen Fragen zentral stellt, aber nicht in der politischen Soziologie, die das beobachtet, sondern in der Politik, die von dieser Soziologie beobachtet wird. Also die Forderung ist ganz klar, der Wahlkampf zuletzt von der linken Bar zeigt uns mal eure Mietverträge. Der nächste Wahlkampf muss aggregiert. Wir haben uns alle Mietverträge angeschaut. Wir müssen alle Vermieter enteignen, weil dann wird es richtig gefährlich. Und dann muss man die Wähler vor die Wahl stellen. Also du kannst jetzt weiter den Kulturkampf deiner Milliardäre führen. Oder aber wir machen dich einfach reicher. Wie wäre es? Maurice Höfken bei Ron Zeilmeier. Also mein Angebot war der Subtext der ganzen halben Stunde. Also mein Angebot ist, wir machen es einfach mal vernünftig und werden dann alle reicher. Wer kann denn da was dagegen haben? Na, wir wissen, wer was dagegen hat. Und wir wissen auch, wie die Grammatik schon personell aufgestellt sind.
Genau, aber dann müsste man ja eigentlich da auch schon voll reingehen und sagen, hier ist der Kampf.
Sag das nicht dem Soziologen, sag das dem Politiker.
Du bist ja jetzt soziologisch aufgewachsen. Nein, ich rede auch gerade schon von etwas anderem. Ich rede jetzt davon, dass man dann, weil wir beobachten jetzt ja in vielen Büchern über Ungleichheit oder so, dass doch wieder so versucht wird, eine Gemeinschaft darüber herzustellen. Also dass man sagt, wir haben da eigentlich eine schöne Gemeinschaft. Wir können da auch, wir haben nur so ein paar Milliardäre, die ein Problem sind. Das ist auch wieder ein Problem. Wenn man dann sagt, ich habe noch so ein paar Delinquente, die heißen Elon Musk und Co., die sind für mich problematisch. Und da müsste man mal an die Superjacht ran. Aber sonst ist wieder alles gut. Dann kommt man nicht dahin. Und das ist aber jetzt nicht ein Vorwurf, den ich Kumkar machen will, sondern das beobachte ich jetzt wieder allgemein, dass man zwar die Ungleichheit thematisiert, aber dann doch glaubt, man hätte eigentlich dann, wenn man so ein paar Steuerprivilegien fallen lässt, wieder eine gut funktionierende, wärmende Gesellschaft, in der sich alle gut verstehen. Und da gibt es eben grundsätzlichen Widerspruch zwischen Kapital und Arbeit. Und ich bin mir doch sicher, dass auch wenn das hier eine sehr gute Beschreibung ist der rechten Politik, dass man auch noch mal weiter käme, wenn man einige zum Beispiel auch Social-Media-Diskussionen noch mal damit koppeln würde, dass eben da sehr viele Leute gerade schreiben, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen und noch mal ein Freiheitsgefühl erfahren, in der Weise, dass sie sich jetzt da einmischen in eine Debatte, die sie sonst aber realitar, wenn sie zum Beispiel zu ihrem Job gehen, nicht vorfinden. Und das wäre meine Kritik daran. Ich sage nicht, bitte gib mir mal ein paar Handlungsmuster, sondern ich glaube, dass man das damit hätte noch verstärken können, wo er ja absolut Recht hat und wo er auch dann eine große Klarheit gewinnt gegen Ende des Buches. Denn manches ist schon in fürchterlichen soziologischen Verklausulosien.
Nein, es ist einfach ganz klar, Gomet Hillsbough.
Es ist an sich klar in seiner Struktur, aber du wirst jetzt mir zustimmen, dass da einige Formulierungen schon auf Bandwurmsätze ausgelegt sind, bei denen man sagt, das müsste nicht sein. Ich will sagen, am Ende gewinnt er große Klarheit. Wenn er zum Beispiel sagt, diese Polarisierung müsste viel mehr als Zuspitzung gesellschaftlich angelegter Konflikte, diese Normalitätsvorstellungen selbst provoduktiv irritieren. Also alle, die jetzt sagen, ja, wir wollen mal wieder so die Mitte und normal und bla, bla, bla. Da muss man sagen, nein, da geht man jetzt rein, da irritiert man jetzt. Also genau nicht das. Du hast es ja wunderbar vorgeführt, was wir gehört haben von dem Grünen-Vorsitzenden Banaschak im ARD-Sommer-Interview. Der sagt ja hier, ich habe da mal so ein Angebot und wir sind auch links, aber natürlich nicht radikal. Also radikal, wo es an die Wurze geht, aber nicht extrem und bla, bla, bla. Damit kommt man natürlich nicht weiter. Da möchte man eigentlich der Normalitätsvorstellung entsprechen. Und Kumkar sagt jetzt, man muss die Normalitätsvorstellung irritieren.
Du musst gefährlich sein.
Ja.
Und die Frage ist nur, gefährlich für wen. Und das können wir eindeutig fordern, für wen man gefährlich sein will.
Da bin ich sehr froh. Ich wünsche mir manchmal, dass das Buch ein paar Seiten kürzer wäre und dann wären vielleicht auch diese Sätze ein bisschen klarer herausgekommen. Aber lass, ja, du, ich weiß, du, du hast dich jetzt darauf eingeschossen, dass alles großartig ist. Aber lass mich noch eine kurze Überlegung zum Schluss mitgeben, denn da steckt ja noch was ganz Kleines drin.
Ja.
Noch ein kleines Geschenk ganz am Ende. Und zwar heißt es da Polarisierung per se wird das weder verhindern noch befördern. Vielmehr wird Polarisierung unvermeidlich die politische Verarbeitung des Vorgehens Kennzeichen. Da haben wir schon drüber gesprochen. Und dann heißt es da, man kann das spinnert oder verantwortungslos finden. Aber da gegen die strukturellen Antriebe der Polarisierung sonst wohl nur eine weder wünschenswert noch möglich erscheinende umfangreiche Depolitisierung helfen würde, lautet die Frage am Ende eben so weiter oder weiter so. Das Wort, das ich mir jetzt angestrichen habe, ist Depolitisierung. Es ist doch ganz erstaunlich, dass das ja tatsächlich, auch wenn er sagt, das sei nicht wünschenswert oder auch nicht klar, dass das jetzt erscheinen würde, dass er das nochmal nennt. Und ich denke mir, ja, das gibt es natürlich auch als Konzept. Und wenn wir uns die 90er Jahre oder auch noch die frühen Nullerjahre ansehen, auch gerade mal wenn wir uns auf den Humor der damaligen Zeit, Bully, Stefan Raab und sowas anziehen, dann war das ja tatsächlich Ausdruck einer Depolitisierung. Womit ich nicht meine, das waren unpolitische Zeiten, sondern da fand ja ganz viel statt. Schlimmes statt, Agenda 2010 etc. Aber es war eben nicht eine stark polarisierte Diskussion, weil man sich einfach gar nicht dafür interessiert hat. Also ich kann mich zum Beispiel erinnern, als ich Abi gemacht habe oder so, waren politische Diskussionen nicht präsent. Also da musste schon wirklich viel passieren. Da musste schon eine Bundestagswahl oder was sein, um da überhaupt eine politisierte Diskussion zu erleben. Und das will ich jetzt auch nicht als Utopie hier anmalen, aber ich finde es nochmal ganz interessant, dass es offenbar auch zu gewissen Zeiten zumindest möglich ist, in einer Gesellschaft zu leben, in der das Politische so aus dem öffentlichen Diskurs rausgedrängt ist, dass man sich am Ende doch nur fragt, wird Verona Feldbusch bei Big Brother einziehen, wird Stefan Raab noch eine dritte Fernsehsendung machen und wann kommt der neue Bully-Film. Es ist interessant.
Genau und deswegen können wir ganz versöhnlich hier schließen und sagen, ja, als nächstes muss eine repolitisierende Aufklärung über die ökonomischen Zustände in Deutschland her, aber nicht in Buchform, sondern direkt als Wahlprogramm. Von daher ist das nicht die Aufgabe des Soziologen, sondern jetzt muss jemand wirklich handeln. Es nützt ja kaum etwas jetzt noch mal ein Buch, in dem das so aufgeschlüsselt wird, damit wir sagen können, voll gut und so, sondern jetzt einfach ein Wahlprogramm. Und die Linken, die jetzt angefangen haben mit diesem, wir gucken uns mal die Mietverträge an, ich hoffe, dass sie da einfach mal jetzt große Schlüsse daraus ziehen. Und zwar nicht nur hinsichtlich, was sollen wir ins Programm schreiben, sondern auch welche Forderungen sollen wir jetzt mal grundsätzlich so formulieren.
Zur Depolitisierung werden wir nochmal gleich zurückkommen, wenn ich von Leif Randt den neuen Roman vorstelle, denn dort wird tatsächlich der Versuch einer Depolitisierung unternommen. Aber erst wollen wir noch über Verbinden statt Spalten eine Antwort auf die Politik der Polarisierung von Gilda Sahebi sprechen. Sahebi hat ein Buch verfasst, in dem sie sagt, dass wir als Menschen doch eigentlich miteinander gut auskommen. Sie bezieht sich da auf Rutger Bregman. Wir sagen, ja, stimmt eigentlich. Und man fragt sich, warum funktioniert das aber dann bei anderen Sachen nicht, zum Beispiel bei Diskussionen im Netz. Das leuchtet hier erstmal ein und ist aber dann trotzdem falsch. Denn was uns ja Rutger Bregman sagt, ist, dass die Menschen im Grunde nicht schlecht sind und sie eigentlich nicht egoistische Monster sind, die sich, wenn sie die Gelegenheit hätten, gegenseitig töten oder aufressen würden. Aber das bedeutet ja nicht, und das ist auch nicht die Schlussfolgerung, finde ich, bei Rutger Bregman, dass man sagt, eigentlich verstehen wir uns alle super, deswegen brauchen wir doch gar nicht so harte politische Auseinandersetzungen. Denn was ja hier passiert, ist ja, dass sich Bregman quasi anthropologische Konstanten anschaut und sieht, Menschen verhalten sich in Krisensituationen so, und dann gibt es so verrückte Machthaber, die kommen immer wieder an die Macht, die sind besonders egoistisch und schamlos und all das. Aber das führt ja nicht dazu, dass er sagt, eigentlich haben wir schon eine klassenlose Gesellschaft, sondern es gibt natürlich Spaltung in der Gesellschaft aufgrund zum Beispiel von Ökonomie. Also um ein Beispiel zu finden, ich kann natürlich mich heute Abend mit jemanden an den Tisch setzen, der Vermieter ist von 150 Wohnungen und gerade über eine Mieterhöhung nachdenkt. Aber ich kann mich mit dem ja auf einer zwischenmenschlichen Ebene nett unterhalten. Nur ist dann in dem Moment vielleicht, wo wir zusammen Wein trinken, keine Spaltung da. Aber an sich ist das natürlich ein Ausdruck von Spaltung der Gesellschaft und hat nämlich auf der einen Seite Vermieter und Mieter sitzen. Bedeutet also, diese Spaltung ist jetzt zunächst einmal sehr stark da. Weshalb, glaube ich, Gilda Sahebi mit ihrem so sehr konstruktiven Vorschlag, dass man eigentlich so zusammenkommen muss, dass das auch dann allen gut tut, fehl geht. Sie sagt, die Herausforderung eines Gemeinwesens ist es, jeden Menschen in dieser Unterschiedlichkeit nicht nur anzuerkennen, sondern wert zu schätzen. Auf staatlicher Ebene drückt sich das in Gesetzen und der staatlichen Ordnung aus. Da würde ich zunächst mal sagen, in den Gesetzen selbst liegt ja schon eine Spaltung, was wir zum Beispiel ja beim Thema Erbschaftssteuer und so, auf das sie ja dann selbst im Buch noch zu sprechen kommt, deutlich erkennen kann. Sie sagt, es existiert keine natürliche Spaltung, ja natürlich in dem Sinne ist die auch nicht, Menschen sind erstmal Menschen, von der aus politisch agiert wird, sondern Politik und Medien erzeugen diese Spaltung im Prinzip auch einfach darum, dass sie behaupten, dass es sie gibt. Und viele Menschen glauben, dass er Realität. Da würde ich aber sagen, ja natürlich gibt es die Intensivierung der Polarisierung durch die Medien und Kumkar klärt ja auch darüber auf. Zugleich aber ist ja die Spaltung eine Reale, die wir erleben, Kapital, Arbeit etc.
Ja, also ich bin, ich habe das Buch schon gerne gelesen, aber ich bin dann doch über Sätze gestolpert, bei denen ich halt grundsätzlich sage, ja ja und deswegen, also fundamental funktioniert das so nicht, sondern wir machen halt, das ist halt wirklich eine Beruhigungspille. Die Beziehung zwischen Menschen schreibt sich basierend fast immer auf Verständnis und miteinander, auf Liebe und Verbindung. Das gilt halt da, wo sichtbare Beziehungen eingegangen werden. Nur ich befinde mich in einer Stadt mit 700.000 Einwohnern und ich muss mit allen irgendwie in einer Beziehung sein, dass wir uns nicht tot schlagen, nur deswegen heißt es noch lange nicht, dass wir uns alle verstehen und miteinander lieben und in Verbindung sind. Und sie kommt dann über die Spaltungserzählung, kennt man ja soweit, und schreit, wer einmal begriffen hat, wie Spaltungserzählungen funktionieren, wird sie durchschauen können. Der erste Schritt ist Wissen. Und ich sage, nee, genau nicht. Also deswegen bin ich ja so dankbar über das Kumkar-Buch, wo das eben aufgeklärt wird. Und ich will nichts zum Thema Arbeit am Selbst hören bei diesem Thema. Also im Sinne von, ne? Ja. Und dieses Finale fand ich dann besonders schade.
Du bist schon beim Finale. Lass noch ein paar Sätze mal. Also sie sagt zum Beispiel, da steckt im Kern das Wir gegen die. Uns geht es besser, wenn es ihnen schlechter geht. Das ist absurd. Eine Gemeinschaft wird es immer besser gehen, wenn es allen Menschen in ihr gut geht. Das stimmt einfach nicht.
Ja, das stimmt nicht. Genau.
Also dem Vermieter, dem ich eine Mietpreisbremse aufprumme, geht es schlechter. Oder wir könnten auf eine andere Ebene geben. Nehmen wir an, ich würde dir mein Auto verkaufen. Dann willst du natürlich einen möglichst niedrigen Preis zahlen. Und ich hätte gerne einen möglichst hohen Preis. Ich werde also sagen, sieh dir diese wunderbare Korrosse an. Das ist so gut wie ein Rolls Royce. Du wirst sagen, na ja, aber ein bisschen runtergekommen ist es schon. Ja, und das ist der der Austausch, den wir führen. Dann werden wir uns irgendwann auf den Preis einigen. Aber wir sind in einer konfligierenden Situation, in der wir da stehen miteinander. Eine Demokratie sagt, sie kann nur überleben, wenn sie allen Menschen ein gutes Leben ermöglicht. Ja, das wäre wünschenswert. Aber wir sehen ja nun wirklich in ganz vielen Demokratien, ohne dass da jetzt die Rechten gleich regieren, dass nicht allen Menschen ein gutes Leben gewährt wird. Also in Frankreich haben wir immer noch keine rechte Regierung. Und trotzdem kann man nicht sagen, den Menschen geht es allen gut.
Ja, ich würde das gerne auch direkt global diskutieren. Also die Demokratie ist nur gut für die Leute, die innerhalb dieser Demokratie leben, wenn überhaupt, denn nirgendwo sonst lässt sich eben gerade durch diese Polarisierung in Regierung, Opposition alles Mögliche normalisieren, wie auch dieser neue Neokolonialismus, den ja zuletzt dann, wie hieß er, unser Entwicklungshilfeminister, der von den 50 Sklaven sprach?
Müller.
Genau, von der CSU, zuletzt, keine zehn Jahre her, dass da einfach gesagt wurde, ne, also Demokratie ist nur für uns so ein bisschen gut, für die restliche Welt zahlt sich das gar nicht so aus, wenn Länder plötzlich politisch so leistungsfähig sind, dass sie da einfach in die Welt hinauf fallen.
Ich glaube, hier werden sie, sie will sich ja mit vor allem dieser affektiven Polarisierung auseinandersetzen und dann kommt sie auf so zwischenmenschliche Begegnungen. Und das ist, um das Beispiel nochmal zu bringen, ich kann natürlich mit jemanden sitzen, der ja Wohnungen vermietet oder irgendein Unternehmen hat, das mit Leiharbeit und weiss weiß ich alles arbeitet und kann mich zwischenmenschlich mit dem irgendwie verstehen und humorvoll austauschen. Aber ich kann dann ja nicht das andere dabei übersehen. Also davon handeln ja eigentlich die Werke von Bertolt Precht, der gute Mensch von Seeschuhe an, handelt davon, dass da eine gut sein will und will eigentlich freigebig sein. Dann merkt sie aber, sobald sie aber Unternehmerin ist, geht das nicht. Dann erfindet sie sich ein alter Ego, das ist immer der Unternehmer, der dann das tut, was ein Unternehmer tut, Lohnkosten senken, Preise erhöhen etc. Und dann schlüpft sie wieder zurück und ihr rollt und sagt, aber jetzt bin ich wieder der gute Mensch. Und das ist der Widerspruch, der nicht geht. Und das muss man ja erst mal klar machen, dass das so nicht funktioniert.
Also affektive Polarisierung ist ein Grundbegriff, den man nicht übernehmen darf, weil er genau diese Differenzierung nicht aufmacht. Der Kumkar so wichtig war, zu sagen, es gibt eine persönliche Meinung und dann gibt es kommunikatives Geschehen. Und die Verbindung dazwischen lässt sich nicht einfach durch, wird hochsummiert, abstrahiert, wie auch immer. Sondern, nee, genau nicht. Das muss man wirklich ganz differenzieren. Wir haben es hier mit zwei Polarisierungs. Menschen haben persönliche Meinung und darüber laufen Polarisierungen, also persönliche Streits, Konflikte in Familien, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es diese politische Polarisierung und die, das ist ja Dreh- und Angelpunkt von Triggerpunkte und so weiter. Diese Verknüpfung sieht man so einfach nicht. Dann macht sie aber, wo sie die affektive Polarisierung so zentral setzt, bei allen anderen Sachen immer wieder den Hinweis, das sei ja konstruiert. Und da kann man einfach nur sagen, es ist alles konstruiert. Niemand sieht irgendetwas. Jeder Wald, den wir in Deutschland haben, ist konstruiert. Jeder Straßenzug, alles, alles, was wir essen, alles. Also einfach alles.
Und das sagt erst mal nichts. Also sie bringt zum Beispiel ein Gespräch, das Wagenknecht mit dem Spiegel führt. Und dann sagt Wagenknecht, die Grünen sind gefährlicher als die AfD. Und dann ist von Sahebi zu lesen, fragte man nun einen Grünen-Anhänger, würde der wahrscheinlich sagen, Opfer, das sind Grüne. Bulli, Sarah Wagenknecht, Retter, möglicherweise die Wähler. Eine Grünen-Politikerin würde vielleicht sagen, Opfer, die Wähler. Bulli, Sarah Wagenknecht, Retter, die Grünen. Alles Bullshit, alles nicht echt, weil alles real ist, ist nichts real. Dennoch ist es Bullshit, Dreieck, aber leider sehr wirkmächtig. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, aber das ist doch offenbar ein Ausdruck von einer Gegnerschaft. Also eines in der Demokratie üblichen Antagonismus, dass man den politischen Gegner disqualifiziert. Und dann kann man sagen, da schlägt aber Sarah Wagenknecht über die Stränge oder schlagen die Grünen über die Stränge, wenn die plötzlich sagen, Wagenknecht ist so wie Putin oder was auch immer. Dann kann ich sagen, ich finde die Tonalität nicht richtig oder so. Aber wir können doch nicht sagen, dass das jetzt einfach nur so ein Bullshit-Treieck ist aus Opfer und Bulli oder so etwas, sondern so funktioniert, wie wir ja bei Kumkar lesen, politische Kommunikation und so funktioniert auch Demokratie. Und dass das aber, ich glaube, sie kritisiert die Intensivierung und bezieht sich ja dann auch darauf, dass Karl Schmitt eigentlich ja so eine Freund-Feind-Unterscheidung macht und die hätten wir jetzt heute ja überall. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, aber das ist ja erst mal diese Freund-Feind-Unterscheidung, die muss man nicht von Karl Schmitt in der ganzen Intensität übernehmen. Aber dass natürlich auch im Parlamentarismus ein agonistisches Prinzip vorherrscht, wie es Chantal Muff sagen würde, ist ja nicht das Problem. Und dadurch, wenn man aber sagt, ich finde eigentlich ist das so ein Bullshit-Bingo oder so, dann frage ich mich ja auch, ja, aber wie würde man dann mit denen anders, also wie wäre dann, wie würdest du das beantworten? Wie würde man dann die Politik überhaupt gestalten können? Also das frage ich mich.
Gar nicht. Also sie kommt ja da nicht raus. Dass man sagt, es gibt den Bulli, das Opfer, den Retter, also dieses Dreieck, und dass Donald Trump das hervorragend zeigt, erklärt ja erst mal gar nichts. Das wäre allenfalls so eine Beraterleistung, die man halt so unmittelbar am Geschehen beteiligten, was weiß ich, Journalisten, damit sie noch mal kurz irgendwas zum Reflektieren haben oder so. Dieses Opfer, was da drin steckt, das Archetyp des Opfers, also das relativ viel darüber läuft, dass sich jemand als Opfer sieht. Das haben wir ja bei Kumkar schön aufgestößt, dass immer über Bande diskutiert wird. Also jemand sieht eine Gefahr darin, dass sich schon wieder ein Politiker äußert, weil der hat ja typischerweise schon immer, folgen ihm die Leute und machen mich dann zum Opfer, ja. So und das, also wir haben es hier mit einem kommunikativen Prozess zu tun, der eben nichts mit persönlicher Einstellung zu tun hat, weshalb hier dann der falsche Schluss drin ist und der Satz steht original so drin. Es braucht viel Bewusstsein und innere Arbeit, um das Opfersein loszuwerden. Also diese Opfer-Imagination. Und da würde ich sagen, nee, die wird wie gepflückt aus dem Himmel abgeleitet aus einer Kommunikation, auf die man gar keinen Einfluss hat. Irgendwer in Berlin kommuniziert irgendwas und irgendwer aus Bayern streut was in die Diskussion ein, dann nützt mir jetzt mein Bewusstsein und meine innere Arbeit gar nichts, um zu sagen, ah nee, ich bin ja gar kein Opfer der Ausländer oder der drohenden Vermögenssteuer oder des Wegfalls des Kündigungsschutzes oder so.
Weil man ja auch in vielen Fällen das Opfer ist. Genau, man ist eben wirklich Opfer und das Problem ist hier, also wenn jetzt die Mietpreisbremse gestrichen wird oder die Mehrwertsteuer erhöht wird, dann bin ich ja Opfer der Politik.
In dem Moment, wo sie sagt, etwas ist konstruiert, schwingt ja immer mit, aber unausgesprochen, weil es nicht auflösbar wäre, zu sagen, wir können es also anders machen, wir haben Gestaltungszugriff. Und das korrespondiert bei ihr ganz hart mit so einem eigentlich, also Rutger Breschmann, so ein bisschen zu kurz gelesen, eigentlich sind wir ja alle gut. Wir könnten also die Gesellschaft, die auf uns beruht, anders konstruieren, weil es ist ja alles konstruiert. Und dann kommt sie auf das Thema Macht, am Ende zu sprechen. Und das finde ich wirklich so, also das darf man einfach nicht machen, denn sie beschreibt dann Macht hier als, sie schreibt, die negativen Auswirkungen von Macht verwundern nicht. Macht zu haben ist im Grunde ein extremer und wieder natürlicher Zustand. Jetzt würde ich zum einen sagen, ja klar. Also zum einen haben wir einen Patriarchatsdiskurs, der sagt, Abgeburt gilt da Machtprinzipien. Also schon sehr natürlich, gerade wenn man wie Hasoni so von der Familie hocheskaliert, über Clans und so weiter in den Nationalstaat. Also da ist dann Macht gar nicht so wieder natürlich, aus deren Sicht. Nur Macht grundsätzlich unter diesem negativen Aspekt zu sehen, nimmt einem ja jede Möglichkeit zu sagen, es könnte nach Donald Trump nochmal besser werden. Weil wir ja unterstellen müssen, jeder Politiker jemals wird ja wohl von Donald Trump lernen und sich nicht den Ballroom und die eigene SA nehmen lassen. Nur so dürfen wir ja nicht rangehen. Also da kommen wir ja wirklich in Teufelskiche. Und von daher ist dieses Macht ist zum einen wieder natürlich und zum anderen, wie sie schreibt, völlig absurd. Das ist nicht die richtige Diagnose. Also die führt uns genau nirgendwo hin.
Und ich glaube, dieses Schielen nach der Mitte verstärkt das Problem so sehr. Sie bringt ja ganz gute Beispiele. Wenn sie sagt, die Wagenknecht sagt das zum Ukraine-Krieg, dann kommt Strack Zimmermann, sagt genau den Gegenteil und dann verheddert man sich. Aber wir haben ja gerade gesehen, wie aus der Mitte heraus eine Eskalation stattgefunden hat. Also ein merkwürdiger Extremismus plötzlich auftaucht, der noch nicht mal auf Wagenknechte und Strack Zimmermann mehr angewiesen ist, sondern da gibt es so eigene Dynamiken. Und Polarisierung findet ja auch dann statt, wenn man gerade versöhnlich spricht. Also wenn ich jetzt vor dir sitze und sage, wir wollen Demokratie, wir wollen nicht Hass, wir wollen uns nicht von Hetze dominieren lassen. Wir sind für Toleranz, wir sind für eine vielfältige Gesellschaft, dann sage ich natürlich damit implizit und ihr nicht, wenn ihr nicht da mitmacht. Also das heißt, ich brauche nicht die drastischen Worte, ich brauche nicht das Gebell von Höcke, um natürlich auch eine Polarisierung herzustellen. Und da muss man einfach sagen, ach ja, genau, Polarisierung haben wir gelernt, ist auch erst mal gar nicht so schlimm. Die Frage ist eben, wie wir sie gestalten. Und dann geht sie ja richtig, richtigerweise, zeigt sie ja, wie zum Beispiel diese Bürgergeld-Diskussionen alle sind, wie immer wieder suggeriert wird, ganz viele Menschen würden in einem kollektiven Freizeitpark, das ist eine Formulierung von Helmut Kohl, leben in der sozialen Hängematte, all das, wie dann auch noch Habeck sich dazu hinreißen lässt, mal über einen Totalentzug von Leistung nachzudenken. Und gerade diese richtigen, ausführlichen und wichtigen Beschreibungen von Sahebi widersprechen dann so ein bisschen dieser Grundthese, dass wir uns alle eigentlich super verstehen, weil diese Leute, die das machen, sind ja nicht einfach irregeleitet, sondern die machen das ja aus einem gewissen Machtinteresse heraus, was aber, wie du richtigerweise sagst, ja nicht bedeutet, dass man sagt, ach so Macht bedeutet Donald Trump, haut die Rosen im weißen Haus klein, also hören wir auf mit der Macht, sondern die Frage ist, wer sollte die Macht eigentlich besitzen, wie können wir sie anders gestalten? Und das hat auch nicht mit Freund Feind im Sinne von Moral zu tun, was hier immer wieder so geredet wird zwischen Gut und Böse, denn Karl Schmidt führt ja gerade diese Unterscheidung, Freund Feind, ein, um zu sagen, das ist eine politische Unterscheidung. Die Moral, die unterscheidet zwischen Gut und Böse, aber wie in der Politik zwischen Freund und Feind, weshalb er ja zum Beispiel auch moralische Rechtfertigung für einen Auslandseinsatz oder so niemals unterstützen würde, denn er würde ja sagen, wer Menschheit sagt, will betrügen. Also wer moralisch kommt in der Politik, der ist eigentlich schiefgewickelt. Von daher ist es ja was fundamental anderes. Und ja, das, was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, dass sie nochmal so auch, und da wird sie wahrscheinlich auch in ihrem Lager, das sie jetzt liest, wahrscheinlich auch für ein paar Irritationen, für produktive Sorgen, dass sie nochmal zeigt, wie erbittert diese Corona-Diskussion war. Und sie bringt dann eine Ärztin, die Atteste für Kinder ausstellte, dass diese keine Masken tragen müssen. Und zeigt dann, wie die Ärztin eigentlich darüber nachgedacht hat. Und wie dann aber durch diese schon stattgefundene Polarisierung, das dazu führte, dass diese Ärztin, die da tatsächlich, weil kann die einzelne Bedenkung jetzt nicht einschätzen, aber aus diesen Bedenken heraus agierte, plötzlich sich wiederfindet neben den Querdenkern und der AfD. Und dann auch noch dort reden hält. Also wie dann solche slippery slope Dynamiken sich in Gang setzen. Ich finde, da ist sie ja sehr präzise in ihrer Beschreibung oder auch wenn sie so beschreibt, wie so eine Eskalation bei Nahost und alles stattfindet. Aber auch hier würde ich sagen, guckt euch die Mitte an, diese, wie Kumkar das sagt, also die Normalitätsverhältnisse die ganze Zeit stabilisieren sollen. Das muss man auch irritieren. Das heißt, wenn man so ein Buch dann schreiben will, dann muss man auch Anne Will, Igor Lewitt, Lage der Nation und so weiter irritieren. Man kann nicht nur dann Strack Zimmermann und Wagenknecht und so weiter hernehmen. Dann führt das am Ende nicht besonders weit. Und ich frage mich auch an manchen Punkten, wenn ich die ganze Zeit dieses im Grunde gut und können wir uns da verstehen und so. Naja, wir müssen ja schon gewisse Linien, wollen wir ja eigentlich einhalten. Also wenn ich kann in ein Streitgespräch mit einem AfD-Politiker oder so treten. Aber es wäre jetzt, glaube ich, für alle doch weithin irritierend, wenn ich sagen würde, ich mache mit dem so eine Unterhaltungsshow. Ich mache mit dem Maximilian Krah, mache ich jetzt so ein YouTube-Styling-Format. So wir verstehen uns auf einer menschlichen Ebene gut. Würde jeder sagen, sag mal, spinnst du? So, zu Recht. Also von daher sind wir gerade bei diesen Kämpfen doch auf eine Polarisierung erheblich angewiesen.
Ja, absolut. Ich bin einfach dafür, dass es mehr Soziologie gibt, in der man einfach kalt schnäuzig drüberfliegt und sich auch nicht davon verunsichern lässt, wenn andere Leute zu früh ökonomische Diskussionen fordern oder so, sondern diese gewisse Kalt- schnäuzigkeit gehört dazu. In der haben wir ein sehr gutes Buch gelesen und eins, das eben noch mal alle Stolpersteine aufzeigt in diesen ganzen Debatten.
Wie können wir die Spaltung in der Gesellschaft überwinden? Das ist die falsche Frage, sagt uns der Soziologe Nils C. Kumkar in seinem Buch Polarisierung. Polarisierung ist an sich gar kein Problem. Ja, das ganze System funktioniert nur, wenn wir polarisiert sind. Die Frage ist, wie intensiv darf es denn sein? Und wie verändern zum Beispiel die sozialen Medien die Polarisierung? Und sollte man nicht die Polarisierung noch weiter vorantreiben, dabei aber andere Arenen bespielen? Das sind die Fragen, die Nils Kumkar nicht nur aufwirft, sondern auch beantwortet. Er tut das in zugegebenermaßen allerlei Soziologen-Jagd. Aber es ist eine inspirierende Lektüre.
Es ist ein ganz hervorragendes Buch, sensationell geschrieben. Die Soziologie ist wirklich haarsträubend, luzide aufklärend und wir bekommen, ich will nur ein Thema aufgreifen, eine Gegentheorie zum Rechtspopulismus, in dem uns eine Lehrstelle aufgezeigt wird, geradezu ein Desiderat formuliert. Und wir müssen uns fragen, warum war der Rechtspopulismus oder ist er so erfolgreich, weil er für sehr viele in der Gesellschaft eine Gefahr ist. Und die Frage ist, für wen kann ein Anti-Rechtspopulismus oder ein neuer Populismus eine Gefahr sein, und eine gute Alternative zu dem, was wir in der Alternative haben. Selten haben wir so eine eindeutig klare, nachvollziehbare und nun programmatisch unterfütterbare Antwort bekommen wie hier.
Wir sprechen jetzt über Let's Talk About Feelings. So heißt der neue Roman von Leif Randt. Leif Randt wurde sehr populär vor allem durch den Roman Allegro Pastel. Das ist ein Roman, der eine Liebesgeschichte erzählt und in einem sehr besonderen Realismus, der sehr nüchtern ist, uns zunächst einmal einführt in die Welt zum Beispiel des Frankfurter Hauptbahnhofs. So beginnt der Roman. Gründonnerstag, 29. März 2018. Der Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof wurde von milder Abendsonne geflutet. Die wartenden Passagiere, Angleis 9, warfen lange Schatten auf die Minute pünktlich. Um 18.30 Uhr fuhr Tanja Ahrenheim mit ICE 375 aus Berlin ein. Als Jerome Daimler, der eine Tüte mit frischen Backwaren in der Hand hielt, Tanja auf Höhe des Bordbistros aussteigen sah, überlegte er für einen Moment, ob er ihr entgegenlaufen sollte. Aber dann fand er es charmanter, einfach stehen zu bleiben.
Weise Entscheidung wahrscheinlich.
Es geht also darum, wie viel Gefühl wollen wir denn zulassen? Wie viel überschwangen? Und es ist eine Welt der gedämpften Gefühle. Sehr viel ist verkopft. Man überlegt, wie man gerade empfindet. Kann es vielleicht oft selbst gar nicht so sagen. Man flüchtet sich in Äußerungen, wie es ist okay, es hat sich ziemlich gut angefühlt. So auch, wenn der Sex beschrieben wird oder die Stimmung danach. Jetzt in dem neuen Roman von Leif Randt ist es so, dass wir es mit einem Boutiquebesitzer im Alter von 42 zu tun haben. Er heißt Marian Flanders. Seine Mutter, einst ein berühmtes Model, ist gestorben. Sein Vater ist ein berühmter Nachrichtensprecher. Er verdient einigermaßen mit der Boutique, aber kann sich jetzt keine großen Sprünge erlauben, bricht aber jetzt doch mit ein bisschen Erbe im Rücken, 37.000 Euro sind es, glaube ich, auf, um jetzt nicht einfach nur die Midlife-Crisis zu erleben, sondern ein bisschen in die Welt hinauszugehen. So ist man beispielsweise in Japan, hält sich dort eine Weile auf. Da heißt es, auf seinen Reisen in den zurückliegenden 20 Jahren hatte Marian die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es meistens ein Fehler war, Dinge aufzuschieben, die man sich für einen Aufenthalt vorgenommen hatte. Für die vier Tage in Osaka hatte er den Besuch des Flagship Stores von Abel Toyago und der Shongwei Manufactures geplant, zwei Labels, die Marian perspektivisch bei Kenting Beach, so heißt sein Laden, führen wollte. Pete interessierte sich zwar nicht ganz so akut für junge japanische Bekleidungsfirmen wie Marian, aber er schien so kurz nach der Ankunft vor allem froh darüber zu sein, keine eigenen Entscheidungen treffen zu müssen. Beide Stores befanden sich in überdimensionalen Malls, die auch an einem späten Mittwochnachmittag so voller Menschen waren, die sich alle auf ihre Weise perfekt kleideten, dass Marian das Gefühl bekam, Osaka sei um ein Vielfaches größer und von ungleiche wohlhabenderen Menschen bevölkert als Berlin. So erleben wir also diese Reisen, die der Protagonist macht. Zwischendurch ist er wieder in Berlin oder telefoniert mit seinen Angestellten in Berlin. Er ist dort mit einem Freund unterwegs. Es ist aber auch so, dass er Frauen kennenlernt. Da ist eine Ärztin und da ist dann irgendwann auch noch eine Filmemacherin. Man bewegt sich so durch die Welt, denkt darüber nach, was man an Mode kaufen könnte bzw. welche neuen Stile sich durchgesetzt haben. Aber wie schon in Allegro Pastel ist es so, dass wir es nicht mit politischer Literatur in dem Sinne zu tun haben, dass sie für oder gegen etwas sein will. Man ist so allgemein progressiv, aber macht sich auch nicht mehr Gedanken weiter dazu. Etwas, was natürlich der Pop-Literatur eigentlich zu eigen ist, was sich hier wiederfindet. Ich würde aber sagen, im Gegenteil zu dieser sehr coolen Pop-Literatur geht es natürlich schon hier, also der Titel bringt es ja schon mit sich, Let's Talk About Feelings, darum, wie viele Emotionen sind denn eigentlich da, was lassen wir an Emotionen zu. Und die Frage ist dann aber auch, ob doch noch eine politische Komponente da ist. Da heißt es Irma gegenüber, erzählte er, also Marian, dass er sich manchmal Sorgen mache, dass es bald so wenige Menschen geben könnte, die sich noch als apolitisch definieren. Im apolitischen, fand Marian, lag eine besondere bindende Kraft, die ein friedfertiges Miteinander überhaupt erst möglich machte. Nur wer in der Lage war, nicht in politischen Kategorien zu denken, konnte sich offen unterhalten und andere wirklich kennenlernen. Auch modisch schien ihm jene Gesellschaften anregender zu sein, in denen es weniger klar markierte Positionen gab. Marian dachte in diesem Fall explizit an die Street-Photography-Strecken, die ihm zuletzt aus chinesischen Metropolen zugespielt worden waren. So viel Liebe zum Detail wie bei den explosiven Fashion-Kids in China war vielleicht nur möglich, wenn man sich zu gesellschaftlichen Themen gar nicht erst äußern durfte und diese also weniger Kapazitäten lähmten. Positionierst du dich selbst denn als apolitisch? fragte Irma und sah dabei ein bisschen schockiert aus. Marian, ich gehe zu sämtlichen Wahlen und habe eine klare Meinung zu den meisten politischen Entscheidungen, aber ich habe es früh aufgegeben, mich mit den Theorien dahinter zu befassen. Ich finde, Kanzlerin Brinkmann, die regiert nämlich dann hier in Deutschland 2026, hat schon einen guten Punkt, wenn sie sagt, dass alle großen Ideen bitter gescheitert sind, also auch der freie Markt und dass man jetzt schauen muss, wie man mit Hilfe neuer Technologie den Schaden klein hält und dabei dennoch fair und optimistisch bleibt. Irma, und wirst du sie nächstes Jahr nochmal wählen? Marian, ich habe 2022 am Ende doch die Linkspartei gewählt. Irma, verstehe. Ich bin mit dem Alter auch wieder linker geworden. Leider gibt es trotz all den Neugründungen noch immer keine wirklich linke Partei in Deutschland. Und so parliert man ein bisschen darüber und dann geht es wieder weiter hin zu einer Modestrecke, die man sich unbedingt ansehen muss. Irgendeiner Begegnung, der Frage, ob man am Abend Alkohol trinkt oder vielleicht auch mal Ketamine ausprobiert oder sonst etwas. Und so ist alles in einer, ja, gedämpften Stimmung, die Tage fließen dahin. Es ist eigentlich ganz gut oder vielleicht, wie der Protagonist sagen würde, ziemlich gut und ziemlich gut ist auch die Frau, die Filmemacherin, die ihr kennenlernt. Alles auf Sparflamme, alles getrosselt. Die großen Tragödien finden so wenig statt wie irgendwelche größeren Ereignisse. Es geht alles so seinen Weg. Und damit versucht natürlich diese Literatur, auch indem da so eine Bundeskanzlerin einer progressiven Kraft, die aber nicht wirklich jetzt forciert politisch offenbar vorgeht und so etwas wie Polarisierung oder so anstreben, versucht eigentlich dieser Roman zu zeigen, wie eigentlich Normalität lebbar und beschreibbar auch ist. Also es ist natürlich auch eine literarische Frage, die sich stellt, wie geht man eigentlich damit um, wenn man nicht das große Ereignis beschreibt, sondern es nur um die Frage geht, sollen wir heute Abend noch in den Club gehen oder bleiben wir eher zu Hause? Und was hast du morgen vor? Warst du gestern essen? Ja, das sind die Fragen, die sich gestellt werden. Das ist, könnte man jetzt böswillig sagen, einfach nur Hipster-Literatur. Es ist aber natürlich ein gewisser Realismus, den wir dann in Berlin besonders, aber auch in anderen Großstädten wiederfinden können. Und ich glaube auch, dass diese Idee davon, wie jetzt Beziehungen heute sortiert sind, dass man also nicht mehr den romantischen Überschwang dann hat, sondern dadurch, dass man schon so viel Rationalität im Leben erfahren hat, auch darauf anders blickt und dann doch aber seine eigenen Gefühle nicht ganz verstehen kann und die Figuren auch nicht in der Lage sind, ja, die Romantik wieder ganz zurückzuholen. Also sie wollen das immer so stückweise haben und vielleicht wirft man sich mal Ecstasy ein und dann werden die Gefühle noch mal intensiviert. Aber eigentlich bleibt dann doch alles in solchen seichten Gewässern. Das ist ja nicht, was ich jetzt dem Roman angreide, sondern das ist ja das Prinzip, das er uns vorführt. Meine Kritik an dem Roman ist, dass im Gegensatz zu Allegro Pastel hier aber eigentlich nicht ein neuer Ton angeschlagen wird. Es wird nur so ein bisschen verschoben ins utopische Surreale, dass wir da eine andere Regierung offenbar haben als die, die wir jetzt gerade in Deutschland haben. Dass das aber nicht dazu führt, dass wir einen wirklich anderen Ton wahrnehmen als den von Allegro Pastel. Die Figuren sind ein bisschen älter geworden, wie der Auto auch älter geworden ist. Und wir haben es dann doch am Ende mit einem Sound zu tun, der irgendwann einem doch lästig wird. Ich will nicht sagen, weil mir das alles so privilegiert ist, dann wäre man fast wieder bei so einer Thomas-Mann-Kritik da angekommen. Aber das nur mir so vorgeführt wird als die Leute, denen es noch so einigermaßen gut geht und sie leben so dahin, ist mir dann als Literatur auch ein bisschen wenig. Das hat zwar auch komödiantische Elemente. Also wenn über eine Mode-Linie gesprochen wird, und dann heißt es an einer Stelle, dass die zu okayen Arbeitsbedingungen in Polen gefertigt werden. Also dieses Okaye und die Arbeitsbedingungen, dass man also noch sieht, es gibt Lieferketten, es gibt da irgendwelche Probleme, ruft das so kurz aus. Aber eigentlich interessiert uns das jetzt hier in Berlin nicht in den Kreisen, in denen ich mich bewege. Ist natürlich auch so, dass wir das in gewisser Weise ironisch, parodistisch lesen können. Aber es bleibt dann doch so eine Stimmung, bei der ich sagen muss, ist der Roman wirklich raffiniert oder ist er am Ende in einer ähnlichen Banalität selbst anzusiedeln, wie die, die er da beschreibt? Also es ist ja eine interessante Frage, muss die Literatur was Aufregendes beschreiben? Erstmal würde ich sagen nein. Peter Handke beschreibt jetzt auch nicht nur aufregende Dinge, sondern oft gehen da Leute durch den Wald und suchen Pilze oder so. Aber wenn die Literatur sagt, ich will also nur noch so diese, wie sich im Alltag die Leute fühlen, also wie sie bei Krobacke oder wie das heißen Croissants kaufen und dann gehen sie weiter und kaufen dort was und dann warten sie auf den Zug und steigen dort ein und abends treffen sie sich noch und eigentlich war das japanische Essen ganz lecker. Dann ist das natürlich etwas, was einen Realismus hervorbringen kann, den wir so in der Literatur doch nicht so häufig finden. Also wir sind da ganz stark am Puls der Gegenwart. Und zugleich aber ist es dann auch eine Literatur, die sich selbst in gewisser Weise so arm macht, dass ich mich fast frage, warum sollte ich noch mal das dupliciert bekommen, was ohnehin der Fall ist. Das ist mein Problem mit dieser Literatur. Ich kann die Stimmung einfangen, aber ich kenne sie auch eigentlich schon.
Ich würde ja einen Vorschlag machen an Leute, die gerne Romane schreiben. Und zwar gibt es ja ein neues Phänomen, dass wir Kinder haben, die nicht mehr wählen wie ihre Eltern, schon weil die in einer ganz anderen Welt leben und so weiter und so fort. Und man weiß gar nicht mehr, was soll ich beruflich machen, wo doch alle nur sagen, die Berufe gibt es eh alle nicht mehr und so. Und es gibt, finde ich, ich will es nicht so verallgemeinern, aber ich forciere es ein bisschen da, wo ich kann, dass man sagt, ja, hör doch auf dein Gefühl. Und ach, es muss jetzt nicht ein extremes Gefühl sein, das sich typischerweise in Pop-Literatur gerne aufzeigen lässt, weil am besten ist es noch drogeninduziert oder so, sondern einfach nur komplementär zu bisherigen Antworten, wie man auf eine Welt im Chaos reagiert. Einfach sagen, achte doch einfach mal auf dein Gefühl, aber nimm auch die wahr, die als frühe Gefühle, kleine Gefühle, unbedeutende Gefühle und so weiter, den geben wir jetzt einfach Relevanz. Was sich zum Beispiel äußert in so Sachen wie, klar darf ein Kind Scheiße sagen, aber es muss halt erklären können, was wirklich so scheiße ist, dann überprüft man mal, ob sich das Wort wirklich gelohnt hat. Oder jedes Kind darf sagen, was es will. Hauptsache, es ist relativ darüber im Klaren, dass es auch wirklich Spaß macht. Also dann gelten gewisse, das ist doch Quatsch-Erklärung nicht oder so. Und das bedeutet aber schon, dass man sich dann darauf einlässt, Gefühle, die typischerweise nicht allzu wichtig schienen. Bislang, weil sie einfach nicht lebensverändert sind, sondern einfach nur einen kleinen Alltag gestalten oder mal eine Entscheidung formen oder so. Dass man die halt ernst nimmt, obwohl sie nur so klein sind.
Ja, aber das findet hier schon statt. Also es geht schon darum, dass so ein kleiner Haariss vielleicht auch jetzt bedeutet, dass diese Beziehung doch keine Chance hat. Zum Beispiel sowas. Also davon handelte es die ganze Zeit natürlich. Und das sind aber diese, also ich sage mal, die Probleme, die hier geschildert werden, sind keine übergroßen. Aber doch sind die Leute auf der Suche nach etwas Glück. Aber das Glück haben sie jetzt auch nicht überdimensioniert vor sich, sondern wir hatten eine gute Zeit. Also nach diesem Motto wird da eigentlich agiert. Ich finde, es wird sich ein bisschen leicht dadurch gemacht, dass wir hier Figuren haben. Also ich habe schon gesagt, Mutter, Model, Vater, Nachrichtensprecher, er hat eine Boutique, lernt eine Filmemacherin kennen, der beste Freund macht einen Podcast. Der Podcast heißt Let's Talk About Feelings. Dann sind wir eben in so einer kleinen Blase angekommen. Und ich kenne natürlich auch Leute aus solchen Blasen und weiß auch, wie sie reden und finde das bei Leif Randt dann auch sehr gut wieder. Und wenn irgendwas gesagt wird, dann bestätigt man das mit voll. Ja, das kenne ich natürlich. Nur frage ich mich, ob man doch nochmal, wenn man schon so einen Realismus hat und wenn man den Bahnsteig beschreibt oder beschreibt, wie die Restaurants sind oder irgendwelche Ladenketten, was auch immer, ob man dann nicht auch mal bereit wäre, noch eine andere Form des subjektiven Empfindens reinzubringen, als nur den von solchen Künstlerpersönlichkeiten oder der Akteure der Kreativwirtschaft, damit man doch nochmal eine andere Form von Realismus reinbekommt, als der, der jetzt gerade da ist. Denn am Ende ist es natürlich schon so, dass hier jemand es sich offenbar leisten kann, durch die Welt ein bisschen zu reisen und telefoniert dann hin und wieder mal mit den Angestellten. Das bringt zwar nicht viel ein, das Geschäft, aber es ist ausreichend. Und ich würde schon gerne auch wissen, wie ist das Verhältnis zum Beispiel von normalen Angestellten innerhalb dieses realistischen Kosmos, der aufgemacht wird. Und so habe ich den Eindruck vielmehr, dass hier ein Eskapismus betrieben wird. Und das ist an sich nicht schlecht, der Eskapismus. Aber ein Eskapismus betrieben wird, der so aussieht, dass man sich eigentlich so ein bisschen einlullt in so eine eigene Wirklichkeit, wo man auf Blogs noch mal nachliest, welche Jacke ich mir morgen noch kaufen kann. Aber sonst geht es darüber nicht hinaus. Ich weiß, dass es so Leute gibt und auch über sie kann man wegen mir Romane schreiben. Die Frage ist nur, ob das dann interessante Literatur ergibt. Und das sehe ich jetzt bei diesem Nachfolgeroman von Aleko Pastel, also sehe ich bei Let's Talk About Feelings eher nicht so, sodass ich einer literaturwissenschaftlich jetzt nicht besonders qualifizierte Antwort, aber doch wahre Antwort gebe. Ich habe mich streckenweise sehr gelangweilt.
Ich mache jetzt eine Pointe, aber ich habe auch keine Ahnung davon. Du möchtest also ein bahnwerder Tier-Naturalismus, der dich schon depressiv zurücklässt, als Leser. Ansonsten war es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein. Man verlässt ja die Roman von Leif Randt auch nicht mit einem Hochgefühl oder so. Man verlässt ja mit dem Gefühl, dass man vielleicht noch ein Date und vielleicht läuft es ganz okay. Der Sex war echt noch ganz in Ordnung. Wir konnten auch noch ein zweites Mal. Aber dabei bleibt es ja auch.
Habt ihr das nicht bei Karoline Wahl auch so besprochen?
Das ist ein Vergleich, den ich eigentlich nicht machen will, weil ich natürlich sehe, dass hier noch mal eine andere literarische Qualität da ist. Aber jetzt, wenn du es ansprichst, ich finde, dass es dann durchaus Parallelen gibt zwischen Karoline Wahl und Leif Randt. Ich will deutlich machen, Leif Randt ist sicherlich der Schriftsteller, der wesentlich mehr kann. Aber ich finde, dass gerade dieses Gefühl, und offenbar ist es sehr nachgefragt, dieses Gefühl gerade, dieses so, na, irgendwie hat er mir gut gefallen, mal gucken, ob ich mich morgen nochmal bei ihm melde. Irgendwie war es auch ganz okay, dass das etwas ist, was jetzt gerade sehr dominant ist und die Literatur abbildet oder erzeugt. Darüber wird man irgendwann nochmal reden können. Aber ja, in gewisser Weise haben wir es hier wirklich mit Gegenwartsliteratur zu tun. Also bei 22 Bahnen genauso wie bei Let's Talk About Felix.
Kann ja nicht alle, nur Thomas Mann lesen, man kann doch mal einen Punkt machen.
Danke, Stefan.
Brief von Brosius-Gersdorf im Wortlaut hat The Pioneer veröffentlicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es, also da wurde über ihre Anwaltin irgendwie veröffentlicht. Ich habe ihn jetzt nur da gefunden, aber da kann man mal nachlesen. Und ich finde, da läuft auch eine schöne Pointe hinaus. Also sie wollte Verfassungsrichterin werden, weil sie gefragt wurde. Dann hat sich die Koalition und so weiter da zerstritten, wie auch immer. Wir kennen das Verfahren. Sie schreibt also im Nachhinein oder um den Prozess dann abzukürzen oder zu beenden. Nach reiflicher Überlegung, bla bla bla. Denn ihr wurde aus der CDU-CSU-Fraktion mitgeteilt bzw. deutlich signalisiert. Man spricht ja nicht mit ihr. Man hat sie auch nie in Fraktionssitzungen eingeladen, sondern deutlich signalisiert. Meine Wahl ist ausgeschlossen. Und da sie sagt, sie möchte auch verhindern, dass sich der Koalitionsstreit wegen der Richterwahl zuspitzt und eine Entwicklung in Gang gesetzt wird, deren Auswirkungen auf die Demokratie nicht absehbar sind, zieht sie jetzt zurück. Also, sie gibt eine großes Opfer, würde ich mal sagen. Die SPD-Fraktion hingegen hat bis zuletzt an ihr festgehalten. Und sie hat auch Zuspruch und Rückendeckung vom Bündnis 90, die Grünen und der Linken. Sie macht das ganz explizit, und zwar zweimal in diesem Text. Ich frage mich, wieso? Haben wir hier etwa eine Bundesversammlungsmehrheit, die so organisiert werden kann, wie auch immer. Zweitens, also sie hat das durchgepunktet, jetzt kommt Punkt zwei. Nach dem TV-Gespräch mit Markus Lanz hat sich die Berichterstattung in den Medien deutlich versachtlicht und wurde sie ganz überwiegend inhaltlich geführt. Der CDU-CSU-Fraktion ist es dagegen nicht gelungen, sich mit meinen Themen und Thesen inhaltlich auseinanderzusetzen. Eine Einhaltung in die Fraktionen hat es nie gegeben, wurde bis zuletzt nicht ausgesprochen. Stattdessen wurde ihr öffentlich vorgehalten, dass sie diesen Satz, und sie zitiert ihn nochmal, es gibt gute Gründe dafür, dass die Menschenwürde-Garantie erst ab Geburt gilt. Und das Argument ist super einfach, ich habe es am Podcast auch schon gesagt, Menschenwürde ist nicht abwägungsfähig. Und da aber Menschenwürde von Zwei, also Mutter und ungeborenes Kind, hier in Beschlag genommen wird, sagt sie, wir können sie aber andere Paragrafen laufen lassen, bei denen durchaus eine Abwägung gemacht werden kann. Denn hier bedeutet einfach, wenn wir dem Fötus Menschenwürde geben, müssten wir sie automatisch der Mutter absprechen. Wenn zum Beispiel medizinische Implikationen sagen, die Mutter würde die Geburt nicht überleben oder was auch immer, dann ginge automatisch der Fötus vor. Weshalb sie halt sagt, in einem juristischen Diskurs, der irgendwann zur Entscheidungsfindung mal herbeigeführt wird, kann man einfach nicht mit Menschenwürde argumentieren, weil es dann nicht aufgeht. Also so bekommt man einfach keinen politischen Pragmatismus rein. Aber gut. Sie möchte, im Grunde habe ich mir nur als Notiz gemacht, könnte sie der CDU vorwerfen, die Menschenwürde als Prinzip aufzuweichen, weil das die Konsequenz wäre. Menschenwürde für den Fötos geht nur, wenn man Menschenwürde abwägungsfähig macht und damit wäre Artikel 1 aufgeweicht. Hätte man auch mal so scharf formulieren können. Drittens, die ablehnende Haltung von Teilen der CDU-CSU-Fraktion wegen meiner Position zum Schwangerschaftsabbruch steht im Widerspruch zum Koalitionsvertrag. Es ist paradox, jemanden wegen seiner einer Position abzulehnen, die man selbst vertritt. Also da schießt sie recht scharf. Das Argument habe ich so auch noch nirgendwo anders gehört. Und dann kommt sie ab, viertens, auf die Medien zu sprechen, insbesondere die Leitmedien als Eckpfeiler unserer demokratischen Ordnung. Also der professionelle Journalismus, der ja typischerweise sachlich fundiert, schon Kampagnen führt, aber eigentlich keine Desinformationen und Diffamierung sich hingeben sollte. Und genau das wirft sie aber, und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, sie meint hier die FAZ. Denn sie sagt dann doch ganz explizit, blablabla, nicht im Vöter, sondern im Politikteil und so. Da wo auch Juristen schreiben, also ich weiß nicht genau, wer da Reinhard Müller oder so, einer aus der Gang da geschrieben hat, die nämlich sagt sie dann, sie als Sperrspitze einer, also sie als ultralinke Aktivistin wurde sie geprägt, ultralink und Aktivistin in Zitat-Anführungszeichen, wie sie da beschrieben wurde und einige Journalisten und sie schreibt dann in Klammern nicht Journalistinnen, also sie meint nur Männer, haben sich dann doch als die Sperrspitze eines eher abschneidenden Journalismus herausgestellt. Also ziemlich hart, Punkt 5. Neu und bedrohlich ist, dass sich in sozialen Netzwerken organisierte und zum Teil KI-generierte Desinformations- und Diffamierungskampagnen bahnbrechen zur Herzkammer unserer Demokratie, dem Parlament. Von politisch verantwortlichen Funktionsträgern wie Abgeordneten der CDU-CSU-Fraktion, die für bürgerliche Werte wie Anstand, Respekt und Verantwortungsbewusstsein stehen, darf und muss man erwarten, dass Grundlagen ihrer Entscheidung nicht ungeprüfte Behauptung und Stimmung, sondern Quellen- und Faktenanalysen sind. Also, sie hat ja quasi der CDU gesagt, wenn ihr das in mehreren Kampagnen so macht, bleibt nichts übrig von eurem und so. Also, schon ziemlich hart. Und jetzt springen wir mal an Punkt 8. Sie schreibt hier unten, Besonders berührt, und das ist auch der erste Ausstieg aus dem Text, Besonders berührt haben mich Tausende von E-Mails oder Mails aus allen Teilen der Gesellschaft im In- und Ausland, die mir auf sehr persönliche Weise zugesprochen und beigestanden haben. Ihnen allen sei versichert, dass ich mich weiterhin für die Werte unseres wunderbaren Grundgesetzes einsetzen werde. Aha, ja. Und es gibt ja, finde ich schon, verschiedene Positionen, in denen man das Grundgesetz ehren kann. Also wenn jemand Sonntagsräten hält, dann ja wohl die Bundespräsidentin. Und ich finde es verdächtig, dass die SPD bislang, also das ist der Prozess jetzt, obwohl sie ja schon vor einer Weile zurückzog, noch nicht weiter getrieben wurde. Vielleicht schmiedet man einen Pakt, also dass die SPD einfach sagt, okay, wir nehmen jetzt diesen Verfassungsrichtervorschlag. Aber das ist dann auch die Kandidatin der Koalition. Die Nachfolge von Frank Walter.
Das wäre natürlich ein Coup.
Wer weiß, wer weiß.
Vielleicht lernen sie es jetzt durch dich. Das könnte sein, dass sie das jetzt...
Ja, ich fände es witzig. Also es wäre wirklich wahnsinnig witzig.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sich die CDU darauf einlässt. Dann kann ich mir eher vorstellen, dass man da schon die CDU, die die Koalition so zerrüttet hat, dass man sagt, wir machen das jetzt mit grünen Linken und weiß ich nicht, wie.
Ich will nur die Debatte kurz erden. Zum einen, Werbpflicht. Ganz wichtiges Thema. Wir haben ja einen Podcast schon gehört. Die CDU hat schon ihr Pulver verschossen, eine echte Werbpflicht daraus zu machen.
Bislang.
Ja, und die Werbpflicht ist nun, wie sie alle feststellen in der CDU, ein wirklich großes Thema. Von daher finde ich, wer wird Nachfolge von Frank-Walter? Das läuft für mich noch fast unter Tagespolitik. Also, sich darauf einzulassen, dass sie einfach…
Ja, ja, ich würde jetzt nur nicht die Dummheit der CDU unterschätzen wollen.
Ja, das stimmt. Am Ende, ja, aber…
Das ist das Ding.
Am Ende kann ich auch die Theater leben, wenn sie ihre Dummheit zeigen.
Die Vernunft, die du auch immer herbeiführst, wenn es um die Werbpflichtsdiskussion geht, ist ja eine, die… Bei dir liegt diese Vernunft und bei manchen anderen Leuten auch. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass die Flächendecken verbreitet sind. Also nachdem wir zum Beispiel über die Werbpflicht diskutiert haben, war Ulrike Herrmann bei Markus Lanz, hat dort für die Werbpflicht plädiert. Ja, und wir wissen so langsam, mit Kriegswirtschaft war nicht nur eine Metapher gemeint, sondern das scheint offenbar mehr zu bedeuten. Und dann hat Bodo Ramelow, der noch immer bei den Linken ist, aber eigentlich in die CDU gehört, auch nochmal betont, er ist gar nicht für eine Werbpflicht, sondern für ein soziales Pflichtjahr für jeden Schüler, also direkt nach der Schule. Und da können ja dann manche in so einen Zivildienst gehen und die anderen in den Wehrdienst. Da denke ich mir, ja, genau das wäre ja die Werbpflicht dann.
Ja, im Grunde, ja.
Von daher will ich nur sagen, es sind ja also verschiedene Kräfte aus der Gesellschaft in diese Richtung am Stoßen. Und da wird man gespannt sein, ob die sich vielleicht auch durchsetzen können.
Aber ich argumentiere nicht mit einer Vernunft oder so, sondern ich sage einfach Kennziffern.
Ja, ja.
Die Kennziffern werden es nicht.
Gut, aber Ulrike Herrmann hat ja auch mit Kennziffern kein Problem. Die hätte ja gerne ein Wirtschaftswachstum.
Wir kennen Ulrike Herrmanns Kennziffer. Die sind alle Banane.
Genau. Die würde nämlich ja gerne die Wirtschaft auf eine Größe schrumpfen wie 1974.
Ja, aber mir geht es ja nicht um publizistische Kennziffern, mit denen man ein Argument illustriert, sondern mir geht es um die Kennziffer. Wer baut die Kaserne?
Naja, man ist, glaube ich, zu viel im Irrsinn bereit. Du wirst es sehen. Wir sprechen jetzt über Gedichte aus China. Sie stammen von Zheng Xiaoxiong. Sie ist 1980 geboren, ist in der chinesischen Provinz Chihuan aufgewachsen und hat in Donghuang dann als Wanderarbeiterin in einer Metallwarenfabrik gearbeitet. Sie begann dann auch in den Nullerjahren diesen Fabrikalltag zu dokumentieren, Gedichte daraus zu machen. Sie hat ein Buch veröffentlicht, das in China auch ein großer Erfolg war. Das Buch der Arbeiterinnen, das ist ein Gedichtband. Und nun gibt es den Band Erzählungen von den Konsumgütern. Der bei einem Schweizer Verlag erschienen ist, Urs Engler heißt er. Und diese Gedichte sind ganz wunderbar zu lesen, weil sie zum einen die Produktionsprozesse thematisieren und aber auch die, die diese Produktionsprozesse ausführen bzw. mit ihnen fast verwachsen sind. Da heißt es zum Beispiel, eine kleine Schraube langsam eingedreht ins Fleisch der Industrie, dann festgezogen. Auch Plastikbahnen, Asphaltstraßen, am leicht geneigten Himmel voll Smog, steht einsam verwirrt der Mond. Also wir haben hier eine Verbindung von Industrialisierung und romantischen Bildern, also der Mond aus den romantischen Gedichten, wie wir kennen es. Es ist eine Literatur, die also zum einen einen sozialistischen Realismus hat, aber durch die poetische Sprache, die hier bedient wird und auch indem der Mensch immer wieder in den Mittelpunkt gerückt wird, haben wir es mit einer wirklichen Introspektion auch der Menschen zu tun, die dort gerade arbeiten. Wir sind also jetzt in dieser Phase. Deng Xiaoping hat China geöffnet. Jetzt wird China die Werkbank der Welt. Und diese Zustände sind natürlich auch heute noch da. Und dann heißt es zum Beispiel in dem Gedicht, ein Körper von der Zeit zersetzt. In einem von Zeit zersetzten Körper mit brüchiger Stimme eine Liebe berühren, die einander ins Gesicht zieht über Schmierfett der Maschinen, wo die Restwärme deiner Finger auf dem Stellhebel aushärtet, auf Halbfertigprodukten, Plastikkörben, in denen mein Schmerz einlagert, mit Sonde und Spannzange den Tag von der Nacht trennt, wo Leuchtmelder, die meiner Frühsommerliebe misstrauen, sich die Schönheit mitnehmen, die Einsamkeit. Eine Zeit, die von Flammen gewaschen wird, Brennhitze verdampft, Schweiß, Plastik und Holzscheite. Wir heben die Augen zu den Sternen der Überstunden, die das Dröhnen der Maschinen vermengt, Gluthitze verschmilzt, Augen braun, Temperbehälter, tiefe Nacht und rau reif, war eine zweifelhafte Mischung. Keimt auf den Apparaten, wächst heran, blüht, wo Signallichter, die über den Mond gehen, sich die Schneedecke mitnehmen, das Heimweh. Die Zeit erdrückt eine Sorge, Lichtstrahlen dringen durchs Eis zum Frühling. In Kabel gewickelt bringt der Strom seine Midsommerhitze. Licht und Liebe flackern zwischen Wolfram-Träten, Schraubmaschinen schlagen Sonne. In die Nacht um Mitternacht wird der ruhelose Körper still. Schleudern Folien Aludraht tastend in einer Höhle aus Binärchips. Unsere Liebe, die einander wärmt, wo Warnblinker, die nach dem Mond greifen, sich die Träume mitnehmen, den Frühling. Also das ist eine so faszinierende poetische Sprache, die die Fachtermini drin hat, die all die Realien drin hat, welche Drähte da jetzt gerade verarbeitet werden. Und zugleich die romantischen Bilder, die Annäherungen, aber Annäherungen von Körper, die auch von den Maschinen selbst beherrscht, zugerichtet, transformiert sind, dass man sagen kann, hier ist man wirklich bei einer Gegenwart, Literatur angekommen im Sinne von, wie wirkt eigentlich wirklich der Produktionsprozess auf unser Empfinden, auf unsere Körper, auf die Liebe ein. Und dass man dafür eine poetische Sprache findet und da auch einen Realismus hat, aber eben anderen nicht so nur gedämpften wie bei Leif Randt. Hat mich unglaublich fasziniert. Ich will noch ein Beispiel dir geben. Das Gedicht heißt Augenzeugin. Das Lärmen von Getrieben, Stahlplatten, Synthesisern, Kunststoffen, ein Rollen, Reiben, Fiepen, Tönen. Um vier Uhr früh wächst Müdigkeit ihr aus der Haut. Das Lärmende, Schneiden, Schleifen, Bohren, Schlagen, ein Fließen, Gehen, Eilen, Innehalten. Um vier Uhr früh wächst Müdigkeit ihr aus dem Fleisch. Wir merken also, wir haben es hier mit einer Arbeiterin zu tun, die dort offenbar sehr kräftezehrende Tätigkeiten verrichtet. Weiter heißt es dann, das Lärmende, Fluchen, Herzen, Gähnen, Erschöpfen, Einmengen, Wickeln, Verflechten, Sich auftürmen. Um vier Uhr früh wächst Müdigkeit ihr aus den Knochen. Um vier Uhr früh sah ich ihre Müdigkeit aufragen wie einen Baum, sah, wie die Maschine ihren halben Finger verschlang, sah, wie die Müdigkeit erwachte vom Bluten, sah, wie sie weinte und schrie, sah unsere hilflosen Seufzer. Und dann beginnt der Maschinenlärm wieder und dann kommt wieder Müdigkeit auf. Und dann irgendwann wird es still. Wir haben es hier mit einem Arbeitsunfall zu tun. Und daraus ein solches Gedicht zu machen, finde ich wirklich folios. Also ich kann das nur empfehlen, auch wenn man sonst selten vielleicht Gedichte liest, dass es hochinteressant ist. Es gibt da noch in dem Band dann ein Interview mit der Lyrikerin, dass man sich ein bisschen Eindruck vermitteln kann, wieso ihre Herangehensweise ist, ihre Poetologie, Erzählung von den Konsumgütern von Sheng Xiao Guiyong.
Und ist sie denn jetzt eine echte Arbeiterin aus der Zeit von?
Na, sie arbeitet, ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt gerade im Betrieb ist, aber sie hat die Gedichte entstehen, während sie diesen Arbeiten nachgeht. Ja.
Interessing. Hier ein Thema, das die ganze Welt betrifft. The decline or declining mental health of the young, also die abnehmenden mentalen Gesundheitsbefasster in der Jüngeren. And the global disappearance of the unhappiness hump shape in age. Also übersetzt die U-Form, die wir kennen, dass wir Zufriedenheitswerte aufs Alter bezogen sehr zufrieden, midlife-crisis ziemlich zufrieden. Dieser Artikel ist von Wissenschaftlern, die ihn am 27. August 2025 endlich in Plus One veröffentlicht sehen. Ich will nochmal hinzufügen, eingereicht am 9. Mai 2024, angenommen am 22. Juni 2025. Also man macht sich immer wieder so Vorstellungen. Und hier ist wirklich ein sehr lahmer Betrieb, muss man nicht mal sagen. Gut, also Thema ist diese U-Form der Zufriedenheit. Und die Frage, was ist passiert? Die Autoren schauen auf UK, US, wo sie besondere Datensätze vorfinden. Und dann auf so einen globalen. Und ihre Frage ist, also so metastudienmäßig keine eigenen Erhebungen, sondern Umfragen, die es so gibt, kennen wir ja in Deutschland auch. Wie steht es um die Verzweiflung, Dispair? Die Frage, die in Amerika gestellt wird, lautet, wenn sie nun an ihre psychische Gesundheit denken, einschließlich Stress, Depressionen und Probleme mit Emotionen, an wie vielen Tagen in den letzten 30 Tagen war ihre psychische Gesundheit nicht gut? Und die Kategorie Dispair läuft dann, wenn die Antwort lautet, an 30 Tagen. Also an allen. Und da sind die unter 25-Jährigen von 1993 2,9 Prozent, 2023 auf 8,0 gestiegen. Also fast eine Verdreifachung. Und bei jungen Frauen sogar von 3,2 auf 9,3. Also da haben wir tatsächlich eine Verdreifachung. Zehn Prozent der jungen Amerikanerinnen sagen einfach, jeder Tag ist scheiße. Schon beachtlich. In Amerika wurde dafür das Behavioral Risk Factor Surveillance System benutzt. Dort werden seit Jahrzehnten 400.000 Interviews pro Jahr geführt. 400.000. Also immer wenn Donald Trump jetzt irgendwas streicht an Budgets und so, dann geht es immer an solche Sachen rein. In Großbritannien gibt es das General Health Questionnaire. Da wird auch auf einer Skala von 0 bis 36 abgefragt, wie es um Verzweiflung, Despair steht. Da ähnliche Entwicklungen wie in Amerika und weltweit 1,7 Millionen Menschen, die gefragt wurden. Da kann man noch dazu sagen, ganz interessant, es gibt eine ungleiche Verteilung im Faktor 3. Während man in den Philippinen und in Italien noch relativ zufrieden ist, sind sie in Mexiko, Chile und Peru dreimal mehr unzufrieden. Also dreimal mehr hat man da die Sorgen im Nachwuchs. Und die zentrale Erkenntnis, und deswegen sagt der Text es auch ganz deutlich, diese grundsätzliche U-Form gibt es nicht mehr. Das neue Muster ist, junge Menschen leiden von allen Altersgruppen am meisten. U25, die muss man sich am meisten Sorgen machen. Danach nimmt es typischerweise ab. Wobei, wir können ja heute noch nichts über die dann Älteren später reden. Sondern wir sehen ja immer nur die heute befragten Älteren. Wir sehen also, von der U-Form fehlt sozusagen das eingleitende U. Sondern wir haben jetzt so eine niedrige und dann im Alter geht es dann hoch.
Warum ist das so? Sagen sie das auch?
So, das sagen sie nicht. Aber es gibt eine besondere Beobachtung. Also, die Trends werden seit 2010 beobachtet. Und da habe ich so gedacht, die hatten doch mal so eine coole These, dass die globale Finanzkrise in Verbindung mit dem Smartphone zu so Problemen führt, wie, ach so, kein Geld da. Naja, ich kann mich ja hier belustigen. Wozu Kino, wenn ich ein Smartphone habe? Wozu kollektive Mobilisierungsgedanken, wenn ich einen doch Selfcare machen kann? Und so weiter und so fort. Und es wird tatsächlich beides, aber getrennt voneinander betrachtet. Also sowohl die Finanzkrise als auch das Smartphone. Ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass die Autoren einfach noch mal kurz eins plus eins zusammen denken und einen Global Trend irgendwie daraus machen. Jedenfalls für die Finanzkrise sagen sie, es gibt den Scaring-Effekt, also eine Vernabung von Scar-Scaring-Effekt, der einfach die ganze Biografie dann betrifft. Also man startet mit schlechter Startbedingung und schleppt dann wie so eine verheilte, aber sichtbare Wunde einfach diesen, ich bin in einer Krise in den Arbeitsmarkt gekommen, hinüber und bei Smartphones, ja, Schlüsselhaut auf Social Media, Individualisierung, Esthetisierung, Erwartungsmanagements, die man so hat. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, würde ich sagen, wir können uns jetzt von diesem, fand ich, also fand das jetzt schon eine der großen, dass es da eine U-Form gibt, eine Zufriedenheit in der westlichen Welt, dass das jetzt nicht mehr gilt. Und zwar als Trend seit 2010 und ganz hart eben 2020 bis 2024. Da kann man sich jetzt einfach in sein Fun-Fact-Reservoir schreiben. Aber jetzt sind die Jungen nochmal mehr hier zu beobachten.
Für Newsweek schreibt Tom O'Connor, will Venezuela be the first target of Trumps new Marga Monroe Doctrine.
Wann hat er das geschrieben?
Jetzt vor drei Tagen.
Also nach Brecht's Podcasts auch. Dann ist es eine Welle, die jetzt so kommt.
Jaja, es finden sich viele Artikel dazu.
Ich habe auch einige Hinweise bekommen, so. Wenn man sucht, ja ja.
Die Maßnahmen des Weißen Hauses, schreibt Tom O'Connor, deuten auf eine umfassendere Verlagerung des politischen Schwerpunkts im Rahmen von Trumps America First Bewegung hin, die ganz Amerika als Teil der Interessensphäre der USA betrachtet. Ganz Amerika. Eine Sichtweise, die an die 200 Jahre alte Monroe-Doktrin erinnert, die als Grundlage für die Intervention der USA gegen den europäischen Kolonialismus und die kommunistische Expansion in der Region diente. Das ist also die These, dass hier etwas erneuert wird. Er spricht dann mit einer Professorin von der John Hopkins School of Advanced and International Studies, die sagt, diese massive Machtdemonstration steht im Einklang mit den Bemühungen der Regierung, ihre Dominanz in der westlichen Hemisphäre zu behaupten und die Monroe-Doktrin wieder zu beleben, die die Region als einzigartigen Einflussbereich der USA deklarierte. Das heißt also, das ist direkt in unserer Nachbarschaft. Da haben wir nochmal eine andere Handhabe mit und die lassen wir uns dann, so wäre ja die These von Precht, auch nochmal von Putin zusichern. Dann könnten wir Putin zusichern, dass er dafür was anderes bekommt. Es wird dann jemand anders zitiert. Nee, sie wird nochmal zitiert. Also Cynthia Arntzen heißt die. Die sagte, die Zahl der eingesetzten Truppen ist zwar groß, reicht aber jetzt nicht aus, um Venezuela zu stürzen, da einzumarschieren, die Regierung zu Fall zu bringen. Dann ein ehemaliger Berater des Nationalen Sicherheitsrates, des Außenministeriums, sagt wiederum, es wäre ein Fehler, den Einsatz der US-Marine vor der venezulanischen Küste als Business as usual oder als politisches Theater zu betrachten. Denn dafür sei das schon eigentlich zu kostspielig, was man da macht. Also nur um mal so Macht zu demonstrieren, wäre das doch ein bisschen viel. Und die Trump-Regierung würde auch sehr gründlich eruieren, ob es einen Regimewechsel geben könnte und zu welchem Preis. Es handelt sich dabei dann aber natürlich nicht um so eine Regime-Change-Rhetorik, die man den Tag legt, sondern das nächste Mal sagt man den Amerikanern, da sind die ganzen Drogenkartelle und die sind ja auch da, die gibt es ja. Und davor müssen wir euch beschützen. Also man sagt nicht so, unsere Mission ist das Gute und wir bringen es nach Afghanistan oder in den Irak, sondern das ist so unsere Sache. Und es sei aber auch als Botschaft an China und Russland zu verstehen, also diese Einflusssphären solltet ihr jetzt mal nicht reinkommen. Am ersten Tag der Trump-Regierung gab es auch gleich so eine Durchführungsverordnung, womit man dann Drogenkartelle als ausländische, terroristische Organisation einstufen konnte und dann hatte man auch entsprechende Handhaben. Aus Sicherheitsgründen wird auch gesagt, könne man jetzt nicht, also hieß das dann damals vom Chefsprecher Jean Pannell, aus Sicherheitsgründen könne man nicht über zukünftige Operationen spekulieren. Also man spielt da schon mal damit, dass alles mögliche ginge. Tom Shannon, ein Diplomat, sagt, als Trump beschloss, seine Kampagne des maximalen Drucks in Venezuela zu starten, da hat er das ja schon in der ersten Amtszeit versucht. Aber da sei er nicht so besonders erfolgreich damit gewesen. Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, was ist neu? Also Trump entsandte jetzt den Sonderbeauftragten Richard Grinnell, wir kennen ihn noch als Botschafter in Berlin nach Caracas, um eine Vereinbarung auszuhandeln, insbesondere um die Freilassung inhaftierter US-Bürger zu verhandeln und eine Lizenz für den Ölkonzern Chevron zu sichern, damit dieser seine Aktivitäten dem Land weiter aufnehmen kann. Trump wieder russiv, diese Lizenz später, was laut Shannon geschah, weil der Präsident Stimmen für seine Big Beautiful Bild brauchte, nur um dann im letzten Monat diese Lizenz wieder zu erteilen. Also es ist ein Hin und Her. Man will ganz klar auch machen, wenn wir in Venezuela an die Öl- und Gasreserven kommen, dann sind die Chinesen raus, die Iraner sind raus, die Russen sind raus. Und möglicherweise ist das tatsächlich so ein Update der Monroe-Doktrin. Manche sind da eher skeptisch und sagen, naja, das kann eigentlich gar nicht gehen. Und überhaupt, wenn man sich in so ein Guerilla-Krieg verstricken würde, da ist sehr viel Dschungel und so. Das ist nicht so, dass man da ein paar Bomben wirft und dann hat man die Mächtigen getroffen und kann dort einen Regime-Change vorziehen. Das ist ja auf keinen Fall so. Es heißt dann hier von jemandem vielmehr, spiegelt die Dynamik wieder, dass wir es auch in der Trump-Administration wiederum mit konkurrierenden Fraktionen zu tun haben. Nämlich da gibt es die einen, die sagen, wir müssen da unbedingt rein. Ja, jetzt müssen wir unbedingt den Regime-Change herstellen. Und andere sind da wiederum sehr zögerlich. Was dann auch bedeutet, so schreibt Tom O'Connor, dass Trump einmal mehr als der oberste Schiedsrichter dann da ist. Und beide widerstreitende Fraktionen gucken gerade, was wird Daddy wollen? Sollen wir rein oder bleiben wir lieber draußen?
Ja, also ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Es hat ja auch viel damit zu tun, wie viel Energie Amerika so braucht. Derzeit gibt es ja so einen kleinen Slowdown beim Thema KI und so. Vielleicht gewidiert man doch das ein oder andere. Ich folge da immer, oder was heißt ich folge? Ich achte immer darauf, was Eric Schmidt sagt, weil Eric Schmidt übertreibt immer komplett. Entweder erklärt er für irgendeine Konferenz, dass wir jetzt zehnmal so viel Energie wie überhaupt brauchen. Oder die sind ja alle verrückt geworden im Silicon Valley, viel zu viel Geld und so. Also es ist immer, kann man so ein bisschen kleinen Indikator, aber mal sehen. Ich glaube, spätestens dann ist auch China und Taiwan nochmal anders zu verhandeln. Ja. So, Richard Crinell gehört zu einer Gang, also zur Regierungsgang, weshalb die New York Times Sean McCreech darüber aufklärt, dass es Donald Trumps Big Gay Government gibt. Kommt natürlich so ein bisschen vorschlaghammermäßig daher, aber ich möchte es wie folgt rahmen. Wir haben einen Diskurs darüber, dass Frauen nicht so richtig in der Geschichte zur Geltung kamen, weil sie von Männern unterdrückt wurden. War ganz einfach gesprochen. Und die Frage ist, warum eigentlich? Und eine funktionale Begründung in verschiedenen soziologischen Angeboten lautet, Männer möchten es gern unter sich in einem offenes Visier-Faustkampf, der Stärkere setzt sich durch, CEO-Wettstreit klären. Und es wäre ein bisschen hinderlich, wenn man sich die Leute, mit denen man eigentlich klüngeln möchte und so, wenn man sich so in die verliebt, weil dann kommt so eine emotionale Ebene rein, die ist blöd und die kann man vor allem schlecht berechnen. Deshalb für Frauen allenfalls die Sekretärin stelle, aber die war so weiträumig in der CEO-Etage, so oder als Flugbegleiterin, wie auch immer. Also das, was wir heute der KI unterstellen. Allenfalls Assistenz, das war ja die Rolle der Frauen. Und die Frage ist ja, warum gibt es Homophobie? Und ich möchte ganz sagen, unter denselben Gesichtspunkten. Männer möchten gerne die Streite um Macht mit offenem Visier und im Faustkampf klären. Und es wäre blöd, wenn da so eine emotionale Ebene reinkommt, die man nicht sieht und nicht berechen kann. Nämlich jemand ist in jemanden verliebt oder so. Weshalb heterosexuelle Männer als Mehrheit eben Frauen ausschließen aus ihren Klüngeln und schwule Männer. Und unter diesen Gesichtspunkten finde ich es wahnsinnig interessant, jetzt einfach diesen Text zu lesen. Weil hier wird ja genau das beschrieben, weshalb man so ein Homophobie-Reflex historisch ausgebildet hat. Oder, wie die katholische Kirche gleich alles untersagte, selbst die Selbstbefriedigung, also bloß keine Verquickung. In diesem Text wird jetzt auch nicht über emotionale Beziehungen gesprochen, sondern einfach nur das Anhäufen schwuler Männer und wie sie sich so organisieren. Das aber finde ich schon sehr trifftig so. Also ich war ein bisschen überrascht, dass der Text so erschien. Ich habe dann auf Google Maps mal nachgeschaut. Es gibt ein NED, Net Club, der hat sehr schöne Bilder und der Text beginnt damit. Es war der letzte Mittwoch im Juli und viele der wichtigsten Persönlichkeiten Washingtons hielten sich im Net Club auf, einem privaten Club gleich um die Ecke vom Weißen Haus. Und der ist so krass um die Ecke des Weißen Hauses. Also das Weiße Haus steht da auf einer grünen Fläche und die grüne Fläche hat vorne ein Tor und der Weg zum Tor ist schon enger als die grüne Fläche des Weißen Hauses, weil quasi auf dem Gebiet dieses Parks, in dem der Weiße Haus steht, ist zum Beispiel dieser Net Club. Also das ist sozusagen, würde mich nicht wundern, wenn ein Tunnel direkt dahin führt. Also da hängen die so alle rum, das ist so der an Kaffee Einstein oder wie auch immer. Und sie sind dort und in einem braunen Ledersessel sitzt ein hochrangiger Beamter des Energieministeriums, Charles Moran. Wir fragen uns, wer ist denn das? Und im Text steht wörtlich, der 44-jährige Moran ist der Pascha einer neuen Machtgruppe in der Hauptstadt. Doppelpunkt, den schwulen Männern der Trump-Regierung. Also wir lesen hier New York Times, ne? So, das sind die A-Gays, also A-Gay wie A-Team, aber A-Gays. Ach so. Sie sind also offen schwul und sehr stolz darauf, für den Präsidenten zu arbeiten, also Trump spezifisch. Das hat also schon auch Abgrenzung zu den bisherigen Republikanern zu tun. Sie üben überall in der Stadt Einfluss auf. Steht hier im Pentagon, im Außenministerium, im Weißen Haus, im Kennedy Center. Kennedy Center, Richard Grinnell hat ja da die Leitung. Wir sind wie Visa, sagt Moran, überall dort, wo man sein möchte. Also die tragen es wirklich ganz offen, dass sie hier so gangmäßig organisiert sind. Zu den weiteren Agays gehört Tony Fabrizio, der langjährige Meinungsforscher des Präsidenten. Trent Moors, ein scheidender stellvertretender Assistent des Präsidenten. Richard Grinnell, der heute das Kennedy Center leitet. Jakob Hellberg, ein Unterstaatssekretär. Und es gibt viele Beispiele, wie sie hier noch sagen. Sie sind schwul, aber Republikaner. Und das so ungefähr seit 2015. Es gab 2016 die Rede von Peter Thiel auf dem Parteitag. Das war, glaube ich, sogar der Nominierungsparteitag von Donald Trump, bei dem er ja sagte, ich bin stolz, schwul zu sein. Ich bin stolz, Republikaner zu sein. Aber vor allem bin ich stolz, Amerikaner zu sein. Und da saßen schon relativ viele, organisiert im Sinne von, da weht jetzt ein neuer Wind und so, und haben gedacht, wow, jetzt wird aber ausgeboot und so. Und nein, der Saal feierte das natürlich, weil das Peter Thiel-Mysterium sozusagen, ja, dann nehmen wir jetzt den. So, der bringt so einiges Mysteriöses mit, ist halt schwul, so ungefähr. Es gab sehr großen Applaus auf diese Rede und daraufhin, ah ja, okay, ist also akzeptabel. Da ging sozusagen los, dass sie in der ersten Amtszeit schon, aber jetzt in der zweiten, sich halt da richtig ein Nest gebaut haben. 2019 steht hier im Text über Namen Moran, die Locke-Cabin-Republicans, die schwule republikanische Gruppe, die er dann komplett auf Maga ausgerichtet hat. Also die kann man einfach namentlich so finden. Und dass er da als Pascha in der New York Times beschrieben wird, vielleicht ist das auch deren Selbstbeschreibung. Also dass die sich einfach selber so machen, das ist unser Pascha da. Es wird auch so beschrieben, wie er da so sitzt, sondern reinweise die Leute einfach so in kleinen Gesprächen dann bei ihm. Der Text wird dann unterbrochen mit einem sehr großen Bild von Scott Besant, dem Finanzminister, der also auch in die Gang gehört.
Also ich meine, die Gender-Theoretikerin Yves Kossowski-Setschwick, die hat ja in ihrer Literaturwissenschaft immer wieder von homosozialen Räumen gesprochen, aber das meinte eigentlich jetzt nicht, dass sich dort schwule Männer bilden in Gruppen, sondern sie meinte, dass also die männliche Strukturen oft davon geprägt sein, dass es so homosoziale Räume entstehen, in denen dann zum Beispiel Frauen nicht stattfinden. Und hier ist aber ja nochmal eine andere Dimension da, wenn es also in dieser Expezitheit ist, wenngleich dir jetzt nicht alle miteinander in irgendwelchen Beziehungen, also Intimenbeziehungen, stehen. Das ist gar nicht das Ding.
Dieser Morin führt also eine Excel-Tabelle, in der dutzende Namen von Mitgliedern mit Titel und wo sie arbeiten drinsteht. Und er sagt, ich finde es toll, wenn ich herausfinde, dass es jemand Neues gibt. Dann wird er direkt kontaktiert und dann eingebunden. Die A-Gays halten meistens zusammen. Also gibt es nur die typischen, aber es gibt erstmal diesen A, ihr seid der Schwul, okay. Also organisieren wir uns. Und er sagt dann auch, ich liebe es, diese Gemeinschaft als Ressource zu haben, als Werkzeug. Und er schildert dann so einen Fall, wie jemand anrief und fragte, hey, haben wir jemanden in dieser und jener Behörde? Und er dann, jaja klar, ich hab mal nachgeguckt. Also das geht schon sehr hart in diese Richter, wo ich mir denke.
Aber wie erklären die das von den New York Times? Weil zunächst einmal ist es ja so, dass jede Partei hat ja zum Beispiel Sprecher für LGBT-Rechte oder hat Untergruppen, Schwule und Lesben bei den Grünen oder die Bundeswehr hat das natürlich auch. Ja, also das ist erstmal was viele Institutionen haben. Aber hier geht es ja irgendwie darüber hinaus, dass man nochmal so ein offenbar stark von PtT geleitetes Interesse hat, dass man sagt, man baut in einer Welt, die ohnehin Clan-artig funktioniert. Also dafür steht ja Trump wie kaum ein anderer.
Dafür steht vor allem Washington.
Ja, baut man jetzt also so eigene Clan-Strukturen auf. Und jetzt könnte man sich fragen, was könnte man als zusammengehörig wahrnehmen? Man könnte zum Beispiel Katholiken zusammenbringen oder so etwas. Und dass man das jetzt über die Sexualität, also die Homosexualität, spielt, ist ja ganz interessant. Weil es ja zunächst mal eine Kategorisierung ist, die in der Politik, gerade weil ja generell da liberale Rechte herrschen, überhaupt kein Thema sein. Das heißt, man wäre jetzt genauso verdurzt, wenn man sagen würde, da treffen sich alle, die blond sind oder so. Aber da aber offenbar hat man da so eine Struktur, durch Pieter Thiel und sowas schon vorgefunden, die man dann anknüpfen kann oder die man erweitern kann.
Also das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Also sie organisieren sich und machen es offen aus, also der Text argumentiert es nicht, er beschreibt einfach nur und ich würde jetzt Schlussfolgern. Zum einen sagen die, der Kampf für die Rechte von Homosexuellen ist im Grunde genommen gewonnen. Aber sie sind alle in Washington DC, der schwulsten Stadt Amerikas, in der sie nicht willkommen sind und vor allem nicht in der schwulen Community.
Ach so, die sind nicht in der schwulen Community.
Die sind nicht in Washington DC willkommen. Das heißt, also klar.
Ja, das ist ja die Debatte, die wir hier auch zunehmend erleben. Also wenn Jens Spahn sagt, er sei schwul, aber nicht queer, dann sagt er natürlich, ich habe mit der LGBT-Community nichts zu tun. Das würden die natürlich auch sagen, wahrscheinlich.
Genau, also Richard Grinnell ist jetzt Vorsitzender dieses Kennedy Centers. Trump ist ja Chairman, aber er fühlt irgendwie die Geschäfte. Dort wurde ja zuletzt Les Miserables oder so aufgeführt, wo sie alle hingesind. Und da saßen also die A-Gays vorne unten nahe dem Bühnenrand.
Die sind wirklich zu Les Miserables.
Oben auf der Tribüne saß Trump mit Melania.
Ja, Trump scheint auch so Musical nahe zu sein.
Ja, genau. Und hereinmarschiert sind dann noch, ich zeige sie dir mal, sehr viele Dragqueens, aber wirklich als Queen aufgezogen, um dieses Zeichen zu setzen. Wir gucken uns jetzt auch dieses Musical an. Also hier gibt es Transpersonen, die es vielleicht sogar auch nur feiern, als Happening machen und jetzt gar nicht in der persönlichen Einstellung. Dann gibt es echte Schwule, aber die echten Schwulen haben auch nichts mit der schwulen Szene von Washington zu tun. Und das alles als Kampffläche Kennedy Center. Also da wird schon ordentlich Linie gezogen und polarisiert, sag ich mal. Dass die sich organisieren, ist aus dieser, wenn man es so liest, jetzt gar nicht so, weil das ist halt eine echte Schicksalsgemeinschaft. Die sind halt schon über Eigenschaften miteinander verbunden.
Vielleicht muss man es so sehen, also die bilden sich natürlich da heraus, weil das absurde ist ja jetzt hier, für die Liberalisierung bezüglich Adoption, Ehe und so weiter, haben ja nur linke Kräfte immer gesorgt. Also wenn die Rechten sich nicht dagegen gestellt haben, okay, aber sie haben das nicht vorangetrieben. Das heißt auch, was in Deutschland ja da errungen wurde, ist ja, Grünen SPD zu verdanken und Merkel hat dann irgendwann gesagt, ja, dann macht verdammt noch mal die Abstimmung, ich stimme dagegen, aber macht die mal.
Ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Also das heißt, dass die sich jetzt so offen und all das bekennen, ist ja Resultat eigentlich von linker Politik. Jetzt sagen die aber, meine Identität, meine sexuelle Identität ist aber, auch wenn ich diese Vorteile genieße, die erkämpft wurden von links, nicht gleich mit einer politischen Identität, die man jetzt als demokratisch, also im Sinne von liberal sehen kann, ist nicht progressiv, sondern ich bin für mehr Polizei, für militär und für einen schlanken Staat und Donald Trump und bin schwul.
Und Trump kommt hier ins Bild, weil er ihnen halt wirklich ein positives Angebot gemacht hat. Trump wurde damals schon im Wahlkampf gefragt, wie halten sie sich mit dem Schwulen? Und dann war so die Erzählung, ja, da fühlt sich das sichtlich wohl. Der mag es hier irgendwie. Dann gibt es hier einen kurzen Erinnerung.
Ja, sein Anwalt, ja, auch damals der berühmte in den 80er Jahren.
Ja, The Apprentice. Hat er mal jemanden explizit gefragt, ob er schwul sei. Und daraufhin sagt der Typ ja. Und dann sagt der Trump, ich mag Steak, jemand anderes Spaghetti. Deshalb gibt es in Restaurants Speisekarten. Das ist eine großartige Welt. So, und da wurden die natürlich viel direkter angesprochen, als wenn Merkel jetzt so, naja, gut, okay, machen wir eine Schule für alle, wo das so nebenbei läuft.
Ich hab jetzt einen Clip kürzlich gesehen bei Instagram, da hat Trump erklärt, dass er Gay Weddings mag, weil die viel mehr Geld für Hochzeiten ausgeben.
Genau, weil die viel mehr mieten, also viel mehr Geld ausgeben, viel höhere Budgets haben. Trumps Tanz zu YMCA ist ja sowieso schon legendär, dass er dann sogar mit den Village People zusammen aufgetreten ist. Da werden halt die Signale gesetzt. Und Melania Trump, sie taucht sehr selten auf. Aber immer mal wieder, wenn so Spendenaktionen, Veranstaltungen, die schwulen Republikaner sich im Trump Tower treffen, dann hält sie kurz die Rede und so. Und dann sind alle ganz ergriffen, weil sie natürlich alle so ein Madonna-haftes, das ist unsere Melania und so. Und wie kommt man jetzt in diese Kreise? Also schwul sein alleine reicht nicht. Sie haben ja auch einen Protagonisten, den sie so verfolgen, der leider sagen muss, die begehrteste Einladung für die Magerschwulen steht bei ihm noch aus. Er war noch nie auf Peter Thiels Party. Der macht nämlich immer mal wieder so kleine Versammlungen. Er hat dann eine Villa in der Embassy Row, also auch nicht weit, wo man sich dann trifft. Und viele Schwule in der Trump-Regierung sind sehr von Peter Thiel inspiriert, sagt er. Er war der erste Querdenker, der gewissermaßen die Tür geöffnet hat. Also, die Schwulen sind da präsent. Allerdings müssen sie unter sich bleiben. Das ist ihr Schicksal. Denn auf die Frage hin, was passiert, und die haben dann die Schwulen in der Schwulenszene in Washington, die sie immer rumgefragt haben, was passiert, wenn sie jemanden treffen, der wirklich super aussieht, der ihnen richtig gefällt. Und dann stellen sie fest, das ist so ein A-Gay. Und dann sagt er, er würde von plus zehn sofort auf minus zehn fallen. Also ganz rigoros. Für Trump-Arbeiten geht da gar nicht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sich das noch weiter entwickelt in diese Richtung oder so. Ich könnte mir natürlich auch vorstellen, dass das noch mal so eine Reaktion auch darauf ist, dass ja die Debatten um Identitätspolitik, nachdem die Ehe für alle ja in den westlichen Staaten dann so weitgehend flächendeckend eingeführt war, dass die sich ja dann verlagerte auch sehr stark darauf, dass also zum Beispiel die Binarität von Geschlechtern in Frage gestellt worden oder die radikale Konstruktivität von Geschlechten im Mittelpunkt gestellt worden, also die wirklichen Gender-Diskussionen. Und da gab es ja schon damals auch ein Fremdeln damit, weil ja natürlich dann die Argumentation war, naja, also wir stehen ja schon auf Männer. Das heißt, wir wollen, dass die Geschlechtskategorie ja gerade nicht auflösen. Genau.
Schwule Männer sind immer noch Männer.
Ich glaube, dass, ja und ich glaube, dass das aber quasi, also in diesem, wo diese Debatten gerade so auflappen, das ist eigentlich so 2015, 16, glaube ich, ist das auch noch mal so ein Hinweis darauf, dass dann also sich daraus diese Gegenbewegung oder wie immer man das jetzt bezeichnen will, entstanden ist.
Ja, also der Anteil Homosexueller Menschen ist ja gar nicht so gering. Das heißt, die einfach zu politisch zu ignorieren ist, also macht jetzt keinen wirklichen Sinn so, weshalb ja Trump da auch nie drauf eingestiegen ist. Die Frage der Transsexualität, da sie plötzlich dieses Gebiet eben aufmacht, wie du sagst, zwischenmännlich und weiblich und sei es nur als Weg, wenn man dann kurz bestätigt, ist halt wirklich ein ganz anderes Metier, also wirklich ein ganz anderes politisches Feld. Es ist eine ganz andere Arena, weil die Leute natürlich da auch also andere biografische Entscheidungen schon mal für sich treffen müssen, überhaupt Entscheidungen anstehen, wie auch immer.
Ja.
So, das einfach unter, ja, da geht es halt um Geschlechter oder so zusammenzuführen, ist halt...
Zu wenig, ja.
Ja. Also muss man aber sagen, ja, dieser Text handelt jetzt von schwulen Männern, also von Männern.
Und ich meine, es ist ja auch jetzt nicht eine an sich historisch neue Tatsache, dass der Homosexuelle es nicht auch zum Beispiel mit dem Faschismus gut praktieren kann. Auch das gab es, also zwar gab es den Nazi-Faschismus, der Homosexuelle verfolgt hat und zugleich gibt es aber dann natürlich auch entsprechende Größen innerhalb der Nazi-Riege, von denen das schon an sich bekannt war, zumindest in den Parteistrukturen, auch wenn dann nicht in dieser Weite der Öffentlichkeit, wie das da heute der Fall ist. Also das eine die politische Identität und die sexuelle Identität muss nicht zusammengedacht werden im Sinne von progressiv gleich dies oder das. Was ja auch noch, das fand ich noch ganz interessant, um das noch nachzuschieben, von Gilda Sahebi. Ihr hatte doch da so ein Beispiel, wie Republikaner und Demokraten sich einschätzen. Kannst du dich noch dran erinnern? Weil das wirklich sehr, sehr amüsant war. Und zwar ging es da um die Frage, wie die Demokraten eigentlich auf Republikaner blicken und die Republikaner auf Demokraten. Und genau, hier habe ich es. Da schreibt Gilda Sahebi. Man hat Republikaner nach Demokraten befragt, Demokraten nach Republikanern. Die Befragten glaubten, dass 32 Prozent der Demokraten zu LGBTQ-Community gehörten. In Wahrheit waren es sechs Prozent. Über republikanische Anhängerinnen glaubten die Befragten, dass 38 Prozent von ihnen mehr als eine Viertelmillion Dollar im Jahr verdienen. Hier lag der wahre Anteil bei zwei Prozent. Also da haben wir wieder diese Projektionen in alle Richtungen.
Ja, das ist alles rein virtuell. Das ist alles nicht gut.
Virtuell ist das Stichwort. Du hast vielleicht Aufnahmen gesehen vom Konzert, von den Konzerten, die Will Smiths in Europa gegeben hat.
Nein, tatsächlich nicht.
Ah ja, Andy Bayo hat auf Waxie ein Artikel geschrieben, der heißt Will Smiths Konzert-Crowds are real, but AI is blurring the lines. Es geht um ein einminütiges Video eines Will Smiths Konzerts, das für Aufsehen sorgt. Sehr viele große Medienhäuser haben darüber berichtet und sagen, das ist doch fake, das sind keine richtigen Fans und das sind doch irgendwelche falschen Schilder, die man dann sieht. Ich empfehle einfach mal dem Link zu folgen zu diesem Artikel, denn dort werden Bilder miteinander verglichen, da kann man sich Kurzvideos ansehen. Also dieser Autor geht sehr in die Analyse rein, was sich jetzt nur wörtlich wiedergeben kann, aber man muss die Bilder vielleicht mal gesehen haben. Tatsächlich sieht das so aus, da sind Leute, die in die Kamera, die nach vorne blicken, die irgendwie so ein bisschen verschwommen, aber auch wieder so zum Teil merkwürdig konturiert aussehen. Sie haben so Schilder in der Hand, ein Paar. Bedankt sich dafür, dass Will Smiths ihnen Mut gemacht hat, sie so den Krebs überwinden konnte. Man denkt, naja, also bitte, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Es ist aber wahr. Und dieser Antibio sieht sich das genauer an und sagt, die Menschenmassen sind echt. Jede Person, die sie in dem Video oben sehen, stammt ursprünglich aus echtem Filmmaterial, von echten Fans, das bei mehreren Konzerten von Will Smiths während seiner jüngsten Europatournee aufgenommen wurde. Also man hat natürlich verschiedene Aufnahmen, hat die zusammengepackt und hat dann ein Konzert rausgepickt, wo er auf der Bühne performt. Aber der Rest ist so zusammengeschnitten. Der Hauptauftritt von Will Smiths stammt von einem Festival in Frankreich. Und dann hat man verschiedene Aufnahmen des Publikums von den Festivals, auf denen Will Smiths aufgetreten ist, genommen. Was ist aber jetzt nun passiert? Man sieht also, wie gesagt, dieses Paar zum Beispiel, dass man den Krebs überwunden hat, weil man irgendein Will Smiths-Lied als Mut mitgenommen hat. In einem heute von Die Independent veröffentlichten Artikel verweist Musikredakteurin Royce O'Connor auf das Paar als eindeutigen Beweis für die KI-Generierung. Zitat, eine andere Aufnahme zeigt die Knöchel eines Mannes, die zusammen mit einem Schild, auf dem You Can Make It steht, verschwommen erscheinen. Du kannst es schaffen, hat mir geholfen, den Krebs zu überleben. Danke Will. Die Frau vor ihm scheint seine Hand zu halten, aber das Stirnband der Frau hinter ihr befindet sich irgendwie über ihrem Handgelenk. Also alles stimmt nicht so richtig zusammen. Aber dann an die Bio, das Paar ist echt. Es gibt zwei gute Fotos von ihnen auf Will Smiths Instagram-Account in einer Diashow mit Fotos und Videos vom Festival in Bern. Sie können sie in diesem Video aus Will Smiths Instagram-Post sehen, das unten eingefügt ist. Also hier muss man sich das dann genau ansehen. Was ist also passiert? Will Smiths Team hat offenbar mehrere kurze KI-Bild-zu-Video-Clips produziert. YouTube hat die daraus resultierende Shorts-Montage nachbearbeitet. Er sagt, wir müssen erst mal mit YouTube beginnen. Will Smiths Teams hat dasselbe Video auch auf Instagram und Facebook hochgeladen. Da sieht es aber deutlich besser aus als auf YouTube. Ohne den verschmierten Glanz und dieser unheimlichen Details. Jede Linie ist schärfer und übertriebener, was besonders bei Aufnahmen der Menge mit Gesichtszügen und zuvor unscharfen Fans auffällt. Das Instagram-Material ist besser, obwohl einige der Zuschau-Clips immer noch Probleme aufweisen. Wie sich herausstellt, hat YouTube in den letzten zwei Monaten still und leise mit der Nachbearbeitung von YouTube-Shorts-Videos experimentiert. Videos wurden geschärft und von Rauschen befreit, was oft zu unschönen Ergebnissen führte. Das heißt, du hast bei YouTube was veröffentlicht und die haben selbst nochmal irgendetwas da geändert. Gen-AI bezieht sich in der Regel auf Technologien wie Transformer und große Sprachmodelle, die relativ neu sind. Upscaling bezieht sich in der Regel darauf, eine Auflösung zu nehmen und sie bei einer höheren Auflesung gut aussehen zu lassen. Dabei wird weder Gen-AI verwendet noch ein Upscaling durchgeführt. Es wird die Art von maschinellem Lernen verwendet, die sie beispielsweise bei der computergestützten Fotografie auf Smartphones erleben und die Auflösung wird nicht verändert. Das ist also die eine Sache, die stattgefunden hat. Zum anderen ist es so, dass das Team von Will Smiths Fotos genommen hat und sagte, die gefallen uns. Nur, wir können ja nicht einfach ein Foto einblenden. Wir müssen die animieren zu so einem Ein-Sekunden-Video, dass dann gerade dieses Paar, das das Schild hochstellt, anfängt zu lächeln oder so. Und das bauen wir auch noch mit da ein. Also hat man nicht in dem Sinne gefaked, dass man sagt, wir generieren irgendwelche Fans, die da stehen und haben merkwürdige Plakate in der Hand, sondern sowohl die Automatisierung bei YouTube, die eingesetzt hat, wie auch das Vorgehen von Will Smiths Team, haben dafür gesorgt, dass es so komisch aussieht, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir es mit Echtheit zu tun haben. Was also bedeutet, plurring the lines, was also bedeutet, ist, dass wir jetzt in so ein Zeitalter eintreten, wo wir gar nicht mehr sagen können, na, da ist was gefaked und da ist echt, sondern es ist überhaupt, es verschwimmt alles. Hier heißt das, praktisch alle Kommentatoren auf YouTube, Reddit und X glauben, dass es sich um gefälschte Aufnahmen von falschen Fans handelt, die von Will Smiths Team erstellt wurden, um eine glanzlose Tournee aufzubessern. Wie die Gesichter im Video ist auch die Wahrheit verschwommen. Die Menschenmengen waren echt, aber die Videos wurden manipuliert. Zuerst von Will Smiths Team und dann ohne zu fragen von YouTube. Wir können über die Ethik der Verwendung eines Bild-zu-Video-Modells zur Animation von Fotos auf diese Weise diskutieren, aber ich denke, dass es sich deutlich von dem unterscheidet, was die meisten Leute Will Smiths hier vorgeworfen haben. Die Verwendung von generierten KI-Videos, um eine ausverkaufte Menge begeisterter Fans vorzutäuschen. Das bedeutet eigentlich, dass sich da so alles verschiebt, wenn wir plötzlich solche Bearbeitungen erleben. Und man kann das da in diesen Bildern, die die Bio zeigt, wirklich sehr gut nachvollziehen. Und es prägt sich dadurch natürlich auch so eine neue Ästhetik ein. Also wie man plötzlich glaubt, Gesichter wahrnehmen zu müssen oder wie man glaubt, dass Gesichter so aussehen.
Wir haben mal einen Clip gespielt von diesem Teller-Magier Las Vegas und so weiter, der hat so einen Podcast Sunday School.
Ja.
Und der beschreibt es auch. Es wiederholt sich jetzt nochmal, was wir schon mal hatten. Nämlich, dass es hieß, ich habe hier einen Brief des Königs. Und der sieht ja nach was aus. Also es ist auch ein Brief des Königs. Bis man dann gelernt hat, ne, nur weil es aufgeschrieben ist, ist es noch lange nicht wahr. Und dieser Umgang mit Texten, also das dann irgendwann wichtig war. Erstens, wer hat ihn geschrieben? Zweitens, wer hat ihn vorbeigebracht? Wer kann sicherstellen, dass es vom König ist und so? Das wiederholt sich jetzt. Also man kann den Bildern einfach gar nicht mehr vertrauen, da einfach alles einfach generiert werden kann. Und ja, auf der einen Seite Teufels Küche, auf der anderen Seite historisch jetzt nicht einmalig. Mal gucken, wie weit man es noch treibt. Es gab ja den ersten Vorwurf an Gavin Newsom, der sich nämlich kürzlich auch in so einer Conan-artigen Heldenpose zeigte, dass er sich jetzt auch ein bisschen zu weit auf die Ich-mach-s-wie-Trump hinauswagt. Nämlich nicht nur in Großbuchstaben zu twittern und so den Joke aufzugreifen, sondern sich tatsächlich ästhetisch zu verherrlichen. Und da müssen die auch noch Diskussionen führen, inwieweit unter dem Gouverneurs-Twitter-Account des echten Gavin Newsom, Chef der fünfgroßen Volkswirtschaft der Welt, jetzt plötzlich AI-Slop auftaucht und so.
Nur frage ich mich jetzt, wenn das noch in den Kinderschuhen steckt und deswegen noch diese Fehler passieren, da bin ich mir sicher, wird die Rechenleistung vieles noch bringen und werden entsprechende Programmierer einiges beheben können. Dass man also in einer Situation eigentlich ist, wo ständig eigentlich eine Inszeniertheit, eine Programmiertheit mit reinkommt, die ja eigentlich diesen Realitätsbezug so weit verfreundet, dass dann auch eigentlich die Frage ist, warum braucht man ihn überhaupt noch? Also warum ist die Referenz noch da? Also man ist offenbar nicht zynisch genug zu sagen, man generiert einfach Fans, die irgendwelche Plakate hochhalten, sondern man braucht noch mal den Realitätsbezug offenbar da. Aber dann ist es so sehr manipuliert schon, dass es sich auch von der Realität wieder löst. Also ich weiß natürlich, jedes Bild ist inszeniert. Und ein Fotograf, der nicht mit AI arbeitet, kann natürlich mit Lampen einen toll aussehen lassen oder schrecklich aussehen lassen, je nachdem, was gewünscht ist. Und hier aber haben wir ja noch mal so eine andere Komponente drin. Vor allem, wenn noch mal das über das, was die Creator eigentlich intendiert haben, hinausgeht, also YouTube selbst noch mal eine Manipulation vornimmt, die ich ja erst gar nicht gewünscht haben, aber plötzlich würde ich in der Filmanalyse, weiß ich nicht, ein bisschen gelber aussehen oder ein bisschen klarer konturiert.
Ja, also klar, wenn das noch jemand anders macht mit deinem Material, kannst du ja nicht mal drauf verweisen, aber das ist doch mein Kanal. Also wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, Wolfgang, du hast doch mal das und das über diesen und jeden Film gesagt, und du sagst dann, ne, das hat jemand gefaket, guck dir nochmal meine Originalfilmanalys an, aber selbst die ist dann gefakt oder der YouTube-UHL.
Also diese Artikel von Andy Baio konnte ja jetzt nur geschrieben werden, weil offenbar ein solches Tool bei Instagram noch nicht war. Da konnte er sagen, hier war das zwar auch schon manipuliert von dem Team von Will Smiths, aber da war noch nicht die YouTube-Bearbeitung dabei.
Also Google macht sehr viele Experimente, hinsichtlich Komprimierung und so, aber dass sie jetzt in die Richtung gehen, ist natürlich qualitativ wirklich was Neues und auch nicht gut.
Zum Schluss noch Musik, Tchaikovsky.
Sehr gut. Aber nicht schön.
Doch, doch, sonst hättest du dich ja nicht ausgewählt. Aber jetzt nicht große Symphonie, nicht Klavierkonzert, sondern nur Klavier. Der südkoreanische Pianist Jun-Chan Lim hat ein Werk von Tchaikovsky eingespielt, das ja nicht so den besten Ruf hat. Denn es handelt sich da um so ein Auftragswerk. Tchaikovsky wurde gebeten, für eine Musikzeitschrift Stücke zu komponieren, und zwar jeden Monat eins. The Seasons, also jeder Monat, bekommt ein Stück. Und es sollte auch so komponiert sein, dass das, naja, ich will nicht sagen Laien, aber Leute, die gut auf dem Klavier sind, spielen können, und die müssen jetzt nicht die absoluten Profis sein.
Also für eine Zeitschrift komponiert heißt, man hat die Partituren abgedruckt und den Leuten geschickt.
Ja, das war eine Musikfachzeitschrift dann schon für ein besonderes Publikum.
Ja, aber man hat ja keinen Tontrecker mitgeschickt.
Ja, ja, genau, genau.
Also muss man es ja spielen können.
Also, dass man es für den Haus gebraucht auch spielen konnte. Man muss natürlich gewisses Talent haben, aber es ist jetzt nicht so virtuos, wie man das bei Tchaikovsky im Klavierkonzert hat. Ja, da könnte man jetzt nicht sagen, da begebe ich mich mal dran, das lerne ich mal. Hier sind also Stücke, die für Leute, die schon jahrelang vielleicht Kavier spielen, durchaus spielbar sind, ohne dass man jetzt Konzertpianist sein muss. Und dadurch, dass das so Auftragswerke waren, hat man sie eigentlich nicht so sehr beachtet. Und Junshan Lim machte aber jetzt aus diesen Charakterstücken wahnsinnig viel. Nämlich, er versucht hier schon, eine andere Tiefe einzubringen. Sicherlich auch dadurch, dass er gewisse Verzögerungen forciert, auch ein bisschen bedeutungsschwerer, dass er alles anspielt. Also es hat mitunter den Charakter von Salonmusik, möchte man fast sagen. Aber er führt diese Salonmusik eigentlich dann weg hin, mehr zum Charakterstück. Und das gefällt mir sehr gut. Es sind Stücke, die stark mit Klangmalerei spielen. Also wir hören zum Beispiel Lärchen oder wir hören Schlittenfahren. Das sind Lieder, die eine liethafte Melodie haben. Sie sind auch nicht lang. 4-5 Minuten sind die lang. Und auch wenn das mitunter so ein bisschen formelhafte musikalische Genrebilder sind, hat mir das äußerst gut gefallen. Denn die Interpretation, und da ist ja doch das Entscheidende, was bringt der Pianist nochmal mit ein, führen nämlich diese Stücke weit weg und werten sie nochmal in ganz anderer Weise auf. Also ohnehin ist Tchaikovsky natürlich ein wichtiger Komponist, auch für Klavier. Und dass man aber hier sich diesen Werken annimmt, finde ich eigentlich eine sehr gute Herangehensweise. Und so kann man dann durch die Jahreszeiten und durch die Monate hindurchgehen. In dem Booklet hat dann Junsham Lim auch nochmal aufgeschrieben, was er sich zu den Stücken denkt. Also er schreibt dann beispielsweise Folgendes. Im zweiten Stück, Karneval, tummeln sich ausgelassene Menschen, necken einander, tanzen, trinken Bier und torkeln umher. Sie vollführen slavische Tänze, purzeln übereinander, stehen wieder auf, stecken Fähnchen in den schneebedeckten Hang, den Kindern immer wieder hinabrodeln, andere Leute zeigen Kunststücke mit einem Treuker Pferdeschlitten. Am Ende verschwindet die ganze lustige Gesellschaft ohne Anflug von Reue. So charakterisiert er das zweite Stück. Oder das dritte Stück Lied der Lärche übertrifft sogar noch das gleichnamige Stück von Klinker Balakirev. Eine klagende Melodie wird vorgetragen, die linke Hand antwortet mit ruhigem Gleichmut, während die rechte Hand Tränen der Tragik vergießt. Also sehr schöne Worte auch für ein beeindruckendes Spiel. Eine CD, die ich sehr empfehlen kann. Vielleicht auch gerade für die, die sonst noch nicht so viel Klaviermusik hören. Hier bekommt man auf jeden Fall einen sehr schönen Eindruck davon Tchaikovsky The Seasons von Jun-Chan Lim.
Dann hören wir das alle mal und haben gute Laune im September.
Wir sehen uns dann im September im Live-Salon oder hören uns dann dort?
Genau, wir hören uns da. Tragt euch in die Stadtführung ein, dann sehen wir uns da schon. Ansonsten hören wir uns Ende des Monats.
Und die Stadtführung ist als Link jetzt unten drinnen?
Die ist hier in den Show Notes verlinkt. Da kann man gleich oben sich einfach anmelden.
Bis dann.